foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
and competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter is
Envy a wing a blitz Jersey Maxime hey
buddy I love you welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the wheels came off wow she
just took down Hikaru Nakamura and look
at her she is jubilant entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion
we win we win oh my God my friends it's
the 2023 Pro chess League which team can
Rise Above the Rest they won't be able
to do it alone
it's a new day it's a new double header
it is the pro chess League I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend my co-commentator in crime
Grandmaster Daniel narodisky Dania we've
had epic matches throughout the week
we'll have two more in store for
everybody today
we will indeed Robert I thought you did
a fantastic job yesterday with Danny I
was on the edge of my seat and I'm sure
that nothing will change today it's been
an epic first week and what better way
to cap it off than with two more
wonderful high-level matches
for sure well the season has just begun
but it will cap off in playoffs and
that's going to be at the end of a five
week regular season's elimination Swiss
you win three matches you make the
playoffs you lose three you're out but
Donya the All-Star Game the arena Royale
March 24th I'm guessing you'll be
playing in that
I don't know why you would think that
Robert playing I'm just a commentator
come on uh let's not talk about the
Carolina cobras and their week one
performance but in all seriousness mark
your calendars ladies and gentlemen
because you've got non-stop action for
three months the finals will be coming
your way in May May 11th to 14th and the
end of March is the playoffs so you've
got action evenly distributed make sure
that you block off work that you don't
schedule brunch because you will not
want to miss this action
playoffs we're talking about playoffs no
right now we're going to talk about
yesterday's matches uh they were two
epics it was just the first week of the
season but the blitz they stormed back
against mgd1 to take it in tie breaks 10
F9 F and Donya the Gotham Knights Hikaru
not off to the right foot in game one
but he scored three straight victories
to lead them to a 9-7 match win over the
Berlin bears
well just like a sports game in a PCL
match you need to win essentially four
quarters and that's what we saw
yesterday in the Gotham Knights match
yukaro loses the first game it's a
shocking loss but he maintains his
composure and Gotham shows incredible
resilience and speaking of resilience
the blitz what a comeback we saw we've
already seen a couple of near comebacks
I mean the Spanish Maniacs rims they
came oh so close and the blitz complete
the first crazy comeback and Robert I
will bet a silver dollar that it's far
from the last oh it certainly will not
be we may see more today but something
we saw yesterday was one of the biggest
Smiles I've ever seen because while
Hikaru Nakamura was upset Josephine
heinemann she tweeted I can't believe I
just beat Hikaru Nakamura three
exclamation points I think she could
have used 33 and that wouldn't be enough
but unfortunately my team still lost the
match but we will come back stronger
next week and shouting out the Berlin
Bears that's her team's so I've done it
what can you say about her game against
Hikaru well first of all I can say that
that was an excellent game Hikaru was
better at some point but Josephine kept
the pressure she kept her hopes up and
when things mattered most she delivered
several moves in a row and I can tell
you firsthand how hard it is to keep
your composure when you even have an
inkling of a possibility of beating
Hikaru and this is what the PCL is all
about yes the match scores are the most
important but we're also looking at the
individual players and from a Fan's
perspective you get to look at so many
players so you haven't seen before
develop new allegiances and develop new
players that you're going to be watching
for years to come and that's what we saw
yesterday
it is the nature of the pro chess league
and you know Hikaru Nakamura he's hard
to beat in any time control this format
or the pro chess league is the rapid
time control Everybody Plays everybody
that's good and fun it's a tight Patrol
of 10 minutes plus two second increment
and the first team to eight and a half
points wins yesterday we saw tie breaks
you just replay those round four
pairings it's Ultra exciting but Dania I
think what I like best about the pro
chess league is that everybody plays the
entire other team and that means
Josephine heinemann a strong player in
her own right she doesn't use usually
get to play against a card Nakamura
Magnus Carlsen and the top guns but she
did yesterday and she delivered
yes and we're not just saying it board
four is just as important as board War
board one is just as important as board
two all boards play four games every
Point counts equally and that's what
makes this format so exciting you need
to reach eight and a half points you can
do it in three rounds we saw that in
only one match so far it was a complete
blowout by the India yogis against the
Capybaras who are going to be facing a
pretty easy team next week uh forget
which team in particular but it's
exceedingly rare and normally the entry
goes down to the very very last game
Robert
it doesn't even the team that qualified
uh the Spanish Maniac shrimps they
almost took down the Norway gnomes that
was an epic Wayne Jones wins on a mouse
slip blunder uh by the maniac shrimps
dude that was crazy it was crazy that
was one of the craziest finishes I've
ever seen but we may see more of the
same today because there's a lot of
parody in this league it's kind of like
having a salary cap there's a rating cap
and the Saint Louis archbishops they
have been a winner of the pro chess
league three times they take on the
Shanghai tigers and first of all I love
the logo of the Tigers but that team has
a lot of bite from top to bottom of the
roster you do not want to mess with many
of those Chinese Superstars and then of
course we followed that up with the
Croatia Bulldogs led by a godmother he's
the captain of that Squad and the
California unicorns the team you know a
thing or three about
I do indeed and I've played for them for
a year or three I have an emotional
connection to the unicorns ultimately
this year I decided that mile agencies
lie in uh the city in which I reside but
my heart is still part of my heart is
still in California uh it's a great team
speaking of great teams St Louis is
obviously a stellar they are a maiden
State they need no introduction but do
not sleep on the Shanghai Tigers because
they might leave their cage if you close
your eyes for one second too long
I of course I saw I heard you mentioned
a cage and the Tigers they will not be
caged today they will not be tamed
unless the St Louis archbishops bring
their best stuff and they have a
fantastic roster spearheaded by Fabiano
caruana and lenier Dominguez those 27 40
plus super Grand Masters that is going
to be a tough team and we do want to
note uh it has been a difficult time in
the Chess World the St Louis team has
removed Alejandra Ramirez from their
roster it was their decision but they
would like to focus on the chest today
and look at this lineup done I'm
actually looking at Alice Lee that is
The X Factor for me for the St Louis
architecture
Alice Lee is a Phenom she is one to
watch He's incredibly young she improves
every single year and she's just the
sort of person none of the top
Grandmasters want to face she's got
great openings and yesterday I made a
brief appearance Robert and I mentioned
some of those I AMS and women's GMS and
you might look at their feed a rating
and you might say yeah they're probably
going to go out of four no they're not
they're vastly underrated and they
actually in many cases will be the X
Factor for the team but obviously St
Louis is stacked at the top caruana and
lanyard Dominguez any team with those
two players is bound to go far
and the archbishops are captained by
Nemo so they have found her she will
hope that her Squad can get another Pro
chess league title but they first face
the Shanghai tigers and when you mess
with the Chinese Squad you better bring
your A game because we look way ye e is
the highest rated player on the team but
they have ju and June the women's world
champion and that is going to be a tough
task you look all across the lineup and
Dania I see 1996 for a rating of a
player that's as scary as it gets
because you know that these Chinese
players you're asked that question who's
most underrated it might be Ying Zhu Mao
listen I I would I think I'd rather
prefer to see a two in front of that
name maybe
2996. that would be less scary than
1996. obviously Chinese players uh they
don't often in many cases have an
opportunity to play internationally and
so in many cases they're vastly
underrated and I think everybody in the
Chess World knows that so each and every
player on this roster is very solid
they've got Wei they've got Youth and
they've got experience nihua has been
around for decades he's maintained a
rating in the high 2600s and obviously
uh the Women's World Champion you and
noon she needs absolutely no
introduction Robert these teams all
across the board are so well built and
I'm just impressed with the work that
the captains and the managers have done
uh across the board to assemble teams
that really have a shot
yeah some teams have a top heavy lineup
others are more balanced we saw
yesterday with the Gotham Knights
they're being top heavy with Hikaru
Nakamura and Lim lay and then the Berlin
Bears they had those 2600 so let's talk
about roster construction because there
is a rating cap in the Pro chess League
you have to have 25 50 average rating
maximum but this is a big caveat that
the players over 2700 count as 2700 So
Magnus Carlson at 28.50 plus counts as
2700 and also women over 23.50 they
count as 23.50 it is good to have G1
June on your roster Donya because she
doesn't actually hurt your rating cap in
fact she does only counts as 23.50 you
want the strongest players in the world
on your team you absolutely do and that
means the job of the manager is not just
to contact every player in the top 20
you actually have to strategize you have
to think about which players are better
and rapid and you have to make uh
serious decisions mathematical based
decisions adding up average ratings and
testing out various lineups across the
week and you don't have much room for
error because three strikes Robert and
you are out so some teams they're
basically going to stick with the same
lineup week to week they're going to put
Faith in four of the same players others
are going to make changes and we will
see what strategies these two teams
adopt but it is their first match Robert
and the teams that they are debuting
this week are both incredibly
scintillating
I'm excited for this one because you
look at their four board lineup and you
see no weak links on board four for St
Louis Archbishop Alice Lee our rating
may look like it's 2284 but that was a
few months ago she's already up over
2300 she's scoring I am Norms but Donya
lenier Dominguez that's the big name for
St Louis the big name for Shanghai is
Wei Yi but look at those middle boards
very evenly matched I'd say because
boards two and three for each side are a
powerful Grandmaster and I think the
biggest X Factor for the archbishops is
Nicholas theodoro now I won't lie
Nicholas and I we've become friends over
the last year I greatly respect this
chess he's a monster Blitz player and he
can be I mean he is just a streaky
shooter he defeated LaVon aronian in the
Olympiad with the black pieces we all
know what Nico is capable of when the
stars align on the other side he also
can play badly he can sometimes be
unstable so he is a big X Factor for St
Louis and Robert as we talked about it's
an all hands on deck effort yes one
player can carry the team Magnus Carlson
did that with the Canada chess Bros but
that is rare and most of the time
everybody has to contribute at least a
little bit
for sure and we'll see that and even in
the first round of action because that's
when the pairings are most lopsided we
start with board one against board four
and for Alice Lee I I've mentioned her
as The X Factor for the St Louis
archbishops she gets the white piece
against weihi who is a super Grandmaster
and has been since he was like two years
old and then on the other side of things
you see Nicholas theodoro he gets the
white piece of his Jew and Jude that's
an all Grandmaster matchup uh but I what
I like about Shanghai Dania is Lou
yaping board four that player is rated
nearly 2 500. that is not an easy task
for linear Dominguez as strong and solid
as he is no not at all and especially
with the black pieces in a rapid game
but lanyard I think he's got the right
opening repertoire for the PCL he plays
the night off he plays combative
openings with both colors and he really
needs to try to gain chances and strike
with black but you're right Robert it
feels like Wei has been a grand master
for decades I feel like a meme could be
built out of it you see the Roman Empire
and Vesuvius erupting over Pompeii wait
he's still a grand master fast forward
to the age of mobile phones uh and the
iPhone comes out wayi is still a grand
master he is experienced and uh the
Tigers I mean they've got some very
level-headed solid players they're going
to be hard to bring down
oh I mean we see one of those players on
screen International Master Louis yeping
rated 2500 that's board four for the
Shanghai tigers and that's because they
have Jew one June every team must have a
woman playing for them in each and every
week and she is 25.50 plus but only
counts as 23.50 against the rating cap
but Leonard Dominguez he has been over
27.50 it feels like for a decade himself
one of the best players in the world one
of the best prepared players in the
world a former second for both veslin to
paulov and Fabiano caruana he is playing
now for the United States and he's off
playing a queen's game and accepted one
of the most underrated players as well
then you're so so good I mean his play
is classy he uh he is just one to watch
he always does well it seems in the U.S
championship and here we go seat belts
fastened I say this every time ladies
and gentlemen and I mean it we are off
to the races a queen's gamut accepted is
on the board and pretty conventional
stuff here so far Robert C5 and black
often follows this up with B5 if of
course white does not prevent that with
A4
right and that's a big question mark
because A4 it's a committal move it
gives up the B4 square but no we're not
seeing that Leonard Dominguez he is as
professional a player as he gets what
does that mean it means he does not take
unnecessary risks with the black pieces
against a player that is 2500 rated now
let's say I respect you if I am going to
make a draw so be it he's not playing
for a draw but he is not taking those
risks the speculative sacrifices that
other top players do you're absolutely
right and as a top player it's important
not to overdo it you're gonna get your
chances in a 10 minute game in a
classical game uh particularly in a
must-win situation I think we would see
a sharper opening such as a king's
Indian or a grunfeld but uh within the
context of a 10 plus two game even if
the position is symmetrical you are
likely to get at least some chances to
unbalance the game so lanyard is not
going to force matters he's going to
play what he's comfortable with and he's
going to start by equalizing and only
then think about gaining the advantage
but I like the way the Chinese
International Master is handling the
situation here White's position is ultra
solid the bishop could come out to F3
Robert the knight from D2 could jump
into C4 and right now the battle
squarely revolves around Queen side and
central control with both Kings in
complete and total comfort
yeah we're gonna see play on the C file
playing the D5 is the only two open
files but I like what you're saying with
the bishop coming out to F3 for white at
the right moment perhaps like it's a
little bit more activity thanks to the
bishop being on the longest diagonals
the B2 Bishop is better than E7 Bishop a
White's light score Bishop likely will
take advantage of its counterpart as
well so it's small pluses here for
yipping Lou but I I or Louis pink excuse
me but I I should say that linear
Dominguez is one of the best in-game
players that is playing today and all
the top players know that they
acknowledge it they respect it they do
not want to see Queens get off the board
and then give them any chances no they
do not and we've all been through it
you're playing a type top player you
start getting excited when Pieces come
off the board it ain't as simple as that
so this game has plenty of life in it
speaking of Plenty Of Life board two uh
has started with Benjamin Bach uh a very
exciting player for the archbishops in
what a well-assembled team Robert so man
Chinese Squad they have a tough task
ahead of them Knight comes out to C4 I
like the kind of start that Louis ping
is off to though
yeah why not throw your knight forward
you're just taking control of vital
squares but now is a big moment for
Leonard Dominguez does he play B5 to
kick this Knight out of C4 that's not a
move you make lightly because as I like
to say Dania Pawn chance only as strong
as their base pawns if black does throw
the B7 Pawn up two squares that A6 Pawn
can become vulnerable later in the game
it's a game of inches I know they say
that in American football but it isn't
chess as well like you make these small
little moves but they have big
consequences as the game continues later
down the line white could position the
pawn on A4 and really get to that pawn
on A6 so I'm with you I think B5 should
only be played under very specific
circumstances Bishop to C5 lanyard he's
got to watch out for the X-ray but the
Knight on C4 doesn't really have
anywhere to jump to obviously 95 that
would be a blunder because the Rook on
C8 would defend the bishop so in my
estimation the position is about equal
stuff could happen in the center we
could also get a bunch of minor piece
trades so I think this game is going to
continue for a while and Robert I think
that affords us a good opportunity to
take our first look at our bird's eye
view because we've got a couple of other
games underway
let's do it I see in the top right
Grandmaster Benjamin Bach he is a
popular streamer and he plays for the St
Louis archbishops he's the black pieces
he's a calm Italian for no and then in
against that's Grandmaster Shu Yi and in
the bottom left we have Nicholas
Theodore somebody you've mentioned he
takes on women's world champion June so
we have the all Grandmaster battles in
game one between the boards two and
three for either side so which one
should you want to go to Donia Robert I
can't even decide what to order in a
restaurant I've been to 10 times you're
expecting me uh to decide between two
games in front of thousands of people
okay let's go to shui's game against
Benjamin Bach just because it's a little
bit more advanced and uh after that we
will travel to theodoro land so we do
have a pretty conventional Italian here
and a modern treatment for both sides
Robert there was a time uh when A4 and
A5 was not standard fare but it seems
like every player is now inserting these
two moves and from Black's perspective
you get this Ace seven square for the
night Benjamin drops his Knight back to
A7 harassing the bishop trying to drive
it back to C4 but shuyi says no no no
you're gonna move your knight away I am
going to strike while you're sleeping
oh my goodness this is getting kind of
complicated because now the bishop is
captured on B5 does white take the dark
Square Bishop on C5 or simply recapture
the Knight on B5 these are difficult
questions to answer I feel like I would
want to capture the Knight because it
keeps my Pawn Center intact but I want
to capture the bishop because I don't
want to give my opponent the pair of
Bishops so he does take the bishop that
was not an easy decision for Shu Yi and
now Dunya we have opposite colored
Bishops that does not mean we have a
draw it means which color complex will
be more vulnerable I like the light
Square bishop or black because it's
developed and attacking some
um unprotected squares with White's Pawn
structure on the queen side I feel like
though those light squares could be
blacks for the taking whereas that dark
Square Bishop for white is sitting back
at home it's not developed and what
diagonal are you going to use with it
yeah I mean the prospect of a sacrifice
on H3 is not as far-fetched as it may
appear I mean after Queen D7 you already
have to seriously contemplate Bishop
takes H3 with a knight from F6 quickly
hopping into F4 white could choose to
play this very positionally if Benjamin
takes back with a pawn white could push
the pawn up to C4 play B3 and start
surrounding that backward Pawn on D6 but
that takes a while and once the bishop
leaves C1 uh Knight H5 Knight F4 looks
even more appealing with the F4 Square
left unattended but Benjamin could
circumvent all of that Robert really
it's a question of whether he wants to
take a serious risk Queen takes D6 is
going to result in a very drawish
position symmetrical Pawn structure but
if I'm Benjamin I'm going for and I'm
taking with a pawn here
yeah we see his microwave in the
background trying to figure out I just
always like his microwave there it looks
like shuyi is playing from a spa or a
hotel uh you know it's like he's just
chilling but it's a big decision so
that's why the players are taking their
time I know most of us myself included
would have recaptured on D6 with one
piece of the other instantly but
Benjamin knows that it changes this Pawn
structure it changes the dynamic of the
game he can take with the pawn I
actually don't mind that because if Pawn
takes D6 and pawn to C4 like you were
suggesting I believe that black can
bring that knight from F6 to D7 up to C5
take control of some of those dark
squares and maybe some of the light
scores as well so I think the Benjamin
while he is considering his options we
can go back to our bird's eye view Dania
just because all four games are now in
full swing and a perfect time to leave
this game uh in disapproval of
Benjamin's choice to take back with a
queen just kidding of course he wants to
stay solid he's got the black pieces and
he's definitely solved all of his
opening problems a crazy game is
unfolding on the lower left Nicholas
theodoro has a very Nicholas the like
position I think he's already sacrificed
upon I've been doing a whole lot of Pawn
counting in the PCL commentary so far uh
sort of upon sacrifice because D4 is
hanging Robert I don't think he'll
protest if we take a closer look uh at
that one
no let's do this the game in the bottom
left the game in the top left by the way
between Dominguez and uh Louis yeping
that one's looking very even still but
this one is anybody's contest Donna you
mentioned that black is up a pawn but
what black also has after this move Pawn
to E5 is the D5 square and as I'm saying
it Jew when you does it she uses that
square for her Knight that is an outpost
so what do you make of this Donna White
has control of some of the dark squares
as the more you know Advanced Pawn in
the center but black is up a pawn and
has this D5 Square to her advantage well
the various aspects of the position I'm
still adjusting my eyes to what's going
on here let's rewind really really
quickly and see how we got this zoo in
the first place this started uh as a
pretty tame Catalan G3 D takes E4 this
is all very standard fare but Nicholas
he is known for his unconventional
opening choices he often plays standard
stuff and then makes Sidelines within
them Knight B to D2 is a lot less common
than Bishop D2 and it leads to a sharp
and relatively unexplored type of
position June June says hey you're going
to give me the pawn I'm going to make
you regret it A4 C6 is standard fare the
Knight drops back to you one Robert
nothing about this game is normal 95 is
uh the more typical night Sally Jew in
June stabilizes her own night it's
chased away back to C7 E5 back to D5 it
goes that is a huge stronghold for Black
Knight after Knight E4 Nicholas Theodore
doesn't waste a second Queen H5 making
his intentions clear and Checkmate could
come really really quickly the Knight is
brought back to F3 it's threatening to
jump to G5 and the reason I think Jew
and June's position is hard to handle
Robert is because there's a combination
of problems on the one hand look at your
King right Bishop G5 Knight fg5 could be
a problem but the D6 square is just as
big of a problem particularly if the
dark squared Bishops go off the board
no I'm with you but there is one
defensive idea and I've played this from
the black side many times not this
specific position but this type of
position Queen to E8 is a sneaky strong
move because if white is careless and
makes a move like Rook to B1 Rook A2 or
some kind of random move just any random
move F5 is Black's idea that you are
offering a queen trade normally what it
would take on passant but you can't do
that because your queen on H5 is hanging
so that would just win black material
and if you don't take on Passat you have
to trade queens and after Rook takes you
see the it's no longer I need to restart
my computer Robert it's not letting me
just a second uh oh let me tell you yeah
so you can't do it
so it allows black to secure many of the
important squares and the challenge
white setup uh she does not go for this
by the way she did cited instead of
going for Queen eight to take on A4
that's a move most of us would not make
because look at Black's resulting I mean
double I said pawns everywhere but I
think her idea is to eventually play for
the move C6 to C5 and break open the
position yeah and opening up the queen
side could favor Black in the long term
right there's a B file The Rook could
come to B8 and hold the bishop down on
C1 I think Nicholas could recapture on
A4 and then June could follow up with A5
uh Rook takes C4 there would not be
possible because of Bishop A6 although
in such a position really any sacrifice
is possible so never uh Say Never but
Nicholas could also leave the pawn on A4
for later and focus instead on
developing his kingside initiative with
Bishop G5 or even uh typical idea Robert
Knight fg5 induce H6 and just come back
to F3 something a lot of players don't
like to do because it looks weird but
you're creating a hook on H6 and a
sacrifice could come fast and furious
there on the king side but I want to
show a quick variation and that's why I
keep mentioned Queen E8 and let's say
you do play Knight to G5 and then black
plays H6 and you go back a good
defensive move and this might happen is
Queen because Bishop takes H6 if black
takes back on H6 then the queen takes
and I think the black king is in a huge
trouble with the Knights jumping in you
see the eval bar is saying it's a messy
game but instead of politics F5 once
again has the Queens eyeing each other
the queen trade is forced because the
queen can't go the G file and try to
deliver Checkmate and then once the
Queens come off both the Knight on e4
and the bishop on A6 are hanging black
Nets apiece and she played it she played
Queenie I guess it's happening great
call by you Robert the only difference
is that the Knight is on H3 but I don't
think that that's substantively as we go
back to the light board changes the
tenor of the position Bishop H6 F5 is
still very much in effect great
defensive eye by the the former women's
world champion and Nicholas Theodore's
attack might come to a screeching halt
here Robert because even if white screen
drops back F5 is very much still in play
right because it allows black to lash
out like a tiger claw herself some space
and this is bad news for Nicholas
because he is down two pawns
I don't know what we're talking about
encouraging sign for Joe in June you
called it no this is really not great
for Nicholas it shows that he was going
for the attack it didn't pan out but now
for her she can make a move like Bishop
A6 right away I see you're playing A5
but maybe bishop A6 they put your Bishop
on B5 and now they're all sorts of
threats in the position including the
move C4 to C3 so I really like this for
the women's world champion he takes A4
was such a gutsy call and as was her
last move F7 F5 she is determined to
push White's Knight off of its active
post but there is no question that black
is objectively better despite the ugly
Pawn structure that Knight on D5 is an
absolute monster I was optimistic about
Nico's attack but he is going to have to
reset and try again as he Ponders
whether to take on passant or keep the
structure intact let's swing back to the
bird's eye view because a couple of the
games are but are already reaching the
time scramble phase you can't blink
because you're gonna miss the action
yeah I do just want to point out in the
bottom right Alice Lee with the white
pieces against super Grandmaster Wei
Alice Lee is 12 years old and she is
playing a super GM she has eye of norms
to her name but look at that in the
bottom right that's pretty level we will
get there eventually I don't think we
have to dive in right now because the
position is closed uh but Donna in the
top left lender Dominguez still looking
very solid as he competes with the
d-file yeah pieces are getting traded
Rooks are going off the board this game
should end in Israel white is also up
two and a half minutes fantastic time
management by the Chinese player and
Robert it's important not to overstate
the case right you don't want to go
crazy a draw with the black pieces is
not the end of the world yes you'd like
to win as the higher rated player but
half a point here and there it may
change the outcome of the match but this
is only round one and you certainly want
to err on the side of caution for now
yeah Leonard Dominguez I think he's just
going to make a simple straightforward
draw once the Queens come off the board
uh maybe somehow he'll play for a win
that is as linear Dominguez as it gets
like neutral position very level and
then he wins because he's an end game uh
technician so he's the Queen's likely
coming off in that one so Donna where
should we go as the queen just came off
the top right board and Benjamin Bach as
well yeah I'll keep an eye a peripheral
eye on that game if things heat up we'll
take you there lenier with 90 seconds
he's got to watch this clock but let's
go to that board on the lower right
Alice Lee we talked about her she's a
fascinating player she's already very
experienced at 12 years old she's played
tons of over-the-board tournaments she's
played in Charlotte dangerous dangerous
player way is not taking this lightly
let's see what we have here Robert on
the one hand encouraging sign for black
this night on D4 is a beast and if it's
captured it's replaced by an even bigger
beast in the form of a pawn that will
drive the night away and create chances
of a discovered attack against The Rook
so that's good for black but Alice has
some serious Queen side pressure she's
got out the positional concept of
playing B5 and carving out her own
outpost on D5 what do you make of this
how do we evaluate this position well I
first did some Googling I want to
apologize to Alice she is 13. she's now
a teenager still super talented super
strong and aiming for the move B5 Rook
B1 says let me get control of the B file
I want to push that pawn to B5 carve out
the D5 square and you know I love to
point this out that Knight on E7 is
dominated by that E4 Pawn there's
nowhere for it to jump uh the bishop on
G7 staring into its own Pawn on E5 so I
just feel like with the bishop hair even
though it's at the best Bishop pair and
black can take this bishop on E2 at any
moment it's the presence of the dark
Square Bishops I think whites is better
and I think White's Knight on C3 is
better than the counterpart on E7 agreed
completely and a lot of newer players
when they see a piece like D4 they tend
to panic and they tend to take that
Knight off the board as quickly as
possible but more experienced players
realize that there are two other sides
of the board there's the queen side
there's the king side and yes the this
night is annoying it's going to be
annoying for a long time but you can
work around it and this is exactly what
Alice Lee is doing she can also throw in
a prophylactic move like King H1
ensuring the safety of her King and if
you're way ye I think you're basically
playing against White's clock you're
trying to keep the tension for as long
as possible Alice is down below for four
minutes and Robert we know how nervous
the lower rated player can get when
they're down on the clock and they sense
that a big upset is at hand we saw that
two days ago with Trisha Kanye moral
getting oh so close to stunning chakra
Ahmad yarov but choking at the very very
last moment it's such an understandable
feeling but Alice Lee doing a great job
so far
and that move F4 that was just played by
way he's going for the king's Indian
attack G5 next but but what attack
doesn't white have a light Square Bishop
on E2 how are you ever going to play G4
when all of White's pieces stare at that
square so I feel like now is the time
for Alice to play B5 which is a
nerve-wracking move to make because as
soon as you play B5 and you see black
play C5 you may wonder is the position
two closed the knight's gonna start
dominating but she has no fear she
recognizes that B5 is the best move she
has an advantage Alice Lee is not just
here to say oh I may make a draw every
now and then she's just playing great
chess right now she is and that's
exactly how you want to handle things if
you're the lower rated player right the
best way to lose is to play for a draw
uh the best way to score an upset is to
play like you're playing any other
opponent you don't want to change the
way you're playing just because of the
number in front of your opponent's name
but wait he's stubborn he insists on
trying to squeeze G4 through will he be
able to succeed I'm pretty pessimistic
but he's also keeping the tension on the
queen side and a big decision there by
Alice to open up the queen side Robert a
quick interjection game one as we
predicted has indeed ended peacefully
lenier Dominguez has drawn his game
against Liu ping yeah that game was not
overly exciting it was a solid
professional drop for Leonard Dominguez
and for Lou yaping a good result you're
the board four taking a half point from
the board one that is a success in its
own right so let's look at this position
a little deeper I feel like oh Bishop D1
it's a step in the wrong direction
suddenly ways pieces are coordinating
the good news is G4 is not possible the
bad news is uh White's pieces they don't
look well coordinated I think she should
jump forward with a knight to B5 this
time around not to D5 I do think a trade
of knights will be helpful for her just
get that Knight out of D4 if you can
but I'm starting to get very
apprehensive about the way this game is
going no pun intended Rook B8 right now
could pin the Knight and threaten A6 on
the other hand that Bishop on D1 great
defensive piece it's guarding A4 perhaps
the queen could move out of the B file
and black just doesn't have a lot of
purchase on the queen side the Knight on
D4 looks impressive but you need a
little bit more spice to win this game
so Rook B8 Queen D3 uh if A6 then the
Knight could grab that weak Pawn on D6
so objectively I think the position is
still around equal but can we keep
finding ways to spice it up and keep
White's clock ticking closer and closer
to zero there's Rook V8 and Alice has to
stay alert and get her Queen out of B1
I think Queen D3 looks automatic and
it's a good she plays it as soon as I
say it she is putting maximum pressure
on the D4 squared now D4 is well
defended because the bishop on G7 even
though it's not active it defends that
square a bunch of times with Knight the
pawn the bishop it's okay but I think
for Alice now shingle Queen A3 perhaps
and go after the D6 Pawn like let's
slide around we do have a draw on board
two that game was not particularly
exciting either a Benjamin Buck makes a
professional draw with black against
Grandmaster shuyi so we have two
forwards remaining and the St Louis
archbishops are white on both of those
boards and just to bring up the four
board scene for a second uh Nicholas
Theodore has his work cut out front like
whoa big move from June by the way in
the bottom left E5 huge move so maybe
should we head on into that one since
we've been on the Alice Lee game for a
while we will try to catch both uh of
these games and bring you the time
scramble in Alice Lee's game but E5 is a
move that we have to investigate more
carefully June June trying to break out
of the shell there's total pandemonium
in the center her idea I think is that D
takes E5 runs into Knight takes E3 if we
could bring up an analysis board really
quickly this is important de3 93 wins
the game for black queen is hanging and
if you trade Queens then suddenly the
Knight on C5 is hanging rookie 3 Bishop
C5 end of story black is up a bishop so
in the position after E5 Robert Nico has
to maintain the tension he can do this
in several ways he can drop his Knight
back but that may allow Bishop A6 but
after Knight distribution Basics Queen
takes C6 can come in and don't fall
asleep on the prospect of a pin against
the queen and the King this could come
very very untimely for black in time
pressure absolute craziness on the board
right now and you can sense that it's a
critical moment because Nicholas
Theodore he's using his clock and I
think what Drew and June wants is a
queen trade that like Knight takes E3 if
that's her next move will force a queen
trade even if it doesn't win a piece and
Nicholas Theodore does not want to
blunder pieces like that I it will allow
the Queens to come off the board and she
may find her defensive test easier and
the reason why is let's look at the
material and Knight D3 was it I expect
her to take on E3 yeah swap queens and
then take on D4 because in all
likelihood even if black loses all three
of those Queen side pawns those ugly
isolated pawns if she can get B2 out of
the way she'll only be down one Pawn on
the king side and with a pair of Bishops
I think she has good chances of holding
so I think it was a good practical
decision but Daniel she took a lot of
time to play Knight takes E3 there and
this is where experience comes in this
is where all those sleepless nights
blitzing on chess.com playing 30 second
chest that's where it comes in handy yes
there's a two second increment but it
doesn't change all that much when push
comes to shove because those two seconds
evaporate so so so fast and Nicholas
theodoro one of his greatest strengths
as a blitz and Rapid player is his
ability to keep the tension in positions
that may seem lifeless so June June
let's see if she can maintain at least
45 seconds on her clock take on D4 Play
Bishop F6 and make sure your pieces are
active don't worry too much as you're
saying about losing even potentially all
three of these pawns don't burn all of
your clock trying to keep these
weaknesses alive
I mentioned this often Hikaru Nakamura
gives the wise advice you should play
good moves quickly rather than the
perfect move slowly and this is a moment
where she should just be playing quickly
she knows he takes D4 upon trade is
perfectly fine for her but she's trying
to find the perfect choice does she
flick in the move A4 to A3 is now the
time for that it's not an easy choice
right like there are a lot of things at
playing and as you're putting out Bishop
takes C6 with Bishop D5 to follow with
that Rook on the F7 square that looks
messy and I think she might be missing
that after ed4 Bishop C6 The Rook has to
move out to A6 I think in order to meet
Bishop D5 with Bishop P6 but she's
panicked and she's giving away the E
Pawn oh that is a huge mistake by Jew
and June and now Anika is going to get a
massive Pawn Center and the prospect of
driving the Knight up to E5 was that a
mouse slip Robert was that panic in my
mind
it was Panic no I think she just should
recognizes her position is getting
difficult and she's just trying to get
those pieces out so if Rook C8 here
there's just Knight E5 maybe she thought
both pieces were under attack at once
now she's trying to kick that Knight out
of D3 but E4 for white push that pawn up
get rid of that Bishop the Knight is
safe and sound Bishop D5 is a threat
you've just two healthy Pawns in the
center uh that was a big big mistake
from the women's world champion in some
sort of time travel God those pawns
those Center pawns are running up the
board like a Mack truck D5 E5 T6 and all
of the barriers are cross here the minor
pieces are perfectly positioned uh to
breach the defensive wall the black is
set up with her Bishops I think Nico
should just keep pushing he's double
checking he's asking himself is this too
good to be true I don't see a single
chance at this point for Jew and June
maybe after D5 Bishop C8 E5 she has to
drop her Bishop back on F5 generate some
activity but at this point she's Living
on a Prayer
but look at Niko Theodore dropping under
a minute himself he is a fantastic ball
player he goes Knight F4 not a move that
we're looking at and I think that Juju
Bishop B3 why not just bring your Bishop
to protect your A4 Pawn keep it on the
same diagonal as your king and rook and
E5 so the pawns are going forward Donna
but now Bishop B4 you're highlighting
before I can even say it like really
it's like you're reading my mind the
Bishops are free and she goes to G5 I
understand that choice as well uh but
here come the pawns right here come the
pawns and Nico he's gotta throw caution
to the wind and throw the kitchen sink
at Juan June right now Bishop F4 and
Rook F4 not dangerous at all in fact you
want to get rid of one of flax Bishops
because then the danger to your king
diminishes greatly E6 also possible to
hear Robert but maybe premature what's
on your mind oh my gosh I'm just seeing
something happening in the other game oh
my God Alice Lee all of a sudden this
game looks like Nico Theodore was taking
charge it's pandemonium on this board
but look at board four let's go into
Alice Lee against super Grandmaster Wei
because her Queen has slithered into the
E6 Square and suddenly this position
looks very difficult for the super Grand
Master From China Bishop C ford next
Queen G8 Checkmate Queen H6 mate is also
going to be there when the bishop goes
to C4 how many pawns is black up it's
just one and A6 is under attack as well
this could be a win for Alice Lee
only disturbing thing is the time on our
clock way is up a full minute on the
clock she's gotta keep playing fast do
not be fooled by the connected passers
on the C and D files the light squares
around Black's King are devastatingly
weak the absence of a light squared
Bishop is hurting the Chinese Grand
Master can weigh e use his minor pieces
in his Queen to keep White's peace
tandem at Bay the king is running to H6
Robert h8 is protected by the bishop
otherwise that would have been made
Alice Lee is down to 16 seconds and this
is where Panic often sets in
the pawn can just go it can't be stopped
there unfortunately if you take the
Knight The Deep Pawn goes to D2 and then
D1
and the A4 Pawn is the bane of White's
existence there but he missed
finalelessly a new
she needs to bring her Bishop back right
now go back to B3 to cover the D1
promotion Square she gives a second but
Bishop G7
yeah no this is going for weight by the
way Juan June somehow drew the game is
that right
no way she she found
unbelievable well look at that after
this
uh this is now unfortunately for Alice
Lee I mean it's just all downhill for
her her King is in trouble the king and
a chick somehow was tucked away and
saved and here come the pawns it's
actually on the safest Square on the
board there isn't a single check love
the move H4 it's still not over where
you can finally get that G4 move in
about 30 moves later than he wanted to
but he doesn't even need to he's
focusing on what's important D2 is
coming next and that King on G5 is
feeling as comfortable as ever Alice Lee
has no threats here and D2 ends the game
yeah just D2 you have to at best give up
your Bishop for one pawn and then
probably to give it other Bishop for the
second one and that's two extra pieces
the King on G5 can't even be checked in
any meaningful way so yeah this is going
to be a win for Wei but good on Alice I
mean she played a great game and she had
her chances and that was a big win for
Wei that was the only when the three
other games ending in a draw and a big
Miss for Nico theodoro if I can bring
that game up really really quickly to
show what on Earth happens we thought
this was a bygone conclusion Robert and
it never is in time pressure disaster
struck after Jew and June delivered a
check on G4 and a check on F4 and played
this last ditch move Rook F4 E7 it's
still winning apparently oh my gosh Nico
didn't realize that he could run away
from the checks he did not realize that
he could run his way back to C1 to B1 to
A2 and a three can you blame him with
three seconds left what a save by Jew
and June yeah it looks like you're about
to get checkmated or something so
amazing save for Jew and June she was
fighting every single move in that game
she survives that means the Shanghai
tigers go up two and a half one and a
half thanks to weigi's Victory but
Daniel this was as close as it gets I
know the score isn't tied that would be
closer but on each and every board it
felt like both players had chances and
listen Alice Lee can't feel too bad she
had her chances if she had 30 more
seconds on her clock we could have seen
a different result on that board but now
lanyard Dominguez and Benjamin Bach are
going to have to take more risks they
are going to be white in board two they
cannot allow a quick solid draw they're
gonna have to strike and St Louis
already has a little bit of coming back
to do but they've got three rounds to do
it and nothing has been decided
absolutely not so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back after this short
break for round two of the protesting
match between the St Louis archbishops
and the Shanghai tigers
foreign
I remember people saying so no you got
to stand back keep your rating low go
play in the World open and win six
thousand dollars you know just just
don't don't keep your rating up and I'd
be like what are you talking about I'm
trying to become a GM that's ridiculous
so that mentality was something I had to
escape this was not the black bear
School mentality but the park ecosystem
it for me was Prospect Park in Brooklyn
definitely Foster this idea because you
a little bit of awesome mentality that
you keep your rating low and you try to
win somebody who's running
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
to this Pro chess League match between
the St Louis archbishops and the
Shanghai Tigers currently a lead for the
Tigers Donna it was an impressive first
round for the team from China
high level chess all around a solid
chess all-around everybody doing their
job Robert everybody contributing
yipping Lou holding lenyard Dominguez to
a draw way surviving a valiant effort by
Alice Lee but ultimately not panicking
and pressing the right buttons at the
right time and a miracle save by former
women's world champion Jew and June
everybody contributed and they are
leading by a point they're doing great
that half point baiju and Jude may be
huge for the overall standings of this
match she is 32 years old she is the
second highest rated player female
player in the Pro chess League behind
Katerina lock no three-time Women's
World chess champion uh she earned the
GM title of 23 she's one of Six Women to
surpass 2600 and most importantly are
most pertinent to this league Dania she
only counts as 23.50 against the rating
cap and she's over 25.50 herself she is
a huge Ace and she has not been as
active in the last couple of years but
again she's only 32 years old she's
still incredibly sharp and of course uh
the other two women to surpass 2600
Judith Polgar and her compatriot huyifan
uh who doesn't play actively anymore but
Jew and June is a force to be reckoned
with everybody takes her very seriously
and for very good reason she uh is
capable of being a major major X Factor
in a major push for the Shanghai tigers
Shanghai Tigers up two and a half one
half right now they are in the lead but
will they remain so after the next round
that's the big question Leonard
Dominguez and Benjamin Bach the top two
boards or the archbishops get the white
pieces against Grandmaster Shu Yi an
international Master luya ping both very
solid players but then the bottom two
boards done yet I think that's where the
Shanghai Tigers they are going to look
to get some decisive results Wei with
white against Nicholas theodoro and June
June with white against Alice Lee that's
the biggest rating differentials there
on or two for the Tigers board four for
the Archbishop
yeah fascinating matchups here and once
again for linear Dominguez very
important to press the gas pedal now
Robert because Nicholas theodoro he's
got a very tough matchup with black
against Wei and Alice Lee has her work
cut out for her against Jew and June
also with black so lanyard and Benjamin
Bach the onus is right now squarely on
of their shoulders St Louis has coming
back to do and they've got a tough round
ahead of them
they do every single round is tough and
St Louis did not bring out Fabiano
caruana this week and it's Leonard
Dominguez instead so you know it's one
of those talking points like should
Fabiano played I think Woulda Coulda
Shoulda the hindsight is 20 20. uh but
Fabiano has been amazing in the protest
league in the past so whether or not he
plays the future weeks we have yet to
see but he's not playing here in week
one and maybe that will hurt St Louis
archbishops if they can't mount a
comeback
well like you're saying hindsight is 20
20 we see the same types of criticisms
in sports games why did the coach not
put in Steph Curry earlier why didn't he
start this player or that player but you
can't know until the match is over I
think St Louis's lineup is totally
reasonable and I'm sure that fappy is
going to make many memorable appearances
in subsequent weeks yeah menu Dominguez
oh my gosh what it you know what a
replacement yeah
I mean come on you replace your 2760
player with a 2740 player who is a
superstar in his own right I feel like
Leonard Dominguez and I've said this
often he's just one of the most
underappreciated players in the world I
mean the guy is not even in his chair
and his clock has started uh but he is
an absolute monster an in-game
technician he just knows how to work
those small advantages and he's
fantastic it's a great pickup for St
Louis is a great pickup for the United
States because he now plays for the U.S
Olympia team and well let's see what his
first move is because he's just getting
into a seat E4 well he's an E4 player
through and through but don't be fooled
by his repertoire Jose rule capablanca
would be proud of the Heritage that
lanyard Dominguez continues because
behind the Tactical repertoire lies a
very solid positional underpinning and
phenomenal end game technique as saying
I hope I'm not seeing a Petra up here I
hope my eyes are deceiving me Robert
this is a Scourge upon humanity and it
is uh winding its tentacles around every
corner of the Chess World
many many Chinese players do play the
Petrov whether it's you Yang Yi uh Wang
yuei they have a chess school there so I
believe that they actually work on it
and it's really difficult to crack the
Petra off but Leonard Dominguez a former
World Blitz Champion I believe is 2008
when he won that title that is of course
a tremendous accomplishment for Emmy
used to play for Cuba now in the United
States and he's just playing this calmly
like he goes Knight to D2 if you take
this Knight on D2 you get to take the
bishop on F5 that's why the Knight drops
back but Daniel what do you make of this
opening thus far well this position
resembles another riveting line the
rookie won Berlin and I am joking of
course that Petrov is a full-fledged
opening as has been proven out uh for
well over a decade Boris gelfon playing
it uh in the early 2000s and now Jana
pomnishing a lot of the top Chinese
players are continuing the tradition
objectively the position is close to
equal I think they're following Wesley
so's series of games against nihal sarin
from the chess.com Global Championship
if memory serves me right I remember
this move Knight A6 now knee Hall I
think positioned his Pawn on F6 a little
bit too early and softened up that E6
Square the big question here Robert can
black deal with the ensuing pressure
down the E file white is going to try to
double the Rooks white is going to bring
the Knight up to G3 and from a rapid
play perspective there is no question
that White's position is easier to play
but we shouldn't forget the tcgms they
analyze these positions to move 20 move
25 they look at all of the ideas and
they feel comfortable holding uh the
fort in a situation like this I love how
we were looking this is going to be a
solid Affair it's lender Dominguez and
he plays Harry the H Pawn up to H4 that
pawn is Untouchable you lose a piece on
the spot if you took that pawn and now
we see why the Paul went there Knight G5
and suddenly Dominguez doesn't get a
bishop pair because there are no light
Square Bishops but he does get an
unopposed dark Square Bishop so F6 can
be played by black and just was Bishop
slides back to F4 and this is what you
were talking about the little pluses for
white the E6 Square there is a knight on
C7 but now that Knight is stuck
protecting that square the F5 Square in
comes a knight to G3 and maybe bishop
takes uh D6 to get yourself the F5
square and as you're pointing out H5
maybe even throwing the pun up to H6 and
black doesn't play it himself I like the
look of this the Contours are nice for
white
Harry the H1 might be taking a little
break but uh Harry might be back on the
grind soon enough H5 and H6 could induce
more weaknesses on the king side but all
of this Robert could be water under the
bridge if the heavy Pieces come off the
board black is going to rush this Rook
to E8 try to exchange both pairs of
Rooks and ultimately if all you're left
with is a queen and two minor pieces
then you're just not going to be able to
ignite the Flames of a king side attack
so when you're he's got a very narrow
window of opportunity can he figure
something out before black gets those
Rooks off of the board
yeah I'm wondering he's pausing H5 seems
extremely logical but
yeah I've seen Knight E6 is available to
Black so he's probably trying to figure
out is Queen G3 best great suggestion by
you there uh because you're hitting both
nights in a row and you can't move
either Knight really but if you bring
the Knight forward to F5 maybe you walk
into a different pin along the H3 you
know C8 diagonal so it's just an awkward
position for black the knights are a bit
clumsy but linear he's spending his time
in shuyi he seems to know what to do
here he is playing quite rapidly himself
yeah his Knights are in a row that's not
a good thing but his ducks are also in a
row in terms of his opening knowledge
Leonard Dominguez taking his time here
Queen G3 is a spicy move but it might
also turn out innocuous after Rook a to
d8 there's 94 with Tempo uh but not
immediately because then white will
capture and get two pieces for a rogue
so and you're to make his big moment
right now he senses that he needs to
figure out a way to tighten the screws
and he's got one move to do it perhaps
we could swing our way back to the
bird's eye view as lanyard Ponders this
complex situation because the other
games are underway as well Robert
and I agree with that feature chat that
definitely prepared by Shri but other
games are going so let's go to our four
board view uh boards two and three uh
well boards two for three for St Louis
actually top right bottom left have
begun we see in the bottom left a
Russell limo by Nicholas theodoro
against Wei and the top right we have
one of the most close positions you
could ask for Benjamin Bach not yet
showing his cards he is going to make
some kind of Pawn capture uh some kind
of trade but right now no pieces are off
the board so Donna I prefer the game in
the bottom left it looks a little bit
more exciting more life to it to me but
the interestingly is Benjamin Bach down
under eight minutes so he's the one who
spent time to get to the position in the
top right
showing a little bit of indecision and
he could take that game and two
completely opposing directions he could
push that pawn up to D4 transposing into
a peaceful line of this love or he could
play it shakuri armami jar of style
Richard reports out and run Gary the
Jeep on up the board sacrificing it
trying to open up the king side it
really depends on his frame of mind and
what he has analyzed so let's take a
quick look at Benjamin box game let's
see what decision he ends up making and
then perhaps we can uh turn our way back
to the rosalimo in Theodore's game so
Bishop B2 is the last move yipping low
contemplating his uh decision for black
and Robert black does not need to sit
idly by and wait for white to make the
decision E5 can be a very dangerous move
in these situations if white falls
asleep at the wheel well I could shove
these pawns right up the board and
White's minor pieces are pretty
vulnerable to attack so I think yipping
is seriously considering that move but
there is a drawback to playing even he
just played it now what is going to take
on D5 and if you take back with the pawn
there is this move Knight to be fun
actually white I think obtains a serious
Advantage right now because the bishop
slides back to B8 and then you play Rook
C1 and you're gonna drive that Knight
into the C7 Square to secure yourself
the bishop pair and it's not a closed
position so the bishop pair will shine
and you could see Amelia Pink's face
right now he's like oh oh I don't really
like what I've done here
the problem Robert is that E5 is a very
powerful move in certain positions but
with minor changes it's a huge mistake
if the pawn was on A6 this would work to
Perfection he simply confused the move
order also of course it's my fault I put
this idea in his mind uh let's make sure
we assign the blame properly Knight C7
is essentially a pre-move an E4 would
make matters even worse because it would
seed this massive outpost on D4 this is
major major trouble for the Chinese
player you could see it on his face he's
like what did I just do a Louisa is as
solid of a player as it gets we saw how
he played against Leonard Dominguez it
was just an even game from start to
finish and he wanted more of the same he
had a triangle Pawn structure just a few
moves ago and as soon as he pushed the
Pod forward he left a square behind he
is really upset with himself but the
position is not lost it is better for
white it is an easy position to play
it's a dream come true for any
Grandmaster to have this position from
the white side but I like his choice
there he may be a solid player Dania but
he understands when the position calls
for some dynamism and let's see what
happens if we just gobble up the pawn on
D4 we're saying give me that pawn let's
open up the position but that's it black
gets to open up the position on terms
that are favorable for him with a rook
coming to E8 and the king is still in
the center for white so I think that he
did the right thing given his position
was getting uncomfortable and Benjamin
Bach is annoyed that he won't get a
chance to just put his side on C7 and
win this game smoothly we take this for
granted Robert in strong players they
know how to drive manual on the
chessboard they know when to switch
gears when to try to change the course
of the game and when the game is
starting to slip out of their grass but
no question that white is still better
big choice for Benjamin now does he
stick with Knight C7 or does he take a
moment and grab that pawn on D4 to which
black I'm pretty sure we'll respond with
E4 then the Knight could swing up to E5
I suppose Robert that the downside of
the move Knight C7 if we could bring up
an analysis board there is a crazy trap
that yipping Lou has just set I think
the move D3 wins material for black
can't take it with the queen because you
dropped the Knight if you take it with
the bishop then black takes everything
on C7 and follows up with E4 and look at
these Knights beautifully coordinated
Bishop F6 does not help because one
Knight replaces the other and white
loses a minor piece so I actually think
Benjamin has to has to take on E5 and go
for the complication here
right yeah he takes it and he goes with
it but at least now for black you're not
just sitting in a passive worst position
where opponent has the pair of Bishops I
I think it was a good choice rookie
eight now uh for it it was E4 okay still
right he's getting Dynamic here but now
that Nike go up to E5 is protected twice
by the D4 Pawn the bishop B2 behind it
and if rookie 8 Knight C7 lands there so
not great for black but one good thing
is with these double isolated d-pawns
the Black Knight can blockade with
Knight to D5 and then Knight can even go
to the F4 Square in the future so it's
getting Dynamic it's still better for
white but this is more comfortable for
uh black than just giving up the pair of
Bishops even if the material would have
remained the same so let's uh hop on out
of here while the knights hop around in
this game we see all four games are in
full swing some have more commotion than
others uh Donna in the bottom right Juan
June against Alice Lee that's a very
solid position if I've ever seen one
nothing major happening there just yet
uh but what do you make of the position
in the bottom left and by the way
Leonard Jimmy's just did take the Knight
on d69 F5 in the top left but I was
looking at the bottom left and wondering
your thoughts where white has a pair of
Bishop
yeah when you're trying to knife his way
and Knight his way into Black's position
exploiting that Knight on F5 but lock is
closer than ever then uh to getting them
the heavy pieces off the board but I do
want to take a closer look at that
bottom left board the question Robert
isn't whether Wei is better it is to
what degree how much better is he
because of his Bishop pair because of
his control over the dark Square so two
uh ways game we go it started as a
rosalimo Nicholas theodoro is very solid
here there aren't a lot of Targets in
Black's position and I think Wei is
essentially gonna have to play on both
sides of the board he can reposition the
light squared Bishop to B3 pressure F7
you can also try to play for positional
restriction on the case at G3 uh your
type of move restricting the Knight
maybe drop the queen back and run the
Harry the h-bond it's made several
appearances now in this round and if it
knocks the Knight off of G6 it can
advance to H6 and induce weaknesses on
the king side but that all takes a lot
of moves Robert and much like in linear
dominguez's game well I could try to
take this opportunity to take as many
pieces off the board as possible
yeah no it's a situation here where for
Wei Yi you have the two Bishops you that
Bishop on B7 for Theodore is looking
pretty ugly uh but where are the targets
that's the key question is Black's
position remains solid despite the fact
that white has activity and the bishop
Eric in comes the knights F4 it's a one
move threat the queen can just move away
I'd probably slide back to F3 he goes to
H4 just putting pressure on The Rook on
d8 oh this is making it difficult for
black because you can't trade all the
Rooks now you can only trade one pair of
Rooks on D1 because the d8 square is
covered by White's Queen
yeah this is a little bit nerve-wracking
because there is a check on E2 but it's
a paper tiger uh so to speak because of
King H1 the Knight doesn't touch
anything but don't bring your queen back
to G3 put a Pawn on that square Nicholas
theodoro is under massive pressure here
I think he should bring his Knight back
to E6 and I'm insisting that you know
the key to solving most of Black's
problems is to figure out a way to get
the Rooks off the board maybe Wei is
planning Bishop E7 a further winding his
claws around that d8 square and keeping
at least one pair of Rooks on the board
Robert
yeah no you you need to know what pieces
you want to trade in a position of this
sort and it's not easy to figure out I'm
just saying you need to figure it out
I'm asking somebody else to do it but
here I think Bishop E7 for white I mean
you could play Queen E7 actually and
trade the Queens so I'm gonna throw it
right back to you don't know like any
good teammate you can call me like the
Chris Paul of this broadcast I'm gonna
throw it to you and you're gonna have to
tell me is a queen trade helpful for
whiter for black
I think I black would be relieved at a
queen trade as miserable as that
resulting end game is I feel like with
the Queen's on the board things could
deteriorate in the course of like three
moves and more specifically Robert after
the trade on D1 I'm looking at the board
and I don't see a good way to stop
Bishop back to D6 winning E5 and the
worst thing for black is that Bishop B3
hasn't even been played yet that's going
to raise the pressure by orders of
magnitude so Nicholas Theodore better
find a way uh to completely change the
course of the game much like yipping Lou
did with D4 and E4 but he doesn't have
an equivalent Pawn break his pieces are
passive maybe he should try to reignite
his Bishop with C5 but I don't see a
good opportunity to do that because then
Bishop D6 will calmly pick up the pawn
on E5 and he's played it anyway he goes
for so Bishop D6 maybe there's Queen A5
ah 28 it's also nice but I was in Queen
A5 where you go after the A2 Pawn you
take E5 I grab A2 so I'm protecting my
Pawn by attacking one of your own but I
think even after Queen A5 you could
probably just push her eighth onto A3
and then the E5 Pawn is still loose uh
the problems will persist
no that might simply be winning for
black if we could quickly show uh no we
don't even need to show way he is going
to show us uh the outcome of this game
but I will make the moves on the board
Queen A5 calmly A3 no need to give that
pawn away and in the event of F6 Robert
you can see the eval bar creeping up and
I cheated a little bit there is a crazy
tactic Bishop takes Pawn F takes E5 and
queen E7 this is why you can't always
trust the eval bar and White's Pieces
come in furiously picking off all of
Black's vulnerable minor pieces this
would win the game for white
alternatively in the events of Queen d8
I don't know what the best course of
action here is maybe it's the com Queen
G3 do you see any killer blows here for
white or is Queen G3 the way to go Queen
G3 is excellent because you're
threatening E5 a second time and if F6
well there's a rook in line with that
Queen on d8 so you can just take the
pawn E5 anyway so I do believe that this
position is just very very very good for
white and I just don't see anything for
Nicholas to do he is going down at least
a pawn and you can see it on his face
he's not particularly happy
and he's played Queen d8 trying
desperately to get the Queens off the
board and White's gonna say no way Jose
no Wayne Nicholas in this case we're
gonna see Queen G3 and the Chinese
Grandmaster is completely in control of
this game from the very first moves
for sure so while we know that way ye
you know he is in good shape here we'll
see how this one progresses but let's
zoom out for a second uh just because
some of the other games are getting very
interesting and down the line so we can
bring back our bird's eye view and check
out some of the other ones I see in the
top left linear Dominguez is in a
position with queen and Knight versus
queen of Knight but his position is
better with the white pieces he's much
more active done yet I think this is
where we saw the game going and I'm
looking at the top right uh there and
I'm seeing the Queens are off the board
and Benjamin Bach versus Lou yaping so
all the games are still exciting even
the one in the bottom right that we
haven't looked at Jew and June with
white against Alice Lee uh I see the
bark quite heavily in White's favor but
that position looks messy
well I will say that you I think we're
prescient uh in your complimentary words
about lanyard's end game technique he
has found a way to keep the advantage
even though black has achieved what may
seem like his biggest dream he's taking
the Rooks off the board but he can't
quite push white spaces off their
dominant post so we'll keep an eye on
that end game but I do want to take a
look at way a Jew and June's game
because it is opening up pieces are
getting traded pandemonium is happening
so let's take a brief look at who is
emerging on top first and first feelings
Robert is that it's white Black's got
bad Pawn structure that Bishop is
rerouting to C4 F7 is weak and the last
thing you want to do is give up your
fiancado Bishop because that king is not
going to be happy no not at all because
you know there may be a pawn in the dark
Street Bishop's path but that pawn will
be flicked forward even sacrifice
jettison that pawn to open up a diagonal
so I'm liking the look of this position
for Jew and June the Women's World
Champion uh and the clock is about even
that's the good news for Alice Lee I
think the clock uh was her Kryptonite in
game one against she had a great
position but she had no time here her
position is a bit shaky but she has
plenty of time to try to figure it out
so Donna Bishop D5 you're pointing out
that looks quite enterprising but I'm
already looking at Mike takes F7 Rook
takes D5 sacrifices don't know if they
work
yeah make a little tall style it just
smells right it smells of a sacrifice of
tactics but this is where the time
control can be a major obstacle it's
easy to take four minutes without even
realizing it and in the blink of an eye
you've made no progress and you've got
30 seconds on the clock so you have to
be practical is there a way for Jew and
June to play quickly and keep a big
Advantage I don't know Robert the thing
you can't do is take on D5 and take on
e4 that would be a huge blunder on
account of rooked HD one check Queen C2
uh is her move in the women's world
champion trying to keep her foot on the
gas pedal and keep plenty of time on the
clock the Evo bar dropped a little bit
there but I still think Alice Lee is far
from being out of the woods here yeah
and I think that Alice need to trade
some of those pieces but the problem
with trading piece is if you look at the
pawn structure A7 C5 both isolated and
they're going to be targets E4
overextended so white Pawn structure
much healthier despite the fact that Jew
and Judas push Pawns in front of her
King so our King is actually the safe
one uh and it's Black's King that needs
to be worried about so I'm look
I think that Alice needs a trade I just
don't know what trades you know do the
trick I think Bishop takes C4 rather uh
that might be an option and then if the
Knight takes on C4 Bishop takes E2 just
start training everything but still
going to remain an advantage a plus for
white
you're absolutely right and you called
it even if black takes on C4 and takes
on D1 And Trades the other pair of Rooks
that may take the pressure off of the
king but it's going to increase the
pressure on Black's Pawn Islands you
could simply end up dropping the pawn on
e4 so I really don't envy Alice's
position her clock now continuing to
dwindle this is a game that you and June
really needs to try to bag up and I feel
like she's in control and she's gonna
Coast to Victory unless something crazy
happens and Bishop takes D5 and queen C4
might come close to ending the game or
is there something more convincing well
I think after if we just show that
variations bring up an analysis board I
think Alice has calculated that in this
event of taking Queen C4 this Rook to d8
and you just can't pilot any more
pressure and there's a a counter threat
on The Rook on D1 so you have to move
your Rook on D1 take the Rook on D5 and
then Queen takes D5 we start swapping
pieces there is no longer this big
Advantage for white so there is
something tactical in the air Dania and
I I agree with you bullet I'd be taking
and playing Queens for instantly but
maybe it's Rook takes D5 in the starting
position or something like this trading
everything I was looking at Rook takes
D5 and just using the diagonal but I
like what you're showing here that you
can just simply trade everything on D5 I
was looking for some kind of tactical
shot if the Rook takes Rook takes but
you don't have a next move yeah there's
always that discover check on D1 there's
a queen sacrifice but uh just to tie up
this line instead of Queen C4 add in
Rook takes D5 you are gonna play Queen
C4 but first you're gonna push the queen
Away Great call by you there the
immediate Queen C4 is Hasty but here
there's Rook C7 but Queen C4 I think uh
is the perfect occasion to play this
move and tactics are still very much in
the air even Rook d8 comes to mind but
something more you know utilitarian like
Rook D6 or maybe Rook D7 doom and June
will have plenty of time here uh to
figure out the most precise way to
convert her Advantage I think she is a
couple more accurate moves away from any
of the game but she's played a crazy
move she's played F5 and what do you
make of this I don't know what to make
of it it is chaos look at this you could
take a knight on E5 but that's clearly
bad a lot should not be taking the
Knight E5 because when white takes the
pawn on E6 I assume the Knight on E6 but
the pawn gets there let's just put those
moves on the board we have E7 coming
we're distracting The Rook on d8 this is
the passer a Black's double I said
e-pawns are clearly worse because
somehow that pawn on E6 went to the
other side it feels like I'm looking
like a fellow where now the everything's
just collapsed in the e-file but black
instead of taking the Knight on E5 and
getting into this position I think well
she moved her Knight but I think she
actually moved it to the wrong Square
because
um here there's gonna be a problem
Brooke takes D5 and after Rook takes D5
just Rook D1 and you're piling up
pressure
I think even Desdemona wouldn't find a
way out of this nor would yago's curse
is Rook takes D5 ends the game I've been
saying that for a while but queensy won
at the end of the line is just going to
add too many attackers on The Rook on D5
I think this game is a couple of moves
away from conclusion
and you and June does not need to be
asked twice when there's a pin on the
board he is going to make use of it and
unfortunately just show how this game
might end Rook d8 for what Bishop takes
D5 I think it's Bishop takes D5 it
doesn't matter and then Rook takes Queen
C4 and that's that because the Rook is
pinned you're winning at least in
exchange but also four we're gonna go
or why not end the game with a
retreating move always make a retreating
move said nobody ever Queen D1 ends the
game let's see all roads uh lead to Rome
here Queen C4
she's gone for the Robert Hess approach
big mistake but we'll forgive her that
yeah maybe not as forcing but still
enough you win in exchange you win the
game this is it it's clear right it's
just done
and in the meantime lender Dominguez has
failed to make anything of his slight
Advantage if we could go back to the
bird's eye view because this game is
certainly decided he has drawn and
incredible holds there uh by the Chinese
Grand Master he really didn't give
lenier that many chances you could see
in the final position the Knight has
finally been pushed away from F5 and a
big result for the Tigers on that board
with Jew and June's inevitable Victory
they are going to be leading one and a
half Where Do We Go From Here wait e
might be on the cusp of winning as well
but he's getting low on time
wow that game is looking crazy you see
Eva bar dropping in the bottom left
that's way yiga stickers let's go there
the other game in The Bishop's opposite
color ending draw so what
that your game is going to be a drop
sorry go ahead oh I wasn't certain what
the result would be but yeah it looks
likely and you're saying Bishop F3 here
what if the queen just slides back like
you get the Rook on D1 but the king ajid
I don't think it's gonna be long for
this board
my gosh Queen G3 H takes G5 you don't
care about the Rook on you one and yes I
stand corrected Benjamin's actually up
two pawns so not trying to jump to
conclusions there but Nicholas Theodore
trying to conclude this game as quickly
as possible there is a made threat on H1
this way you play F3 exploiting the pin
then white plaque plays Queen takes F3
and at the end of the line there was
Knight takes E5 he plays Queen F3 anyway
what's going on here Robert
um Queens are coming off the Knight
kicks with check so what's the material
count by the way is white what's up a
pawn so even when the Queens come off
white should still be better but
Nicholas Theodore's up on the clock he
has a second lease on life in this
position but Donna how could you stay in
this game I mean after this position
wiping up a pawn with the bishop pair am
I missing a tactic
well Wei has to calculate H takes G5
because Queen takes F2 is not the end of
the world you play King H3 the bishop
comes into F3 but he doesn't want to
touch that with a 10-foot pull he's got
20 seconds on the clock he goes for the
practical decision King H3 might be the
key to the kingdom to leave the g-file
open for a rook deck check on G1 that's
gonna allow you to unpin the bishop on
D6 that Bishop can make its way back to
D4 and you've also got the possibility
of H5 I have no doubt that white should
be winning this objectively but Nicholas
theodoro we know how good he is at
creating chances in his opponent's time
pressure
and by the way speaking of white winning
games Benjamin Bach would just bring
back our uh four board team quickly
Benjamin Buck is on the cusp of winning
that game he is up two three Pawns in a
bishop color ending and he's got a past
d-pawn ready to run D5 and D5 ends the
game here and now it forces the king
away I was wrong I looked at it briefly
I was fooled by the opposite colored
Bishops but Benjamin Bach a wire to wire
Victory Robert it was bad from the
opening and Louis Peng he tried but he
failed to create chances huge win right
there for the archbishops and it's all
down to that last game it's one and a
half one and a half can way e deliver
another point for the Tigers
yeah so let's go back into this one
because we know June June is going to
get that game and here what's the
material count it is suddenly even by
material not by position because H5 is a
threat for white to win this Knight on
G6 The Rook on date is under attack so
I've actually done yet because the Rooks
under attack and H5 is a threat how do
you stop both
well there's the answer Rook takes F2
defending by attacking but
it moves back to G4 and there's gonna be
a discovery against the bishop on A8
what a devious move with no time found
by way Yi wait that was sick because
black was threatening Rook F3 check with
a drawing mechanism oh my gosh if the
bishop had gone anywhere else like C8 or
D7 or whatever Rook F3 check and your
king can't get out of the checks unless
it steps onto the G4 Square in which
case the Knight would be free to move so
that is why Bishop back to G4 breaking
your own pin to unleash a critical
Discovery wow what a fine by way
I mean we take this stuff for granted
this is just crazy level of tactical
vision and now theodoro his clock is
dwindling he needs to keep finding
chances F5 Robert would Stave off defeat
but only buy a move Bishop D1 would pick
up the Knight I don't think fioruro can
protect his bishop and keep the G file
closed at the same time his time is
running out he makes the most practical
decision he's got three pawns for the
piece but those Bishops could ravage the
king if way you place his cards right
Rook F1 could be one way to start no
Bishop G2 that's so easy to miss oh my
God wait but done it while this is
happening way is six seconds left we
gotta go back to our bird's eye view
because shockingly Alice Lee is back in
the game I mean gosh she was completely
lost and now she's better
oh she's better she might win this can
you forgive me Robert for assuming that
this game was over it was totally over
she might win how in the world is this
happening she was down in exchange for
nothing and now she's a past H Pawn her
King is going to G3 the pawn is going to
H2 and that pawn is promoting
she was up in exchange she was mating
and she was promoting a past pawn and
she had more time on the clock Jim and
June can't believe her eyes King G3 is
the devastating thread followed by H2
and H1 somehow Alice Lee it's like she's
made 10 moves and Jew and June has made
zero her Bishop is still on its initial
Square Bishop D2 the email bar continues
to dwindle King G3 might end it oh my
gosh King F3 I mean look at this just
pushing your pawn and if King has to
slide to G1 to hide in front of the
passer the black king goes into E2
hitting the Rook hitting the bishop oh
my goodness
this beggar this this is unbelievable
and you know the best thing for Alice
Leach that she's got two minutes and she
has to use it it's very important for
her to take her time you can see how
nervous she is she senses the gravity of
this moment Bishop H6 comes to mind as
well involving the last minor piece
Robert but she still has to be accurate
whites rook and Bishop are going to do
everything within their power to keep
blacks past pawns at Bay
yes and it's a nail biter of a position
and she is biting her nails Bishop H6
going take take on E3 with check I love
that down here because the E4 Pawn it's
double and isolated but it's gonna
actually become a passer once she plays
it she's finding all the best moves
Bishop Bishop F2 and the Knight it's
both defending and attacking it's
keeping the F Pawn at Bay June June has
to find some way uh to go to this Knight
off of G4 and run that F Pawn up the
board but it's so much easier said than
done 20 seconds for Jew and June a rook
Sally to D7 she's gonna try to take a
seven but that should not work if Alice
Lee plays this right maybe bishop F2
maybe even C4 robber quick note that
wagy has just won his game because
Nicholas Theodore Blended a bishop and
then a rook it was a complicated
position where you was better but wayi
takes that for the Shanghai tires let's
stick to this one and we can go over the
finish of that one in a bit but Daniel
what just happened Rook takes a seven
then Knight F2 check and Alice Lee is
trying to use one pass spawn to stop The
Rook from preventing the other this is
so hard to calculate
oh my gosh
what is happening here so Knight takes
F6 then you just I think it takes Ace me
I don't know oh because he do Knight F2
check and you win the game by oh man
this is amazing that after E3 F7 you go
Knight F2 check and the bishop let's put
it on the board the bishop has to take
the Knight on F2 and then after Pawn
takes F2 you're threatening F1 equals
Queen mate The Rook comes back the
bishop slides back to H6 so you stop the
F Pawn for white but white cannot stop
the F Pawn for black
Bishop H6 is the hardest move to see in
that entire line it's easy to assume
that the f-pod promotes E3 is fearless
and it's the only winning move Knight
takes up six loses oh my
oh my oh it's back and forth game here
and I mean how does black stop this Pawn
there's no way because the Rook moves F7
and then A7 happens next
too late E3 but still black could turn
this around Knight g49 F2 right a bomb
promotes a check
oh my gosh a knight G4 A7 and you don't
Knight F2 check in time but you whoever
A7 King E2 like can you somehow fight
this game on with King E2 King takes
Bishop if white Queens I have seen much
crazier things than that Alice has to
try it she goes that F2 she's gonna Bank
her hopes on that E Pawn but you and
June could even no she can't give her
Queen up for the e-pawn because black
has enough past pawns remaining how does
white stop the pawn after A8 and E2 this
isn't easy this is easy this is one of
the craziest games I've ever seen and
Alice has to play E2 she does Rook G1
but get a queen here how do you make
progress for what
Rook G2 and Rook takes E2 would have
ended it immediately juven June has to
eliminate the pawn she's gonna win it
yeah yeah no because I I was thinking
like all the pawns were protected like
if the bishop could be on D4 and that
black pawn was on F2 rather than H2
you'd have a chance but no this looks uh
pretty simple now but yeah Alice
dropping all of her pawns yeah I would
just keep that pawn alive on B3 the last
thing you want is to give black the
bishop and the C Pawn this is absolutely
heartbreaking Robert yeah she played
some enterprising chess but she resigns
do when June takes it that's huge for
the Shanghai Tigers because now they
take this round two and a half one half
and Daniel I mean that was a topsy-turvy
game between these two and the other
games were no less exciting
it was completely winning for Jew in
June but what incredible defensive value
and she had to re-adapt herself to a
crazy situation and she ultimately pulls
through a huge win and a second round
win with the same score Robert leading
them to an only a two-point lead it
feels like they've climbed Kilimanjaro
and Everest and hey they're only up two
points and we know how quickly a
two-point lead can be erased in the PCL
certainly it feels like we've been here
forever with only two rounds in the
books the St Louis archbishops have a
chance to strike back after this break
we'll see if they're able to this is the
pro chess League this is St Louis versus
Shanghai and these are the eight players
you see and we will be right back
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter is
NBA wearing a blitz Jersey Maxime hey
buddy I love you welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the wheels came off wow she
just took down Hikaru Nakamura and look
at her she is jubilant entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion
we win we win oh my God my friends it's
the 2023 Pro chess League which team can
Rise Above the Rest they won't be able
to do it alone
without fabulous carwana in the lineup
for the St Louis archbishops the
question is can that man on the screen
in front of you carry them to Victory so
far as Shanghai tigers have been out to
a lead but lenier Dominguez the former
World Blitz Champion the super Grand
Master the professional he can lead them
to Glory he has done so in the past
Tanya I've been mesmerized by the
bookshelf behind him he's got the new in
chess yearbook uh many years as editions
and for very good reason he is a opening
specialist and he will have to use all
of the strengths in his game to deliver
in the final two game we're seeing here
the previous PCL Champion St Louis
archbishops and Lewis archbishops and
Lewis archbishops St Louis the
archbishops and STL those are the most
dangerous team in the league of course
the Armenia Eagles in 2018 that was an
unforgettable season as well yes and
Leonard Dominguez was part of a previous
winner he would like to earn himself
another title and he's told me that he
wants to focus a bit more on online
chess of course there are so many events
happening he wants to take part in them
so to this point it hasn't been his best
showing when he's at his best he wins
world Blitz championships but so far
he's been held so going into the third
round of action he will need to get on a
winning foot because he's had a couple
draws been solid games but in round
three he takes on zhuenju
yeah I mean if you are the St Louis
archbishops you're in incredibly
dangerous territory because you could
conceivably lose the match here first
team to eight and a half wins so with a
three and a half half or 4-0 Victory the
Tigers take this match that means every
board becomes crucial there is no margin
for air Robert and lanyard Dominguez is
gonna have to take some risks with the
black pieces Jew and June is a 1d4
player so I'm actually very excited to
see what we will see from lender
dominguez's opening lab
and way he gets the white piece against
Benjamin Bach and of course fan favorite
Alice Lee she will take the white pieces
against Grandmaster Shu Yi from Shanghai
so I think I like to look at those
bottom boards where I see that the adoru
gets white Alice Lee gets white if the
archbishops can hold on the top two
boards with black they need to strike
with the white pieces on boards three
and four they absolutely do and shuyi
um he was on the defensive in the
previous round but now we'll see how he
plays when the shoe is on the other foot
um okay now I will uh let you talk and I
will stay silent yeah that one was uh
you know a rough one but I will too long
of a windup
yeah well you know you have had better
ones it still wasn't bad but who needs
to be great in this round is Leonard
Dominguez he gets the black pieces
against women's world champion Jun now
uh Jew and June survived that first game
against Nicholas theodoro she was lost
even in the final position but she got a
repetition by checks she survived in
time travel in game two that was a
seesaw battle against Alice Lee she
ended up winning now she gets white she
can breathe a little bit of sigh of
relief because the new game is a new
start but for Linda Dominguez no more of
this Queen's Gambit accepted he knows he
needs to win
get that out of here maybe a nice Vienna
with d takes C4 join June does play the
Catalan as well uh she's very good at it
and she's deciding right now no Knight
C3 is on the board rogozin is Lenor
dominguez's choice so not necessarily
the most combative opening but at least
you're avoiding four straws Robert there
are no lines in which white is able to
essentially force a symmetrical position
June June playing a line that has become
very very popular in recent months with
A4 check forces the Knight to C6 in
order to prevent black from contesting
the center with C5 but lender says I'm
not gonna go to C5 I'm going E5 right
break open the center challenge White's
better Center because White had two
pawns now just one this is a known
variation that's been played for many
many years where white can play F4 and
has just done that but black can take on
C3 and if your Bishop takes C3 white
gets the bishop pair but Donna do you
remember a certain Magnus Carlson game
against Anish giri in a line just like
this
what tournament
I don't even remember what tournament it
was but Magnus Bishop takes C3 for white
he went there's a queen E7 a castle
kingside something like that where he
just gave up the E3 poem with check put
his King in the corner and then attacked
uh on the uh on the king side I'll look
that game up during the break I feel
like when you say Magnus Geary in the
regosan like 20 games are gonna come up
so I'm gonna spend the rest of the show
sifting through uh all of their games in
one particular opening Bishop takes E3
on the board now from a uninitiated
rogozin player's perspective Robert I've
played it with black I'm not too
familiar with the intricacies after
Queen E7 the move that tempts me from
White's perspective especially Queen
side Castle you could conceivably give
up both your enf pawns open up the f
file and those Bishops oh those Bishops
have blood on their mind as they stare
down the barrel of black king side
yeah it's a very interesting variation
it's Dynamic play it's giving up two
pawns for an attack whether it's worth
it that's the big question that the
player with the white pieces has to
answer but Dominguez is he unfamiliar
with this opening is that what's going
on by the way in board two like that we
have some strange things happening we
are getting all weakening it I am just
confirming that we are in fact seeing a
I can't it's a center game in way he's
game against Benjamin Bach when was the
last time we saw this in top level chess
science chagorn in 1894
I feel like Jana pomshi has played the
center game several times where if we
just go through the opening just for
move one uh we can show you how we got
here that
white plays D4 and early D4 and after
Pawn takes Queen takes Knight C6 it's
like didn't your coaches tell you not to
bring your queen out early because it
gets kicked around I believe that Jan is
like Queen E3 a bunch of times in this
variation in the center game uh then
tries to go Knight C3 Bishop D2 and
Castle but here where he plays Queen C4
and I'm out of book I have never seen
this before
so the only experience I have with this
Magnus Carlson has played this
particular setup against me in some
bullet games with the queen on C4 do not
ask me what the Rimer reason is behind
this move what the method is behind the
madness the only uh proposal I can give
is that after Bishop D2 and long Castle
White will try to go F3 and quickly run
the pawns off the board English attack
style and Tempo moves Robert are good
black can go Bishop E6 with Tempo but
oftentimes the queen can withdraw back
to E2 and it's surprisingly hard for
black to get the get the gasoline going
on the queen side you can push your own
pawns up the board but it's gonna be a
while until they reach the third rank
yeah this position I mean it looks very
stable for black and F3 was just played
it's not about the initial evaluation
Wei was the one who decided to play this
he's moving instantly every turn I think
he's going for the long term pressure
and saying to Benjamin Buck you need to
prove that you can hold this position
with G4 coming a storm up the king side
it's not like this is going to be a
devastating attack but it just looks
like a fun position uh where but it's
not a symmetrical position Kings and
opposites the board both sides will have
their chance at an attack
and I love this from way it's a daring
decision I love unconventional openings
and he doesn't just want to make you
know a draw from a position of weakness
and hold a passive position he wants to
end this match with a victory he's got
the white pieces he is the favorite and
this is exactly what you need to be
doing when you're leading in a match you
need to make sure that this does not go
down to the wire because we know what
tends to happen in the PCL the queen has
gone back to E2 Knight D4 is another
Tempo move that's tempting but after
Queen F2 that Knight on D4 is not stable
you can support it with a pawn but then
the D6 Pawn is weakened and White's
night can finally come out and once the
Knight on D4 is smoked out of there
lacket experience problems in the center
as well yeah and I we saw Jasper in the
chat rooting for Benjamin Buck nice to
see Grandmaster streamers supporting
other Grandmaster streamers uh but way
he doesn't want any part of that he says
I don't have to share my thoughts in
front of a big audience and the twitch
chat he's like let me just go forward on
the king side he wants to unleash an
attack and he's also has a huge lead on
the clock this could play a big part in
determining the results of this game so
while Benjamin thinks let's go to our
bird's eye view because all four games
are underway I see in the bottom left
Nicholas theodoro with the white pieces
nothing too special happening just yet
as black has created this Pawn structure
in the bottom left to play C5 in the top
left Lenny Dominguez played the move G6
wow that opens up the dark Square bishop
and then we see in the bottom right it's
Alice Lee against shuyi that game has
just begun Alice with the white pieces
she'll want to get on the scoreboard
after two tough defeats and positions
that were at various times is good for
her and it's just so important to keep
your head up to extract the positive she
is very much in the game she was oh so
close to defeating Jew and June and she
is solid with white I think she's in the
right frame of mind and and upset right
now would come at exactly the right time
so I propose we take a quick look at
Theodore's game uh because things might
happen there in the center and perhaps
then go back to linear Dominguez
fascinating where it goes an affair the
Knight has appeared on E5 Nicholas is a
big fan of these Catalan type setups
where he exerts pressure on the C6 Pawn
Knight takes E5 but probably be
ill-advised not because it loses a piece
but because white clamps down on the D6
Square so yipping Lou has a couple of
problems to solve Robert and if he can
squeeze in the move C5 then most of the
time black eradicates any issues that he
might otherwise experience he's a very
solid player we saw the reason he lost
to Benjamin Buck I will say it was that
early Pawn push to E5 and in this game
if you push C5 too early you pay the
price you can't do it of course now the
bishop 1 B7 is hanging but it's all
about that C5 push how does black make
it happen uh moves that come to mind for
me Rook C8 very standard move slide your
rook and behind that pawn protect it on
its square at night from F6 to D5 just
to blunt that diagonal and to blockade
the D file because something that people
should note is that oftentimes black
wants white to make the move Pawn E2 to
E4 but whoa luya ping says I am going to
instead take this Knight on E5 drop the
Knight back but in comes the white
knight from E4 to D6 Donya this looks
very pleasant for theodoro this is what
I was talking about I guess decided that
he doesn't have a realistic chance of
squeezing in C5 he changes the pawn
structure he pins his hopes on that E5
Pawn being weak you mentioned that white
does not want to go E4 automatically and
white certainly does not want to go F4
unless he absolutely has to it's really
not the end of the world but weakening
your king permanently giving the queen a
check on B6 black could still follow up
with C5 and the last thing you want is a
trade of light squared Bishops because
then the weakness of White's King side
becomes permanent I like Bishop F4
keeping the king safe and Paving the way
for a night maneuver right into the
heart of Black's position this is
unpleasant stuff for yipping Lou and I
feel like for black this is actually a
critical moment if Knight E4 you may
play Knight C5 that forces the knights
off the board that doesn't mean that
black is equalizing all of a sudden but
at least there's not a knight sitting on
the D6 Square just stopping your pieces
from connecting so I feel like 94 will
be met by this Knight C5 but that's why
Theodore is thinking here the advantage
still white despite the double pawns
because the pressure along the C file or
the control of the D file but Daniel I
mean it's a nice try here from the
Shanghai Tigers uh he you know he's has
to survive this game the board four but
I think it's a good effort
Nicholas Theodore has to win and at this
point we are in must win territory for
the higher rated player right now the E5
Pawn is hanging and black will capture
it if given the opportunity because
there is no way as things currently
stand to put pressure on the E5 Knight
so perhaps an imaginative move like 94
preparing Queen C3 in response to Knight
takes E5 is what the doctor ordered but
as you indicated Robert Knight C5 leads
to an exchange of knights and that is
not something that Nicholas Theodore has
to undertake without deep thought so
we'll leave him uh to his devices here
he is going to invest a little bit of
time figuring out a proper course of
action in this critical moment we have
all we can eat here in round three
Robert of the first match crazy stuff on
all the boards yeah in the top left look
at that one between Jew and June and
linear Dominguez I think we should go
back there we of course will get to Alex
Lee's game shortly uh but in the top I
mean look at this they're Bishops
staring at the black king Leonard
Dominguez he is down on the clock his
opponent June June has a pair of Bishops
and I'm looking at this like why is
white not just much better I see the Evo
Bar says it's only a smidgen better for
June June
yeah the email bar is just calmly
sitting there it's sipping on its
espresso while Society is burning around
that battery on the F7 upon that Bishop
entrenched as it is on E5 I guess the
point is that there aren't actually any
concrete threats as of yet on the king
side there is of course the threat of
snagging the B7 Pawn this threat
Dominguez probably has to address
because C7 Pawn is gonna fall as well
maybe B6 maybe even C6 to defend that
pawn with a queen but both of those
moves Robert create further weaknesses
on the Kings on the queen side and
you're putting a lot of strain on your
position B6 there might be Bishop D5 and
even a move like G4 deflecting the
bishop off of F5 very very dangerous
territory or lanyard here and you know
one of the things he's considering is if
White had a free turn is Queen takes B7
a threat he says no and I was going to
say this queen C5 will be the response
so you have to be very very careful if
actually if you take on B7 you're just
gonna get in some big trouble and Knight
D2 by the way is another follow-up that
black has because uh at 4 the rook and
the bishop and suddenly black is taking
material still holes on the king side
and that's why uh you know black oh this
would be of course be winning for black
mother Checkmate sorry
and some other checkmate's always fun
it's a must show uh but I do think that
even if black somehow goes up in
exchange that eval bar is saying that
white is okay because Black's King is In
Harm's Way the bishop 185 is so strong
the bishop 1 C4 teaming up with it but
this is the big question can you get
away with snagging B7 I feel like Jew
and June will not go for it no I think
she should find a way around it it's not
a practical decision there was a
computer move there that as you said
miraculously enabled white to keep the
balance she's thinking about it but
perhaps the immediate Bishop D5 is what
the doctor ordered as painful as it is
to part ways with one of your Bishops I
think you need to get rid of this Knight
on e4 because this Knight is really the
source of all of your problems 92
is a very easy move to miss it's like a
hidden fourth fret Queen C5 is on tap as
well so a critical moment here and top
players Robert not only are they
accurate in their decision making they
know when to take their time that's a
particularly impressive skill when you
don't have a lot of time to begin with
Bishop D5 is on the board great play by
the women's world champion and great
call by you let's take the match score
into account it is five to three
Shanghai Leonard Dominguez is the higher
rated player and just to show a quick
line of bring up analysis board what I
would do if I were Jew in June and I'm
up 5-3 is that after C6 I would take on
e4 I would then take on d8 and then I
played Rook D1 and I'm like let's get
everything off the board let's just make
a draw let's shake those hands another
half point for Shanghai getting closer
to match Victory eight and a half points
is the score you need so I think this is
what I would do if I were Jew and June I
wouldn't be surprised if this happens I
mean Leonardo Dominguez is very
professional he's playing a strong
Grandmaster at the women's world
champion but this may happen so well he
thinks let's zoom out for a second
because a lot of action is heating up
and look at board four we keep talking
about Alice Lee there's a reason for it
she's playing higher rated opposition
every single round and Donya she's
throwing her pawns forward on the king
side there's an open H file her King
looking a little bit open but let's dive
right into the game here because she
just brought her Knight to F3 and that
Knight is coming into the E5 square and
I feel like this position is just fun
for her not to mention the G5 Pawn is
hanging on the spot because opening the
H file is devastating at least a
checkmate
this is an incredibly precarious
situation for shuyi I mean Knight takes
G5 F takes G5 threats all around the
board the pawn structure obviously does
not tell the whole tale it doesn't tell
any of the tale and Alice Lee you know
it's a good example of why the score
doesn't tell the whole story she's
played very high level chess she came oh
so close to defeating Jew and June and
now she's got another serious chance and
upset would go a very very long way
toward keeping St Louis in this match
but right now shui has a clear threat to
deal with Knight takes G5 would be an
absolute disaster he wants to find a way
to get the Queens off the board but
Robert if you play Queen G6 hastily then
white will happily trade and then take
on H6 when the attack continues in the
end game
that's right just because the Queens
come off the board does not mean that
sudden the king is safe especially with
Brooks and Rook E4 played and we see the
evil bar creeping up a little bit uh I'm
sorry can we just take on G5 and 92 yeah
that's exactly what you're indicating
and it's Desperate Times Desperate
Measures he is going to give up in
exchange maybe this is a good practical
Choice Donna and this is what's
happening each takes G5 is forced Knight
D2 Nets Alice Lee a clean exchange The
Rook cannot move
oh she doesn't go she goes to the G5
Pawn instead I understand that though
that's actually not a bad decision
because she's simultaneously threatening
the G5 pawn and Rook D to H1 with checks
on the H file so I get what she's doing
but Knight D2 would have won an exchange
there it would have been exchange I
think that's true you missed that night
Retreats are famously the hardest kind
of move to see I think Alice Lee
overlooked Rook FEA that is such a
tilting defensive move Robert the king
is going to use its own two feet to run
out of the G file to f8 it's going to go
potentially evacuate toward the center
but it's surprisingly safe on f8 and to
further add to White's troubles is the
fact that Rook H1 is not going to be
effective because the h8 square is going
to be protected by Black's Queen so
suddenly shuyi has positioned his pieces
very nicely and Alice Lee once again she
might be losing the threat of the game
here she needs to hunker down and maybe
play a couple of modest moves like Rook
takes G5 and just rookie one not the
greatest thing in the world but I
definitely think she will preserve her
advantage and being up a pawn with a
weak black king not the worst outcome in
the world yeah spring open analysis
board just show if we go back a couple
moves there then Knight D2 why that was
so strong because some of our viewers
may not see it the Rook cannot move if
it moves anywhere then Queen H7 is
checked and mate so the Knight would
capture The Rook but the reason shuyi
did this he did not Overlook Knight D2
is that he was going to play rookie
eight after Knight takes Rook he was
going to take back and he says look at
White's Pawn structure it's actually
really ugly many vulnerable apology I
actually think from a practical
perspective black is very much in this
game so I get why this has just happened
from both sides but for Alice she did
just take the pawn on G5 with her Knight
so if the Rook takes on E3 she'll go
Queen H7 check and who knows what's
going on I certainly do not
is there Checkmate there it's
interesting our intuitions differ I feel
like sure you overlooked 92 but I
totally get what you're saying that
resulting position does hold a lot of
practical chances for black but that
ship has sailed that's water under the
bridge Knight goes forward rather than
backward now brackets keep the Rook on
e4 but Robert without the G5 Pawn that
down in exchange position is no longer
tenable he has to try Rook takes E3 here
we go Queen H7 check is not forced Alice
could drop her Queen back to C2 but that
would be pretty anticlimactic it would
give like a crucial defensive Tempo but
what is the follow-up after Queen H7
King f8 don't forget that white skin is
also shaking in its boots with Rook take
C3 a potentially massive threat well let
me ask you something let's just bring up
analysis report we have to Dive Right In
Queen H7 check oh King King f8 now a
couple things Knight takes up seven is
where I was going but if the queen were
gone from H7 Knight H7 check would be a
fork if you could take your own Queen
you would fork and win the black queen
but Knight takes F7 is what I wanted to
look at because you're opening up the f
file I know C3 is hanging and the white
king is in Dire Straits but so is the
black king and I just don't know I'm
being honest I don't know how to
evaluate we have the you see the eval
bar we don't have the moves it's scary
stuff for both sides
it is and if you take the Knight on F7
after Rook F5 black does have Knight F6
but don't stop calculating here the
check on H6 is going to pick up either
the Knight or The Rook but Alice Lee has
taken the more conservative approach
once again she did deliver the check on
H7 and she acted on your first piece of
advice bringing the queen back to C2
threatening obviously a fork on H7 and
decisions decisions now for shui there
are so many ways to defend against that
fork you can move the king you can move
the queen you can move the King two
different directions even King G8 is
actually not totally out of the question
because the h8 square might need to be
protected this is a very unenviable
situation actually for both players yeah
I think that even with the Queens up
they're still in the tech Queen G6 we
swap Queens Rook H7 is an idea or rookie
h8 check so like you just have so many
options to calculate here and while
shuyi does that we will be back to this
game we promise but we have to look
every single game is of equal importance
in the Pro chess League uh not if you're
bored one if you're bored four the point
is a point in the top left we will see a
to draw most likely between Leonard
Dominguez and June June but Dominguez
may be trying to seek an advantage here
and his King is coming in
his King is coming in and opposite
colored Bishop end games they can be
very deceptive yes there is very high
Josh potential but he's got that three
on two on the queen side he's going to
try to create a pass pawn and squeeze
his King in June June has to keep the
blacking at Bay but Dominguez is going
to get his King to E4 I think should we
take a closer look at that the Nicholas
theodoro game is also on fire I'll give
you the final say Robert I'm just gonna
point out in the top right way you just
made a move and it looks like suddenly
Benjamin Buck has control that's the top
right of your screen look at the pawn
failings in the center for black up
material with an attack of his own the
dark Square Bishop not compensating for
all those pawns he's down so away Yi is
in some trouble St Louis having a good
round right now
having a good round indeed lender
Dominguez is in the driver's seat but I
do think juanchoon should be able to
hold that position with two minutes we
can take a closer look at Benjamin box
game because that might be absolutely
decisive imagine a win with the black
Pieces by Benjamin Bach how much of a
long way that would go uh toward
allowing St Louis to make the comeback
in the final round Queen D6 is the last
move that we see now it's not all bad
news Robert forway he's got a very
impressive set of minor pieces in the
center never mind then I just dropped
back that opens up the diagonal for his
bishop and the queen could travel from
F2 to D4 this game is wide open it's far
from over Benjamin is definitely
objectively better I think he's even up
a pawn yes he is but with one and a half
minutes can he handle these
complications you know this better than
anybody as the highest rated bullet
player at chess.com that this is the
type position where the evil bar goes
out the window because look at the
bishop on C3 and as you're highlighting
Queen F2 Queen D4 if you could get that
Queen into the action and if that black
queen moves Knight G3 will be White's
Choice as well to get that Knight out of
H5 drive it away and then you're gonna
use the dark Sports your adventure what
actually is Black's idea here he plays
E3 and now if Bishop E5 you win yourself
in exchange and I do not like that The
Rook sacrificed immediately on E5 you
get yourself a second pawn and a bishop
for a rook so Benjamin Bach is unafraid
but I'm looking at the clock Tanya two
minutes four-way Yi under a minute four
bedroom box I think the position
right now it's scary F5 Queen D4 as
you're pointing out that looks really
dangerous in a 30 second game I'm going
F5 immediately you want to be careful
about cashing in your chips too soon
it's on the board and Benjamin might
have overlooked that rookie 4 runs into
Queen takes E4 lpdo x-rays oh things
very important the queen on D6 is
unprotected Queen D4 coming next
Benjamin might have to throw his Pawn up
to F6 and use his own King to stand
between this battery and Checkmate this
is very precarious Robert A7 is going to
be hanging with Chuck I feel like wayi
is taking over this game he is me D5 is
hanging A7 is hanging the dark Square
diagonal is in trouble and Knight G3
will be thrown in at some moment you
have to watch out for that the last
thing that black wants to do is take a
knight that comes on G3 with his Knight
it opens up the H file another Avenue of
attacks GF if King F7 is Queen takes A7
check you point out you have to look at
that diagonal over there and honestly
Knight G3 next is scary in many
positions as well
oh my gosh 30 seconds for Benjamin this
is where that extra minute is worth its
weight in gold take on A7 if you're way
you keep the pressure on Black's clock I
think Benjamin can hold things together
for the time being with Queen D7 instead
he goes Knight G3 keeping his options
open trying to open that eight file you
called it and there's so much tension on
the board how is Benjamin gonna handle
this with 20 seconds
I don't know because of 19 H Street the
H7 Pawn is threatened God Queen takes he
takes out C2 but now Queen A7
he notices yeah he noticed it he kind of
looked upset at himself Queen takes A7
there's no good way to block the King
has to go up to E6 and then what done it
maybe Knight back to E2 into D4 that's
leading towards the checkmating attack
my gosh that microwave behind Benjamin
box King is gonna end up in that
microwave 92 when the attack reaches 600
Degrees where he sees everything he's
not gonna let this opportunity slip he
is going to bring the hammer down and
deliver a huge win if he can make a
couple more accurate moves take your
time if you're way you've got plenty of
it I would deliver the check on D4
Robert maybe another check on B4 and
once the king gets to E5 a quiet move
like Queen D7 could essentially give
white uh The Mating material that he
needs but let's not forget Knight D4
check also hits the bishop on C2 so you
could probably even just you can just
trade queens and take a free bishop and
win the game that way
I mean a Soviet Schoolboy mode take on
C2 the pawn down here is virtually equal
this wins Bishop B4 wins you're spoiled
for choice but something tells me Wei
has blood on his mind he's got the H7
Pawn on his mind he took A7 and now H7
and he's not gonna change yeah but he
controls all the important scores as
Rook takes D1 just take that Bishop back
Knight D4 check his next G6 is hanging
he goes F7 so he I think he's playing in
box time travel in part uh but okay now
you take onion
66. yeah you win the queen on B6 came
over FEA
wow just wow that's it Benjamin's gonna
resign here
yeah he's upset with himself because he
was up haunts but he loses the game way
a big victory for Shanghai and Dominguez
and Zhu and June they drew their game so
as we go back to our four board scene
you've seen the top left it's opposite
colored Bishops only one extra pawn it
is a draw with the blockade there in the
bottom left it looks like Lou yaping for
Shanghai he is no longer worse but Shu
Yi or Shanghai is also better this is as
bad news as it gets for the Archbishop
if both boards are won by Shanghai the
match is over I cannot believe I'm
saying that St Louis archbishops they
never lose oh my gosh the the
archbishops have no Bishops left on any
of the remaining boards and Nicholas
theodoro has lost the threat of the game
completely Liu ping might just end this
match with a victory the king is running
to C4 but let's go to our other Ward
because Alice Lee she needs to deliver a
victory and she is also losing the
threat she's losing all of her pawns
this might be over Robert if Louisa peng
and shui win their games this match is
over before it enters round four who on
Earth would have thought that this would
be the narrative but we'll count the
eggs when they've hatched we've seen
crazier things in the PCL can St Louis
mount a final stand Nicholas theodoro or
Alice Lee at least they need to pull out
a draw in order to get themselves a
chance in the fourth round it's looking
very bad on this board down two pawns
and I just want to say this that if I
were the captain in Nemo or the manager
of the St Louis archbishops I'm playing
Alice Lee again you said this earlier
her result is not a testament to how
well she has played she's gonna lose
this game rookie two check now can scoop
up the G2 Pawn as well uh of course the
C Pawn go up to C4 and you get a passer
there but Alice Lee has played great
chess if you just look at the advantages
she's had it's just been in time trouble
it's been uh you know she's been under
duress on the clock and that has been
the reason she hasn't been on the
scoreboard but she is giving these 2500
plus GMS all they can handle so good on
Alice Lee She's gonna fight back to this
game by the way it's not completely over
even though black is about to scoop up
another Pawn here maybe there's some
chances for the white Rook to get active
I think that Nicholas Theodore though
has the better chances of pulling off a
miracle he might be close but Liu ping
is about to promote a pawn I think we
should go to our other game because I
mean three pawns up let's be real I
think shui is going to finish this off
he's also got 90 seconds on the clock
but definitely kudos to Alice League she
should hold her head up high take a look
at the games and come back stronger
let's go back to our bird's eye view
because the other game might be the
decisive when Nicholas theodoro hanging
by a single thread can he stop that
b-pawn let's see if we can swing back to
that game
okay we'll try to do that and it looks
like Alice Lee is going down in this one
down three pawns at the moment and yeah
it looks like King G7 that's all you can
ask for but let's in the bottom left we
see that oh back and forth the eval bar
is on the Seesaw it's a draw and St
Louis lives to fight another day they at
least can fight another round oh my gosh
that was a winning end game it looked
like for black
but yeah that just uh was a misstep
there in the end so I guess Alice Lee we
got to go back there we can I guess what
do you want to do done do I dive in to
what we just missed or should we just
see the final moves of Alice's game
against shui let's see the final moves
of that game because The Narrative of
Theodora's game uh is clear Louisa Peng
was in high pressure he didn't want to
take too many risks he missed a couple
of winning opportunities there now the
score if shui finishes this game off is
gonna be 8-4 that means Robert that
means the San Luis archbishops need to
go 4-0 and that doesn't even win the
match that forces a tie break but that
is some of the most fascinating chess
that we are going to see because we're
gonna see all four players take
ridiculous amounts of risks and this is
what we sign up for when we watch the
PCL but again not to jump the gun here
sure you needs a couple more accurate
moves he needs to avoid blundering a
fork I've seen a ton of games thrown
around with a last second four G5 here
secures the night on F4 yeah the Knight
is protected the Brooklyn A4 I mean this
white king is dancing and prancing but
not getting anywhere although if you can
say kind of take a bunch of the pawns
give up your night for the rest you have
a chance but there's three pawns here as
you said yeah if we're being realistic
just too many extras G3 G2 it's very
straightforward for black
if the time situation were inverted you
could make a case that white as chances
that night it is dancing it is prancing
it's hunting for gold but it's going to
end up bringing about its own demise
King F5 rookie one and I think rookie
two is one way to finish the game
in classy fashion you could also play G1
Queen and pick up the Knight that is
precisely what he does
yeah
Knight and two pawns a good win for sure
Yi it is now eight to four doubled the
score for the Shanghai Tigers over the
Saint Louis archbishops and I mean it's
pretty incredible stuff but in the
fourth and Final Round We will see
lenier Dominguez take on Wei Benjamin
Bach take on June Nicholas Theodore gets
black and shuyi Alice think it's black
against uh Lu yipping so the chances are
not great all Shanghai needs is a single
draw
all they need is a single drop but what
they shouldn't do is play for a draw on
every board they should play the same
way they would play if the score was
whatever you know six six or enough the
score was tied because the way to allow
a miracle comeback is to rely too much
on your teammates and just kind of
assume that you can do whatever they
want so Shanghai is going to take this
game seriously but let's be real Robert
the chances are vanishingly low but we
have seen absolutely everything in our
playing career and our commentating
career so I advise that you go
absolutely nowhere because this would be
the greatest PCL comeback of all time if
Saint Louis can pull it off I'm going to
be honest with you though I think that
St Louis is missing five into carwana
right now because Leonard Dominguez is a
fantastic player but he's a super solid
player he's made three draws you need
victories from him look at Wei off the
three out of three frame games are up
and down you get chances to lose but he
gave himself chances to win so I do
think from St Louis you need to have
that punching power and they have not
had it in today's match there still is a
chance and we will see a fourth and 5
final round after this break but before
we go we want to give a shout out to
something special because chess and
basketball history is being made today
four-time NBA All-Star Luca doncic has
Unleashed his sidekick luke.ai on the
Chess World the new bot joins this
month's slew of AI chess Bots that you
can challenge now the luke.ai bot is
still learning the ins and outs of Chess
but the more plays the stronger it grows
how strong will luke.ai be by February
20th when it battles your favorite
streamers and chess played quick that
much is up to you use the commands of
Luca in chat to play now while the
All-Star break is just days away but
this break is happening right now when
we return it's the fourth and final
round of the pro chess League match
between the St Louis archbishops and the
Shanghai tigers
thank you
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to explain that
you're world champion and it's taking
longer than two words there's something
wrong with your title
there's something wrong with it I
believe in when we're talking in the 60s
and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because they're not going to come
by with it
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's Mr microwave himself you see the
chessboard on top it is cooking he will
need to cook up some great preparation
to win for the St Louis archbishops that
is Grandmaster Benjamin Bach you may
know him from his streams he is
frequently bringing you some
entertainment and chest knowledge but
right now Donya the Shanghai Tigers they
seem to have the archbishop's number and
Benjamin he's going to need to strike
every player for St Louis must win their
game he is indeed I saw something I
can't unsee which is that there is a
chessboard on top of the microphone on
top of the microwave and it's kind of
hanging over the floor so that's all I'm
going to be thinking about well St Louis
uh has some thinking to do they're gonna
have to think about how they're gonna
win four out of four games in order to
force a tie break and I think the
toughest games to win are going to be
the two black games shui uh with the
white pieces against Theodore and Alice
Lee has to beat Louis ping with black
lanyard Dominguez he has not been
particularly convincing today he's
played solid professional chess but he
hasn't been able uh to break his
opponent's resistance he needs a
well-timed victory against sway Robert
the stars have to align but it's also
the PCL and we have seen just about
everything under God's Blue Sky by now
yeah I think if I'm St Louis I'm happy
about boards two and three because
Benjamin Buck gets white Jew and June
playing good chess super strong but
buckets the first move advantage and
then you have Theodore with black he is
kind of a wild card no matter color but
in the Olympiad he scored in metal an
individual medal on his board one
playing for the Greece national team so
you kind of like the fact that those two
on boards two or three will have their
chances but Alice Lee getting black
that's the problem Lou yipping is so
solid he may just force to draw if he
can because that wins the team the match
so I feel like for Alice you might have
to get outside her comfort zone and do
something drastic
this is where we're going to see some
fascinating opening choices and Robert
in Psychology there's something known as
the bystander effect where something bad
is happening and a lot of people are
watching it there's a likelihood that
nobody does anything because each person
thinks that the person next to them is
the one that's going to act and at the
end nobody acts this is what Shanghai
has to avoid if you're way e or Louis
ping you have to avoid thinking that the
result doesn't really matter because God
forbid I lose one of my teammates is
going to pick up the slack there's a
likelihood of that but the best approach
is to just take matters into your own
hands into your own hands and say I'm
going to be the one to ensure Victory so
that we don't have to suffer through
what would be an absolutely ridiculous
miracle
yeah to lose four games in a round I
mean a 4-0 sweep that's pretty much
unheard of it has happened before
I'm sorry buddy I know I didn't want to
bring up bad memories uh but let's see
what Lenny Dominguez chooses in the
opening because this is a super Grand
Master battle these two players well
prepared both very strong but Dominguez
needs to take some risks so where is
that going to come from Dania well first
of all the move D3 is a little bit more
open-ended you are avoiding some very
forcing lines
including the open Roy Knight 64 which
is notorious for producing long
theoretical lines and forced draw so I
like this Choice bilinear you're going
for an open-ended relope position where
you have a chance to outplay your
opponent but that is only the beginning
that's the easy part the hard part is
going to be to break down ways
incredibly solid Play Bishop comes out
to G5 which is one way to play this
position you can also keep the bishop on
C1 and focus on getting your knight to
G3 so position is equal Robert
objectively but it's full of life and
linear I think is off to a pretty decent
start I like what he's doing because he
is trying to provoke the move G5 and
it's a perfectly reasonable move for
black at this stage you have a castle
kingside and even when you do Castle
kingside in this kind of structure it's
often all right but it is a double-edged
position chances for both you've
overextended perhaps allowing white to
counter it both on the king side and in
the center so I think that linear he's
choosing a smart opening he's not going
all in in a way that will just cause him
to lose as if way he finds a couple
accurate moves he's keeping tension now
single Pawn has been traded and D4 will
be flicked in sooner rather than later I
like what linear has done in the opening
he's also has a lead in the clock
yes he does I mean way he is deciding
between G5 and a more modest approach
maybe even B5 the same move on the other
side he can Castle he can delay castling
so a lot of decisions to be made and you
want to force your opponent to make a
lot of decisions in the opening in the
context of a 10 minute game when you're
already up a minute on the clock so
definitely off to a good start Robert to
tie up the reference I made earlier when
I was part of the California unicorns we
lost a match to the Minnesota blizzard
we were leading by three points going to
the final round we lost 4-0 and we ended
up losing the entire match so not quite
as crazy as this comeback would be
because they would also have to win the
tiebreaker but that was one of the most
painful PCL days of my life where he
continues to ponder his move he's down
out down 90 seconds
great news for the St Louis archbishops
and the second board has also started so
uh let's just zoom out for a second
while wait he thinks Willie pushes b or
Jeep on the top right we see a dynamic
opening uh that position is not
symmetrical and it's always good when
you're in a must win position so
Benjamin buck with the black pieces it
was this kind of neocataline it's kind
of a benoni colors reverse and then in
the bottom left Nicholas theodoro gets
the YP says we have a rosalimo sicilian
that means we might have some fireworks
there as well
absolutely I mean these are three
winnable games these are three winnable
games for the archbishops I will uh make
a small correction I think Benjamin Buck
uh is in fact playing with the white
pieces uh against Jew and June so he is
the one uh deploying the kind of reverse
modern benoni which is a very very good
choice and one liberating thing not to
spin this falsely right the situation is
really bad uh it's painful for the
archbishops we're not expecting to be in
this position but you can essentially
rule out any option that leads to a draw
that actually eases your task right
because you don't need to calculate
certain things that you think might lead
to an overly symmetrical position and
the opening choices thus far by the
archbishops have been good but once
again that is only step one
yeah but look at the lead on the clock
like we saw Dominguez he jumped out to a
lead on time because way you was
thinking here already Benjamin buck up a
minute and B4 as a pressing question uh
can you take this Pawn on B4 and the
answer is you probably shouldn't because
after Knight takes before yeah there's a
quick line well swap nights Rook takes
E5 and then white has the better light
Square Bishop has gonna attack this
isolated Pawn on D4 later so it's just a
promising position for him and that's
what we're getting so this is a great
start for Benjamin Bach and the
archbishops
a bit of a panicky decision there by the
Women's World Champion she simplifies
the game she trades pieces off the board
she's thinking about tossing in the move
E4 not out of the question uh and the
fact that she's even noticing this uh is
actually very impressive E4 leads to
some crazy complications Benjamin could
drop the Knight back in response and
essentially get the same structure so I
don't think that really changes
necessarily the nature of the game but
Juju is burning more clock thinking
about this she does play E4 the evil bar
continues to creep up
what gives here is it Nightside too
Knight C2 looks good Rook to B1 is also
an option you'll give up the F3 Knight
but you will still have the same Dynamic
with a great light Square Bishop staring
at the enemy B7 Pawn the isolated D4
upon that black will have to defend for
the rest of the game now this is really
really good stuff for Benjamin Bach he's
also keeping that healthy lead on the
clock he can play for a win very safely
he can indeed and cautious optimism here
felt by St Louis fans they're doing well
on both of the boards in which they have
the white pieces but that is sort of the
given right the big question is can the
players with black generate enough of an
imbalance and then deliver with a
well-timed victory in particular Alice
Lee who has gotten great positions but
has struggled in time pressure so let's
see how those two players are doing as
we travel back to the bird's eye view a
clear Advantage for Benjamin Buck Alice
Lee has the black pieces in the lower
right they have a rosalimo sicilian
which is not a bad opening honestly
Robert in terms of generating winning
chances she also has the bishop pair so
interesting play there and Nicholas
theodoro I like what he's doing as well
he's got an advantage there with block
against Nicholas against shui with the
Bishops lined up very nicely and he got
the white king wow because Alice Lee's
position is a little bit more closed
let's start with board three Nicholas
Theodore with black just threw that pawn
to F5 and Daniel I am loving his
position look at the bishop on B7 that
is going to have an open diagonal all
the way across to the enemy King the
queen and Bishop on the dark squares are
also very powerful so whether it's the
light squares or the dark squares black
controls important diagonals Dynamic
play from Nicholas Theodore that Rook is
going to land on F5 soon maybe that Rook
will slide over to G5 and help deliver a
checkmating attack Donya I love what the
archbishops are doing I
that whatever the outcome of the match
is it's clear that they're putting
together a valiant effort each and every
player is doing everything in their
power to unbalance the game shuyi he
tried to orchestrate some pressure on
the queen side but he hasn't finished
putting his pants on and black is
already knocking on the door on the king
side he's up two minutes on the collect
they've got time advantages everywhere
and if white plays one or two more
careless moves this game could be over
in the blink of an eye for example let's
just show assembly he takes that five
Rook takes F5 and now an impulsive move
like C4 opening up the dark squared
Bishop could meet with Bishop H to check
driving the king away The Rook
infiltrates to F2 the queen comes into
G3 and in this particular position white
is already losing so shuyi is investing
his time very wisely to try to keep
Black's initiative at Bay Robert yeah no
he is doing the right thing because he
may find himself the victim of a
devastating attack and we I don't know
what to say because it seems like easy
for black to play you're just going to
take on that five with your Rook next
bring your second Rook to f8 and then
Rook on A4 you wish that it was
somewhere in the center protecting your
king side but it is misplaced despite
the fact that it's upon A6 it is a
long-term Target so you get that pawn
great it is stuck there it's not going
to be a strong one but the king side
pressure is more important but I think
we should zoom out for a second uh just
because I see the eval bar going Sky
High in one of the critical games look
on the top right of your screen Benjamin
Buck is getting it done he's just
winning an exchange and he's going to
win the game
he is getting it done in Furious fashion
he's got that pawn on C4 it is a
protected faster we don't even need to
look at that game more deeply The Rook
on V8 is hanging juven June sacrifices
in exchange out of desperation aiming
for the light squares but she's tied up
Queen C6 meets with Rook B8 check she's
got a weak back rank total collapse
there by June June I think Benjamin Bach
is gonna win the game in just a couple
of moves to Rook B8 forces Black's
Bishop back to C8 no this is over it's a
rook and an extra Pawn for his bishop
and you're pinned and it's just done so
let's instead go into the game in the
bottom right between Lou yaping with
white and Alice Lee because Alice's
position it's out of a sicilian it's a
locked up battle for now I like what she
is doing she's ahead on the clock and
she has this show on chess kid called
Alice's Pawn Palace and look at her
pawns right now C6 and C5 they're
doubled oh that sounds like a bad thing
in the end game you like to say that
pawn structure is an overrated concept
where people put too much stock into it
but look you have a bishop 186 it's
healthily sitting there a black just may
move the move F6 that frees up the queen
to shuffle where it needs to go and
that's what I was going to say next G5
Knight G6 get your pieces going forward
H5 as well you can initiate an attack on
the king side whereas the center is very
clogged
it's clogged and on that note Lui ping
basically has one button and he just
needs to figure out when he's going to
press it it's the B4 button so for
example if we could bring up an L sport
let's say Alice Lee continues to expand
on the king side white can play B4 in
this position I think that's why he
positioned his Queen on C3 Alice Lee
could respond with a trade followed by
A4 this is now a big asset for a block
but robber the bad news for black is
that D4 could come and that King on G7
starts shaking in its boots after the
trade on Z4 tactics are in the air
Knight takes G5 here would virtually end
the game because the queen is x-raying
the king Alice Lee has to be very
careful here she has played G5 and
Louisa Peng has responded with a more
modest move he's off of F3 and Alice Lee
is not mincing her words she is making
her intentions pretty clear H5 is on the
board yeah she is going and she is not
stopping them they came to C4 yeah
what's the Knight doing right the knight
at C4 doesn't actually attack anything
and if I'm Alice I might throw in the
move A4 for black that stops B4 because
if you played before I take on passant
and I hurt White's Pawn structure so A4
is an option H4 on the other flank is an
option you put H4 and then G4 she first
brings her Knight into G6 I love it I
think she's just gonna take all these
squares and when Knight comes to F4 for
black Donya and the White Knight takes
back G takes F4 breaks open the G file
the king might go to H6 we saw that in
her game against weigi the King was safe
and sound on the H6 square a rook to G8
you unleash what could be a vicious
attack luya ping maybe the higher rate
of player he may be the more experienced
player but we keep saying it he prefers
solid chest positions that's why he
hasn't created any pawn breaks all eight
pawns remain he's moving his Knight back
and forth here and there but hither and
dither won't necessarily get you that
draw if black plays H4 Knight F4 and so
on
nowlessly she needs to time it right
right if she plays G4 too early that
could actually backfire Black's king is
not the safest either so it's a very
difficult task still remaining four
hours sleep but she's demonstrating
growth mindset she made a clear
adjustment playing faster in the opening
and early middle game and setting
herself up for Success she's got another
good position and if I'm black I'm going
to massage Queen D7 on the board looking
at Bishop takes H3 looking at G4
covering the F5 Square maybe Louis ping
is pinning his hopes on that F5 Square
you can play Knight G3 the position
probably closer to equal objectively
Robert but if I had to choose a side I
am definitely taking black she's up a
minute on the clock
oh my Lance this is Knight F4 I mean
black is doing great here yeah Knight F4
you just protect your H5 Pawn uh Knight
F5 is just a single check the king
slides out the way I would have
preferred that she prevented this Knight
hopping in because the Knight on E2 was
completely dominated so now at least the
white Knights coordinate and get out
into the open I think that it may have
been a slight inaccuracy black still has
a quite nice position but I think it
would have been preferable as you
started with H4 done just to keep that
Knight at Bay but let's zoom out for a
second just because we know Benjamin
Buck he has a Healthy Advantage on his
board I'm not sure why he hasn't moved
but look at the top left so in the
bottom left Nicholas Theodore is getting
it done for the archbishops and looks
all the way down the eval bar he might
have a checkmating attack but the top
left way Yi has the upper hand against
lenier Dominguez way is such a beast and
he's saying listen I'm going to take
matters into my own hands I'm going
after my opponent with black Dominguez
he's been in shaky form he's clearly
made an adjustment on the clock playing
quite a bit faster than he did in the
first three games but it has come at a
very stiff steep price black is castled
Queen side which is not a common
occurrence in the Rue Lopez and it's
fully justified in this position look at
look at that Bishop look at the pin on
the D2 Knight the immediate threat
Robert is Knight takes E4 and the second
piece of bad news is that moving the
queen does not solve all of White's
problems there could be an exchange sack
on D2 there could even be tactics
related to the bishop on A4 being
undefended as well linear dominguez's
position is on the verge of collapse
right now yeah just to show it done
you're saying we'll pull up and now
support really quickly and then uh just
a really quick line Queen E2 if Rook
takes D2 Queen takes D2 Knight takes E4
your only move is Queen D3 because the
F2 Pawn is pins your Bishop is hanging
but even a black plays F5 here I mean
you just control all the square so this
is not looking Pleasant for white not in
the slightest and black is in the
driver's seat but I I do want to take
this away from here because big things
are happening in The Other Board let's
go back to our bird's eye view because
Alice Lee is showing no fear she just
played Bishop takes Pawn on H3 does she
first sacrificed in a pawn that Louis
pink didn't take and then she sacrificed
a bishop and she's going for the attack
and the bishop he did take and could he
have afforded to take the bishop let's
take a closer look Queen takes H3 is
going to be the follow-up what's funny
is that Alice Lee has a Perpetual check
she can play Knight F3 game G2 and
Knight H4 Louboutin cannot step back to
H1 because he gets mated Robert that is
obviously out of the question I think
Queen takes H3 is forced and the second
good piece of news for Alice Lee is that
white could force the exchange of
knights with Knight F5 check and here
you don't take on F5 you bring the king
away and Knight takes H4 would be
immediate harakiri because if G takes H4
and The Rook picks up the slack down the
G file the evil bar is still showing
equality I'm not sure why that is
because obviously the immediate threat
is Knight F3 Checkmate I love the way
that Alice Lee is handling this yeah
there must be some timely F3 for white
that like Saves the Game maybe here
actually in this position F3 because G2
and G3 are covered so the best black
will probably have is some kind of a win
of The Rook for the night but then the
white team will find some shelter yeah
just it maybe just isn't quite enough so
I'm looking at this position and I'm
seeing that she's going for the draw
you can't do that for her team
there's nothing to lose this it's in a
rated game I mean it is not even a
question and she is aware of the score
right sometimes you're not aware of how
your teammates are doing here it
actually doesn't even matter because she
knows that all four players have to win
Alice is burning valuable time right now
she has to take on H3 and finding Knight
gf5 and then F3 a cold blooded defense
like that is not a given the game
doesn't end there Queen takes H3 should
be on the board every second is golden
Alice Lee is hesitating at an important
moment impressive game thus far by her
we'll see if she takes on H3 but let's
go back to our bird's eye view because
something is happening in our board
three matchup we have shuyi with the
white pieces and the Evo bar is all the
way down in Nicholas Theodore's favor
and by the way in the top left it looks
like Leonard Dominguez back in it a
mistake by way not sacrificing The
Exchange Here and Now Leonard Dominguez
has a chance let's go to board three in
the game between shuyi and Nicholas
theodoro because it looks like black is
winning based on the evaluation but in
the position there's a bishop and a
queen staring at the black king is it
just a scary look or is there something
there
it's just a scary look I think Nicholas
Theodore is taking the batteries out of
that construction he is attacking the
bishop on e4 he is defending the G6
square with this Knight he is also
attacking The Rook on A4 and if the Rook
moves up to A7 Bishop takes E4 wins the
game because it simultaneously hits the
queen and blacks Queen it's The Rook on
A7 I think this game is coming to an end
what a win this would be for Nicholas
theodoro and combined with the fact that
Benjamin Bach is up a full Rook that
means that two of St Louis's players
have done their job can Alice Lee and
lanyard Dominguez pull off the
unimaginable Robert that is the big
question it looks like Nicholas Theodore
up what is it two pawns right now his
King is actually not in danger it's the
white men in worse shape five minutes he
I think has under control Knight G4 just
trades off more pieces just take that
Knight there's no risk there you're
probably gonna Checkmate the white king
so let's get out of here just because we
know or we feel very confident that
Nicholas Theodore will take this one
we'll zoom out because of other two
boards where you need to win oh the eval
going up and up for luya Ping but Alice
Lee she is trying to win this game she
is playing on but it looks like she
can't get that attack in the bottom
right because those two pesky Knights
four white they cover all of the vital
squares and perhaps the worst piece of
news isn't the objective eval it's the
fact that Queen on F3 Robert is Tangled
Up it is stuck Behind Enemy Lines or The
Rook could come to F1 and white even has
conceivably a couple of possible
repetitions right Rook H2 and Rook F2
could endlessly pursue the queen between
its only two Escape squares and shui is
definitely aware of the score you've got
something on your mind yeah look at
linear Dominguez clock down under 10
seconds let's dive into that one
Dominguez has to move I know his
position doesn't look good but he needs
to find something one second oh my gosh
I mean he's just getting outplayed by
way
two when he played Bishop G1 wow what a
move Rook H3 was by the way in his
opponent's time trouble and now he pins
that Bishop there
oh my gosh he's barely getting these
moves up wait one second he's not gonna
make it he literally had point one
Knight D4 is going to be a sucker punch
forcing the queen back and he's gonna
flag and that's it yeah his Queen was
getting trapped there's a Checkmate next
Queen he won Queen E3 mate so Wei he
takes the match for Shanghai it's
officially over and Wei ye you know he
went four out of four it's clear he is
the hero that Shanghai needed but we
still have a couple games remaining
Benjamin Buck he's he already won his
game against juvenger that's over in the
top right in the bottom left Nicholas
Theodore he's getting it done against
shuyi and the bottom right Alice Lee had
a draw if she wanted it she decided to
be a team player she kept the game going
it's gonna be for not she may have zero
points when all four games are done but
give credit to the 13 year old she
played some excellent chests today and
this game is not over and she still has
chances and I need to set the record
straight we made it very clear before
the start of the round that a comeback
is vanishingly unlikely but St Louis did
everything within their power they came
pretty darn close that Dominguez game
could have gone either way he was up on
time at one moment he did have his
chances so imagine if he won that game
and Alice Lee found one or two more
accurate moves we could have had a
completely different narrative as it
stands great defensive resilience by
yipping Lou and he could essentially
force a draw with Rook H2 and back to F2
which you essentially always want to do
if there is a team a result at stake you
always want to put the health of your
team over individual results
particularly if the game isn't feed a
rated but look at Alice Lee she is still
trying she's playing on both flanks but
unfortunately she won't get the job done
and that's going to feel a little bit
better for Lanier Dominguez yeah I mean
you see this position where I mean the
queen Rook H2 Rook F2 back and forth I
don't think you can stop that and if
you're Louisa Pink as you said it's a
team result
she allowed herself to get checkmated
here I made oh she missed it you can see
it on her face uh but this result I mean
it wasn't because of her play she had to
play for a win and for Louisa ping here
I mean it is mate in two moves and he
finds it and that means that he is going
to get this one and it's unfortunate for
her but I do say this without a single
bit of hesitation she played Four really
excellent games she had chances all for
them when you're 2300 and you're playing
a 2700 super Grand Master and you're you
have a better position deep down into
time trouble and that goes to show that
she is a worthy competitor and the best
is yet to come with her it absolutely is
we remind you that each team has three
strikes before they are out of the PCL
so Alice Lee is an ace she is going to
come back stronger take a look at the
games make Minor Adjustments but she was
oh so close uh to scoring at least a
point probably even more for the St
Louis Archbishop but the upshot is that
the final round is split evenly with 2-2
and it is a crushing victory for the
Shanghai Tigers who over fulfill their
necessary eight and a half they score a
total of 10 points and what a Powerhouse
team this is Robert they've got no weak
links they've got four incredibly solid
players and a rooster filled with great
rapid players experience and youth
they've got it all and they demonstrated
it today they do indeed I mean they are
strong from top to bottom way he put in
a Powerhouse performance he scored a
perfect four out of four for the
Shanghai Tigers so with Wei getting all
four games in his name and then the rest
of the boards filling in the rest of the
six points that they scored I mean
that's just domination
it is indeed it was an impressive match
it was a good effort for the archbishops
but they are not going to be happy and
it's going to be up to the captain to
decide whether Fabiano caruana uh needs
to make an appearance in the second week
lenier Dominguez is going to be hungry
for his chance at Redemption as well so
Robert we will hear from the St Louis
archbishops again they are going to
analyze their games their mistakes and
they are still very very much in the
fight they are not to be underestimated
especially when they are hungry for
Redemption and when you see this
performance from Shanghai Four Points
all four wins for Wei the two points
throughout the rest of their lineup they
are quite balanced with the super Grand
Master on the top board that is scary
for the other teams in this league and
for St Louis one and a half out of four
is just not going to cut it from your
top board Fabiano caruana did not play
this week Leonardo Dominguez will do
better in future weeks but that just is
not getting the job done you see like if
linear could have performed with three
and a half points this would have been
an 88 tie for example actually they uh
you know may have even had a better
chance if he was scoring early because
that wouldn't put pressure on some of
the other boards so I feel like if
you're saying Lewis you don't blame any
player in particular but it's clear that
one out of four on your top board just
isn't gonna make it work broadly
speaking Robert there are two types of
strategies you could recruit those super
GMS but the downside of that is that
they essentially need to carry the team
in most cases we saw Magnus Carlson do
that with four out of four but today it
was not linear dominguez's a match and
the others they did pick up the slack to
an extent but it just wasn't enough the
second type of uh team is one that is
evenly matched on all four boards China
showed the potential power of a team
like that and they are going to continue
to strike nobody wants to face the
Tigers they are not Paper Tigers they
are real tigers and they will claw their
way to the type of the tournament stand
to the top of the tournament standings
lions and tigers and bears oh my but up
next we have the Bulldogs and the
unicorns they haven't quite made their
way into the Wizard of Oz but the
Croatia Bulldogs led by team captain
agad mature take on the California
unicorns led by the chest Dojo I know
David Pruis coaster kabutski Jessie cry
they will be looking for their unicorns
two no A1c to beat these hungry Bulldogs
I think we the Bulldogs are very
balanced team the unicorns have Sam
Shanklin as their top rated board but we
will see that action take place soon for
now we are going to take a short break
Dania and I will be right back we'll be
covering the second half of this double
header you will not want to miss the
Croatia Bulldogs and the California
unicorn stay tuned everybody
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter is
Envy a wing a blitz Jersey Maxime hey
buddy I love you welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the wheels came up wow she
just took down hikara Nakamura and look
at her she is jubilant entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion
we win we win oh my God
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
we welcome you back to another excellent
matchup here in week one of the pro
chess League it is the final matchup of
the week it is the Croatia Bulldogs
against the California unicorns I am
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me as
per usual as Grandmaster Daniel
nerdinski Tanya we had a great start to
our Friday with a very fun match what do
you expect to see from the second one
gosh each and every match thus far in
the PCL has been absolutely epic to the
very last seconds and we have yet
another match uh between two teams that
have adopted a different strategy of
assembling their players and that is
what I love to see we've got some
fascinating players on both sides the
Bulldogs and the unicorns both of them
have a Fighting Chance Robert I am
expecting to see a close match a match
that goes as is usual down to the fourth
round and perhaps even down to the wire
well done this is the fourth round for
those of you who are not watching the
earlier match you may need to be
reminded of the format in the Pro chess
League it is an all play all format
board one plays board one through four
of the other team and time Patrol 10
minute plus two second increment it is
up to four rounds because if a team
reaches eight half points before the
fourth round begins then that match is
over and if it's a tie eight to eight
after the four rounds are played we get
that rematch colors reverse that is
exciting stuff we have seen that in a
few matches including the blitz they won
their match yesterday against MGD one in
tie breaks
indeed they did we've seen all sorts of
crazy stuff usually these matches do go
down to the fourth round it is
exceedingly rare for a team to reach
eight and a half in three rounds it's
only happened once thus far with the
Indian yogis but I have a feeling that
it is not going to happen because when I
look at these rosters Robert I don't see
anybody that is going to come here to
the PCL and go oh out of four we start
with the Croatia bulldogs look at those
names yeah bogdon Daniel dayat from
Romania he is the top of the line for
the crochet bullets whose Captain is a
god mature you may have seen a few of
his videos uh but uh yeah God mature um
yeah you know this famous guy from uh
Croatia leading his Squad but Dania look
down towards the bottom boards look how
strong the women on the Croatia Bulldogs
are and lean Roberts she took part in
taught to steal Challengers she had some
upsets to her name and Paulina shuvalova
from Russia she is nearly a GM she's got
gonna get there but she's nearly 2500
she counts as 23.50 against the cap yeah
let's be real that vowel in front of her
name is going to be replaced by a
consonant soon enough she's incredibly
solid and Eileen rubers with an
excellent performance in the last Tata
steel she trailed off a little bit at
the end it's a grueling event but she
scored some incredible victories
particularly over over Erwin Lami a 2650
stalworth so air lean ruber's a great
addition to the Bulldogs but not to be
out Don Robert the California unicorns
they are a dynastic team they always
find a way to get the big stars I mean
look at this gukesh and Sam and Robson
and najnik I mean they are loaded top
and bottom yeah they're California
Dreaming over there because go cash he
is the top in terms of rating but it's a
mostly California grown roster we do
have some players who have joined the
team like Georg Meyer uh he is a
Mainstay of the protester used to play
for the bottom bun snowballs but this
team is very very strong so many GMS you
see on list and then they have Sabina
Voyager former U.S women's champion and
Zoe Tang an up and coming Wim from the
United States Chess Dojo managers and
Captain's Team they have three leaders
there because Jesse cry David Pruis and
Costa cavuzzi he'll help manage this
squad hopefully to protest League
success
gosh what a fearsome team love to see
Sam Shanklin he has been part of
California Chesley teams for such a long
time he was part of the San Francisco
mechanics back when it was the U.S chess
league as we review the first round
matchup Sam is not playing today but he
will definitely make an appearance
subsequently bogged on Daniel Dage
though Robert he is going to have to
carry the load for the Croatia Bulldogs
but the Bulldogs they're a very loaded
and level team and for the unicorns we
see georgmeyer Darius fierch and Ray
puzzle Rush Champion Robson leading the
way for the Unicorn so I love looking at
this lineup from top to bottom I have to
say Sabina for sure the lowest rated
player by far in this matchup her
current rating is below 2200 we know
she's been 23.50 we know she's won the
U.S Women's Championship but I think
that is the opponent that the Bulldogs
are gonna have to bulldoze because if
they want to win this match against this
three-headed GM lineup from the Unicorn
I think they're gonna have to score
maximum points against foischer this is
a must-win game for Bogdan right off the
bat 2700 rated Bogdan Daniel Dash who
has a couple of great super tournament
performances under his belt he's a
fantastic Blitz player and as we get
started with this game T4 G6 bogged on
making his intentions clear Robert I
will quickly say that bardia danishvar
may be a lesser-known name for chess
fans and an international master from
Iran but he is a very exciting young
player I've played Blitz with him don't
fall asleep he's part of a couple of
international Masters in the PCL this
year who could really be game changers
for their team
for sure and speaking of voice sure we
see that in the opening stage
I'm in a bowel
I appreciate that next time I'll say
Paul maybe like the Bulldogs will stick
your hand up for me but we see that this
opening from Bogue
is playing for a win this modern system
it's a bit amorphous your Bishop stares
towards the center but you're not
creating tension between the pawns and
that will not allow white to liquidate
and trade and have an easy go of it so I
do think that it's a great opening for
higher rated players to use against
strong players but once that they have a
rating Edge against
and Sabina she goes for the classical
approach this is called the classical
variation the bishop comes out to E2
typically in this line White Castle's
King sidon for dash continues uh to
spice the game up bringing his Knight
out to C6 it is more common Robert to
bring the other night out first and part
of the reason why is that Knight C6 does
invite the move D5 but that move also
has a positional downside because it
obviously opens up the long diagonal for
blacksvian kettled Bishop and black will
have the E5 Square for his Knight
potentially
yes no it's one of these decisions you
can't take back she plays D5 she's a
very experienced player and the Knight
goes back to ba Honda C6 is likely going
to happen you chisel at White's Advanced
structure first Knight F6 then Pawn to
C6 and for white it's kind of an awkward
dynamic because you want to play C4 here
but she has to Defender E4 Pawn with
Knight to C3 so you have good control
over the center but black can chip at it
I would play C6 as there it is does
quickly and while uh for sure you know
she will think about her next move we do
have the second game underway it's a
Grand Master on Grand Master Clash the
only one of the first round so uh when
we can we'll bring up the bird's eye
view and we will get multiple games
going in this first round of action
between the California unicorns and the
Croatia bulldog and there we have it
we've switched to the second game
between York Meyer and Eliana Levi's
gorg Meyer Robert is one of the those
players who was just a huge asset on
your team yes he's dropped some fide
rating he was almost at 2700 at the peak
of his career but he pursued a career I
think in finance he has maintained a
very high level of Chess and there is
nobody that I hate facing more In
classical chess than yorkmeyer I have
done it exactly once Robert and I think
if I'm paired with him again on the
black pieces I'm just going to resign
the game right from the beginning the
guy is just a buzzsaw
is honestly one of the toughest players
to face because he just doesn't make
those inaccuracies that you see other
Grandmasters of his rating are even of a
higher rating make he is super solid we
mentioned linear Dominguez very
professional York Meyer is the ultimate
professional player he plays his French
defense he tries to hold in the black
with white he plays the Catalan every
single game and sometimes he beats the
likes of Vladimir krummick so he knows
what he's doing in these positions and
for Leon leviath here a big question is
should he push his Pawn to B5 you have
an arrow with white going to E4 black
should not sit and do nothing B5 is a
way to fight for important squares in
this position for black so to not give
white a free hand
yeah I mean Leon levage definitely gonna
do some barking on the queen side as you
said bulldozing his way past White's
Central Construction Knight D2 is such a
typical and annoying cattle and move so
there's a defensive purpose and protects
C4 serves an attacking purpose and
prepares E4 I like York Meyer's position
I think he's got a slight advantage and
I'm I agree with you Robert I think Leon
levich he can't Sleepwalk through this
stage of the game because if you allow
E4 particularly with the black Bishop on
A6 rather than B7 the C6 Pawn could
ultimately get caught in the crossfire
but Meyer has gotten exactly the type of
position that he wanted to get out of
the opening such a nightmare opponent
for so many players I mean I know I do
not like facing Garrick Meyer because
I'm gonna have to defend to the very end
and leviath he's burning clock right now
and that could be used as a weapon
against him and he does play Knight D7
which E4 feels automatic as a reply
it does indeed but white could also
start with Bishop B2 uh in order to
buttress that T4 pawn and complete the
development I think York is spoiled for
Choice the downside might be that Bishop
does allow B5 and the pawn could sneak
forward 2b4 knocking off a knight on C3
that would otherwise be supporting uh
the pawn on e4 so I like E4 here I like
Meyer's position I think he's got a
stable plus out of the opening
when you say jerk Meyer with the white
pieces of course he has a stable plus
but in all seriousness it's a position
where black is kind of not exactly
active right the pieces are all on the
third rank except for the two pawns out
there and White's pieces after
especially for E4 they actually stare
into Black's position so I think that we
can go away from this one uh Donna we
have other games underway all four games
have begun and the game between well the
game between uh bardia dineshvar and are
your spirits looking like the same
position for both sides here except for
the Knight on D5 versus the Knight on F3
and wake me up when we have an imbalance
here this is kind of uh eerily
reminiscent of lanyard I think it's his
first game in the last round and for
Daria Spears I think a draw is a
perfectly acceptable result here again
he's playing Black he's playing a very
very promising young player who is going
to be a GM it's really only a question
of when I'm sure he has at least one
Norm the bishop will just come out to F6
but Robert I don't want to overstate the
case here the game is not over it's not
a guaranteed draw and both sides have
the capacity to blunder here one
instance would be the tempting move
Knight to E4 right what could be more
natural than centralizing your knight
down goes the Evo bar and down goes the
B4 Pawn opening up a discovered attack
against the knight in this position
white lands upon down for no
compensation so for danishvar I would
keep this night on D2 maybe bring it to
C4 deploy The Rook to C1 if I had to
choose a side though I'd probably take
white by a smidge yeah because the
Knight on D7 that one is stuck in place
the E5 and C5 squares are under White's
control so the Knight goes up to C4
maybe into D6 we have the players on
screen and Darius and he is a calculator
he will determine if he can allow that
Knight into D6 if he needs to make a
queen Shuffle to B8 to keep that Knight
out of there uh it does just that so
yeah I think that he's keeping the
equality in this position so let's zoom
out to uh another game just because this
one it feels quite level that would be
the natural result but I'm looking top
left bottom bottom right and I see
Advantage for the player with the black
pieces it's board one for California in
the bottom right Ray Robson against
International Master Paulina shuvalova
and then in the top left we started the
day with boged on Daniel dayaj against
Sabina foyer it looks like foyer in some
trouble there so I don't know Dania pick
your choice of board ones versus Board
four
well I'd like to look at board four for
one reason in particular as we go there
I will say the dash is about to pick off
that pawn on T5 and he does seem to be
well on his way to scoring a much needed
uh victory for the Bulldogs he needs to
deliver in a big way so a great opening
Choice by the Romanian Grand Master now
I was looking at this and it took me a
second because I was experiencing some
Deja Vu I knew I saw this somewhere
before this type of structure or why to
sacrificed upon it and I remember nihal
sarin displayed this idea at the
chess.com Global championship in Toronto
he was playing from Belgrade and he
played this more than once against Anish
giri and Wesley so it worked the first
time but he lost with this the second
time against Wesley so who was
incredibly well prepared and Ray Robson
seems to be decently prepared but Robert
I think chevalova has managed to Garner
the kind of compensation that white is
trying to get in this line control of
the D6 square a clamp in the center and
long-term chances on the king side in
the event the black castles right into
potentially a very powerful Bishop Queen
battery I have to acknowledge I was
misled by the evaluation bar I didn't do
a count it's an extra Pawn for black but
lots of activity for white and Paulina
shuvola she's down upon for a reason she
gave that pawn up because look at
Black's remaining pieces the bishop on
E7 it's a defensive piece that Knight on
D2 May land on C4 in the near future the
Rooks were white I think it's a tough
question Dania does the F1 Rook or the
A1 Rook go to D1 are you going Rook C1
and Rook D1 or Rook D1 and Rook E1 these
are not questions that are that easy to
answer and now Knight D6 check looks
viable for white
it does indeed trading in one advantage
for another that pawn is Juicy but it
might be even juicier if it lands on D6
plus you'll get the bishop pair that
Knight on D5 for Rey uh is really the
pride of his position but you don't win
games with good pieces that Knight
doesn't have that many prospect it's
sitting pretty it's well protected but
it's not threatening to jump into any
other squares Paulina taking the slower
approach putting the Rook on C1 I think
she'll put the other one on D1 Robert we
are in for a slug Fest in this game
white has to be very patient and she's
gonna have to play a pawn down for a
long time and cash in most importantly
when she sees an opportunity to launch
an attack yeah H4 that's a good move I
usually to play in these positions it's
already a defended Square it helps you
bring a knight to G5 so I think she will
start throwing her pieces forward but
look at how solid Rey's Center is that
Knight on D5 you wish you could slide at
me maybe even that A2 Pawn over to C2
and then play C2 to C4 to kick the
Knight out of the center not possible in
this game so Ray just plays A6 you may
play B5 next he just wants to push his
extra Pawn forward I like what Ray
Robson is doing but I think for Molina
H4 that's the move that I would be
playing ASAP I want to threaten Knight
G5 but she plays the other side of the
board with A3 not a big fan of that one
I agreed to see I was actually about to
propose A3 with the yes very prosaic
very straightforward idea of Bishop B1
and queen C2 but Robert it does seem to
be that inducing G6 would go a long way
towards sparking the fire on the king
side and perhaps from D from C2 the
queen could migrate to D2 and perhaps
even to H6 and maybe even H4 uh becomes
even more powerful with a hook appearing
on G6 it seems to me that you believe
this planet is just a little bit too
slow though maybe I just like pawns
that's what I'm getting at here you know
Yasser serowon always a pawn Grabber he
says give me give me give me luck is up
this Pawn but you are correct that if G6
is induced it's not really an if it's a
win the White Queen will slide to D2 and
try to go into those dark squares on the
king side so this one remains
interesting we'll see if Ray Robson can
withstand the pressure that Paulina is
going to put on but let's zoom out for a
second just because I'm looking across
the boards here Donna in the top right
the game between Garrick Meyer and Leon
levia things have changed a bit where
suddenly in the top right black no
longer has that light Square Bishop it
took that Knight on C4 the pawn
structure is changing and the top left
uh bogged on Daniel dayaj he is yet to
take this Pawn on D5 so he allows it to
stay on the board but the question is
will he be able to win it in the near
future he is down on the clock
he is down on the clock he is a
notorious time pressure chunky I mean
he's always down to his last seconds but
I still think he's got that game under
relatively good control I definitely
want to check into its course but things
continue to heat up on georgmeyer's
board so perhaps uh we could take a look
at York Meyer's Catalan against Leon
Levi she has played the move F4 secured
the bishop pair the downside though
Robert is that he's allowed some
weaknesses on the queen side but E5 is
just a tractor driving through Black's
position and knocking off everything in
its wig how does Leon levage prepare for
that what seems to be inevitability
it looks terrible for black I'm
surprised the evaluation bar isn't
higher up on the screen because E5 is
screaming to be played it's automatic
and then C6 is hanging behind it so if
you have to make a move like Rook a to
C8 some kind of sad defensive move E5
will force the Knight back to E8 and
then white can play 94 at some point or
F5 just keep pushing your pawns up the
board you're gonna launch a vicious
attack against the black king
they're on the bike she needs to find
some sort of tactical solution to his
problems I was briefly considering Rook
88 but white could still respond to the
five and yeah The Rook is x-raying the
queen but I don't see a concrete way uh
to turn that into a defensive tactic
maybe you drop the bishop back to C5 and
get rid of the dark script Bishop that
doesn't really help though E5 still
comes with great effect because it's the
other Bishop that is going to spell Doom
to the C6 Pawn so the evaluation bar
it's not creeping up but the C6 spawn
might have to go to the bar it'll be
going to morgue soon enough if white
plays the movie five
well Jurg would like to send uh Leon
levitz's chances to the more because
that would be good for the California
unicorns now guiltmeyer he has been a
staple of the German team for many years
but he actually transferred federations
to Uruguay I believe he's half Uruguayan
half German if I'm not mistaken so he
plays for Uruguay now and he is looking
at this position he is a Mainstay in the
protest league and I'm liking his
control over the center So Daniel I feel
like the one game we're sure about is
bardia dineshfar against Darius fears
that seemed very even but the other
three boards it seems like a lot is left
up in the air they are indeed and I
actually think bardia is putting a
little bit of pressure on Daria shorts
he is making uh the Polish Grandmaster
work for that draw and Mr Kusha uh a
streamer and a very strong player in his
own right uh told us that bartier done
it far two weeks ago made his final
Grand Master Norm so I brought up that
topic and he will he confirmed a
Grandmaster at the next fide Congress
which is absolutely not a surprise and
what is a surprise that Daria Schwartz
does seem to be buckling a little bit
under pressure Robert
wow yeah that's in the bottom left by
the way in the top right the Evo bar
going even higher because he's looking
Leon Levites for a tactical solution to
strategic problems but he's just going
to lose this Pawn on C6 in the top right
so uh I think we should maybe dive into
either the dineshvar against Spirits
game or where would you like to go
the chevalova Robson game continues to
heat up as well as does sabina's game
against bogdon Daniel Dage where the Eva
bar has not moved a millimeter Sabina is
holding steady thus far I am suffering
from serious decision anxiety but I'd
like to check out bardia Donna schwar's
game he is also the current Iranian
champion and he is doing a fantastic job
of generating winning chances playing
incredibly fast leaving himself with six
minutes and change to figure out a way
to keep putting pressure Robert the big
big question here it's not the fact that
his pieces are active that is disturbing
to me it's the weakness of the B6 pawn
and White's ability to attack it with
all three of his pieces yeah white can
decide to play E4 or Pawn to B5 or just
a simple move like King to G2 I feel
like black can hardly move he starts
with E4 he's being more direct about it
E5 threatens to win a piece the knights
are Superfluous but they need to be
connected because the Knight F6 is
dislodged the Knight on D7 is gone so I
think that for Darius church he needs to
make an awkward move like queen d8 or
queen A7 but either way it feels like
white can just make slow progress bring
the king up to G2 eventually push the
pawn to E5 if you want Push the pawn to
B5 if you feel like cementing the Beast
exponent plays Dania I really don't like
how this is going for Spirits I thought
this was going to be a draw with a high
degree of certainty now I definitely am
looking at this like it's a big
Advantage for white bigger than the eval
bar even says because of the clock
absolutely and that's one big
contribution that Magnus Carlson I think
has made uh to our general skill level
he has shown uh chess players across the
globe particularly young players that
you don't need to give up hope just
because the position may seem
symmetrical and a lot of teenage players
are now a lot more skilled in the end
game and in symmetrical positions than
they ever used to be and we are seeing
that play out here but let's not jump
the gun to are you sure it's a
tremendously resourceful Defender and I
think he's displaying that
resourcefulness with his last move
putting the queen on a good defensive
Square trying to keep all of his bases
covered as much as he can he has pushed
to the last two rows but he is not going
gentle into that good night two minutes
and 16 seconds are left to defend this
miserable position but boy will he try
yeah he is going to have to Buckle in
and try to stop white from making
progress F3 is just a quiet move keeping
the status quo at some point black has
to do something right you can't move
your king because the F7 Pawn will hang
uh you have to push a pawn from H5 to H4
that may allow the pawn to go up to G4
maybe G5 for white at some moment that's
an overextended Pawn the b-pawn can't
move the 97 can't move without dropping
the beep on I do not envy the task of
Darius Spirit cheer so Donya should we
let him suffer in silence should we go
away from this one just because I was
looking at the eval bar if we take a
look at the bird's eye view in the game
between georgmeyer and Leon levich it's
going higher and higher for Georg Meyer
and he has indeed sent that C6 Pawn to
the morgue brought the bishop back to an
ideal spot Levites trying to activate
his Knights but the knights have zero
purchase on any squares the move F4 F5
uh in the position up on the top right
would seem to make matters even worse
for black but it's more in Meyer's style
to play with like Rook C1 and D1 or
Knight B5 to D6 he will tighten the
screws and tighten the screws Robert
until you have no air left to breathe
for sure and well while we can trust
Garrick Meyer even though he's in time
travel all the games are nearing the end
of their clock so why don't we look at
the one in the maybe the bottom right
between Paulina and Ray Robson just
because I saw a rook lift and I couldn't
keep my eyes off a potential attack
I couldn't either The Rook is on D4 the
black pawn is on C3 there are two pass
pawns on the sixth and third ranks
respectively for white and black what on
Earth is going on the EVO bar can't make
sense of it that's when we know we're in
trouble so the pawn count is still the
same black is up a pawn the bishop's
still on B1 the queen still hasn't made
its way to C2 I think Paulina is looking
for the perfect opportunity to pose that
threat on H7 and there it is the queen
is up to D3
Ray can defend it easily Robert but
every move is making concessions F5
weekend Z6 Knight F6 allows the White
Knight to jump into E5
yeah no 95 bring another piece to the
attack this is a critical moment for Ray
Robson and he is The Puzzle Battle the
puzzle Rush Champion he's the whiz kid
but it's not an easy choice and he makes
it he goes F5 he shuts down the queen
and Bishop now I'm thinking at some
point B4 Bishop A2 for white the bishop
on B1 staring into your own Queen which
is staring into an enemy Pawn let's
reroute the bishop that's a standard
plan and maybe there will be some
sacrifices at a future moment with a
take on D5 and all that stuff but Dania
the C3 Pawn is throwing a white side the
D6 Pawn is thrown in Black side but
black remains upon ahead
and now we're basically in a Blitz game
we've got essentially the title Tuesday
time control which is three plus one now
we've got three plus two and this is
where Blitz and bullet experience comes
in so handy Polina does play her fair
share on chess.com but Ray Robson is a
blitz beast and let's see if he can
harness that experience and navigate his
way successfully through the
complications before is an excellent
move you called it Robert and Paulina
continuing to spice up the game finding
new ways to put black under pressure but
it looks like Rey is stable for the time
being how is he going to make progress
though what improving moves does he have
on tap here maybe knight from D7 to B6
at some point or maybe to F6 I can't
decide right you want to bring your
piece forward but that does give the E5
Square to White uh that Knight on D5 is
very importantly defending the C3 Pawn
whoa but he moves it
oh is there like there's a bishop E4
tactic perhaps
oh moving the Knight away so that the
bishop can essentially take its place
but Paulina could move for Bishop up to
A2 and try to take the sting out of
Bishop before maybe Rey will put the
bishop on D5 then who knows it's such a
complicated position and we're
definitely gonna get a Time scramble in
this one we are we're getting time
scrambles in other games let's zoom out
of this one just for the moment as this
one remains complex we look in the top
right georgmeyer he is in charge pushing
his F on up to F5 the 9g4 is in trouble
look at the top left it is seconds on
the clock for both sides and Sabina
Forster is fighting
exactly what she needs to do get this
into a Time scramble when apps
apps but as we head to that game even
though she knows she's up in exchange
look at Black's pawns there are a lot of
them that Phalanx that pawn chain in the
center should decide the game if Dash
plays this accurately
winning A6 oh my gosh he just gave away
his Pony could have gone to a different
Square perhaps to keep the pawn but oh
no that's a big mistake she rushed it
she
could have protected that
first there
no but Don is something to note H5 Pawn
H1 squared dark Square Bishop so if
somehow Sabina can give up her Rook for
all the remaining pawns but the h-bond
she will have a chance to and those
black pawns can't move that easily she's
going after them one by one trying to
keep them stuck to place the e-pawn
can't push the D5 punches but look at
Bogue Don Daniel Dash the king is gonna
go to D4 and C3 in short order
yeah they're just so many things to keep
track of for white and black can always
defend his pawns if necessary Sabina
doing everything hither and thither Goes
The Rook rookie seven but black is gonna
get connected passers and that I think
spells Doom for sabina's drawing chances
King D3 and black pushes the pawns to
Oblivion there yeah time trouble was not
a friend to her there she should have
brought her King back to defend that C2
Pawn but either way it was going to be
difficult and this is just clinical
technique from bogdon Daniel they Arch
the pawns go forward you can't stop him
so there's going to be either
resignation after the pawn promotes
because you can't even get the remaining
pawns the dark sweat Bishop protects G5
and Sabina I think is going to resign
here she does a valiant effort listen
she came oh so close after G3 I think
she might have held that position but
ultimately dead just time scramble
skills Prevail he wins that necessary
game the first strike is by the Bulldogs
but the second one is by the unicorns
Meyer has completed that amazing
positional effort yes he wins you see
those Rooks on the seventh rank against
a queen that's a dominant final position
then we have two games left in the
bottom left and bottom right in the
bottom left it is an endgame grind for
bardia dineshfar he is better against
Darius fears in the bottom right we have
the the whiz kid the puzzle Champion Ray
Robson taking up Paulina shuvolva and
that's a tactical Skirmish So Daniel you
take it from here you pick the game
out to paulina's game bardia continues
to pressure I'm keeping a close eye on
that game as well we'll bring you that
result if it comes but Paulina has
sacrificed the piece she's also
sacrificed a minute of her time and I
don't think she's got anything to show
for it Ray Robson is using his minor
pieces beautifully to keep White's
pieces at Bay I feel like look at that
dark Square diagonal right from C3 to G7
so many pieces in that line but black is
up a knight right it's up a minor piece
but for how many pawns the answer is
semi rhetorical is two pawns that's a
lot of compensation especially with a
bishop pair against the open King the D6
Pawn is a thorn in Black side maybe even
Queen C7 at some point down into trade
Queens because you do have a healthy
passer it's a messy position I do tend
to trust Ray Robson in such a position
and he's ahead in the clock but Paulina
does have chance here because the King
on G8 not the safest King in the world
you're definitely changing my mind
you've opened up my eyes to the fact
that white does have serious practical
compensation and two pawns is nothing to
sneeze at that is a bit of a security
blanket for white that means Paulina
doesn't need to go crazy uh to try to
win the game two pawns allows her to
generate chances even if the worst comes
to pass and the Queens are off the board
and now the clock situation beginning to
equalize as right trying to figure out a
way to get his pieces untangled Quincy
it oh Queen takes the eight he'll take
with the bishop and Robert it's so
important that all three minor pieces
are defending the D7 Square otherwise
that pawn would have rumbled forward and
cost black a piece and I just want to
call out that the game between ordea
dineshfar and darshan is likely about to
end in a draw so we don't have to go
there it looks like the pieces are
traded a good hold for a spiritual
unicorns and this game still a lot of
life left the king is in the corner or
Ray Robson Queen C7 is an option as you
mentioned Queen takes Queen on C8 all of
Black's forces are defending that D7
square that is of vital importance
because you cannot allow that white Pawn
to push forward
I understand this move but I don't like
it Paulina keeping the Queens on the
board at all costs but she might have
just allowed Knight C4 with Tempo there
are mating threats with rookie one and
Knight G4 even though white does have a
Luft Square I think Paulina is losing
her grasp on this position
she is she's losing on time as well she
plays Queen C3 going after the night but
Knight E4 now first one night then the
other and it feels like maybe nice C to
D2 right now just bring your knight in
queensy one check oh yeah yeah oh my
gosh a sucker punch and then another one
and another one Ray is not going to let
this one go but we know that Anything
Can Happen 20 seconds for the puzzle
Rush Phenom for the star of American
chess he's taking almost all of it to
figure out the most precise course of
action but he better display something
convincing he's down to eight seconds
and he plays Knight cd2 and look how
quickly she's running Queen D1 now it's
just a bullet scramble Ray Robinson
about 3 100 in bullet and there has to
be a tactical sequence Knight takes G3
is available here you're up if you're
right
rookie one and Knight F3 wins the queen
nope oh my God the other night yeah that
was smart that was really really smart
by her there and three seconds right you
gotta go
not over yet Bishop D5 F2
50 check it's a
and then you take H4 as well and Knight
F2 at the end will be a problem can you
block with your Rook on H3 so this
should do the trick but Ray he's doing
that super Grand Master thing repeating
and then he'll make progress
and progress he makes with Knight F2
Rook F3 Paulina staying in the game so
so Valiant just take the queen I would
say 93 still not over that D6 Pawn is
annoying in a Time scramble but race
should secure the full point here yeah I
can put his Rook on d8 at any point and
just go after this D6 Pawn now Knight
takes D6 with C4 with his Bishop is six
six oh
uh was that a puzzle Rush tactic because
Ray Robson found it instantly I was
literally opening my mouth to say Puzzle
Battle skills coming in handy now he's a
piece and a pun up and unless he loses
on time or loses his connection
he will score a very important point for
the unicorns that was a pretty sick
tactic like it didn't look easy to take
that pawn on D6 and he makes it look oh
Ray Robson
Ray Robson gets it done for the
California unicorns and I called him
super Grand Master Ray Robson and I
think that's the first time I've ever
been able to do that he recently crossed
2700 with some of his Great Performances
including the US Championship he wins
he's the board one for the unicorns he
takes out board four Paulina for the
Bulldogs but Done Yet two and a half one
half this felt that close
it really did that this seems to be the
most common score after round one of
apcl match and for the Bulldogs a lot of
positives Bach then Daniel Dash a good
game not his best showing it was close
but he pulled through in the end Leon
levage he is going to have to step it up
in the next round he will have white and
bardi adonisfar perhaps the most
frustrating bit about the bulldogs's
first round he came oh so close to
squeezing out what was a completely
equal middle game but he is a Phenom
he's a strong player and he will
continue to try to score important
points for the Bulldogs as they try to
serve out this one point deficit it's a
close matchup only one point separates
the teams after the first round of
action we'll see what happens when they
get set for round two here in this Pro
chess League match between the Croatia
Bulldogs and the California unicorns
we'll be right back
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
makeyourchess.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning for the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
accessible.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Darius Spirits saying only sky is the
limit and there is no limit to the
success that the California unicorns can
have this season he is a strong
Grandmaster originally from Poland now
playing for the United States Dania he
is definitely a player you want on your
team absolutely I mean he is the
consummate professional Robert it took
him a while to get up to the high 2600s
it was a tough Journey for him but
ultimately he made it he is also an
opening specialist by now the author of
several incredibly well-received opening
books he's written both on one E4 and
one D4 he is a fearsome competitor and
he will come every week fight it out and
he does not go too low with the lows he
is resilient every game in a big save in
round one as he holds that end game
against bardi Adonis far in the
California unicorns are sitting pretty
with a one-point lead and Darius Fierce
now gets the white pieces that's down on
the last board against Paulina but I'm
looking at the top because bogdon Daniel
dayas he won his first game Leon leviath
had a tough one against York Meyer York
Meyer is kind of the rock that holds
many teams together he's so difficult to
take down but if the Bulldogs want a
chance at a comeback Well Done Deal
ditch will have to use his 2700 plus
rating to take down George Meyer man I
don't envy him he's basically in a
must-win situation every round and
that's what you get when you've got
those 2700 plus players on your team I
talked about it at the conclusion of the
last match whether you like it or not
you're gonna have to do some hardcore
carrying and the lower boards Belita
shivalova in particular she was in a
very competitive battle against Ray
Robson that could have gone either way
and she has to keep it going keep trying
and score a couple of upsets to give the
Bulldogs a fighting chance I agree with
that because shivalva is such a strong
board four rating at around 2500 we saw
that uh with the Shanghai Tigers right
uh Louisa ping he is a super strong at
2500 as well so you kind of enjoy having
a balanced lineup that's spearheaded by
a monster on the top board and for
Croatia they have that going on for them
same deal with the unicorns though I
think the unicorns if Sabina foius can
ever score even a half point that bodes
really well for their chances because
she has outrated every single game
she is indeed and she's outrated in this
game against the on the bike who got
absolutely demolished incinerated at the
hands of georgmeyer a typical Meyer win
so levich with the white pieces has a
chance at Revenge uh the time control
there was off as much I would like to
see the three minute chess that's not
what that's not what happened I don't
think that was uh Paulina shuvalova she
was playing a Blitz game like someone
Challenger and she probably thought it
was the pro Chesley game
random Blitz game so I saw that as well
but I looked into it and it was Paulina
getting challenged to a Blitz game she
is gonna wait for her rapid game to
begin but this one is off
that's happened to me a couple of times
and there we go indeed Bogdan has the
white pieces here against Meyer and
Bogdan can play both E4 and D4 but Meyer
is a French specialist that D takes E4
Rubenstein French he's been playing it
uh since uh the Treaty of Appomattox was
signed in the 1800s so bogdon doesn't
want anything to do with that instead
they've got a nice little BOGO Indian
yes we do Knight bd2 Bishop coming to G2
kind of a slower approach and wait a
second Dundee is kirkmeyer playing with
the white pieces or the black pieces
because I've had this exact position
against him with the black pieces uh he
plays it with both colors that guy jorg
Meyer the Grand Master who now plays for
Uruguay he knows his openings as well as
anybody on the planet he's a specialist
in the reubenstein French he plays the
Catalan he has inspired many people to
play the Catalan because he always seems
to have a slight Advantage now with the
black pieces he says yo you know what
you take the bishop here I'm okay with
it because I'm gonna rapidly challenge
you in the center first taking on D4 if
the queen takes the Knight comes to C6
with Tempo black can play D7 to D5 at
some moment to trade some more pawns
Eric Meyer he looks unfazed
listen if you're an aspiring player a
young player and you're looking for
someone whose games you can analyze
somebody less known whose games you can
analyze to help yourself build up
foundations positional foundations
learning how to maneuver look at Myers
games with both colors the guy is an
absolute Buzz side he might not have
tall like brilliancies or at least a lot
of them but he definitely has those boa
constrictor wins by the base in full and
right now he is facing a bishop Perry
he's given it up he's given it up for
active development I do like what Bogdan
is doing and once again I'm just making
sure that the colors are right because
York Meyer would just kill to have this
position with white right now I think
what we're likely to see is black to
slide The Rook to C8 and white will
bring the bishop out to G5 and then when
that happens we probably will see all
the pieces the bishop the Knight the
Queens come off the F6 Square so Black's
Pawn structure will be a little bit
compromised but it's not the end of the
world especially in the end game so Rook
C1 step one Knight A5 is actually a huge
threat oh yeah for the C4 pawn and the
B3 Square that's the problem when you
push the pawn to A3 is you give up light
squares over there on the queen side so
Bishop G5 I do think H6 will likely be
in the respect yes see some lightsaber
issues or wide well I remember Howard
Huebner and Joseph Dorfman were playing
a game and uh the B3 scar was also weak
and black actually took a uh a pen and
put it on the Square to illustrate the
weakness of that square okay that uh
went completely in the wrong direction
but Black's Knight is uh knows which
direction it's going why could beat
Black to the punch with B4 but you could
easily over extend yourself then on the
queen side so a lot of difficult
positional problems and moving parts to
take care of I like bogdan's position
and he's probably going to take five
minutes here he is grishock uh number
two he loves getting down below three
minutes that's what he lives for Robert
well he played B4 but will leave these
two yeah he did but just because other
games are underway uh this one is going
to be an interesting battle between two
very uh positional players uh when they
have such a locked position but you see
in the top right Leon leviath with the
white pieces for the Bulldogs take out
Sabina for sure he's gonna to win that
game only a pair of dark Square push-ups
and a pawn each have been traded and the
bottom left Ray Robinson against bardia
dineshfar that one is a maroxy bind
structure white with a C4 and E4 pawns
making sure that you have full control
of the center and the bottom right we
have liftoff Darius Spears against
Paulina shivalova so interesting games
no matter where you look on your screen
absolutely I really feel that the Robson
dineshbar Affair is going to be a
defining game in this match can the
Iranian Phenom the Grand Master elect
having secured his last Norm just a
couple of weeks ago and the reigning
Iranian Champion score a big upset
Victory he's definitely playing for a
win they've got sort of an accelerated
Dragon morosi bind type setup I don't
know what opening it came from we can
take a closer look Robert but I'll leave
the final say up to you
okay you're putting all the pressure on
me why don't why don't we go to that
Robson game against the nestro just
because uh the games on the right side
seem to be a little Tamer whereas this
game here it's not a symmetrical Pawn
structure and what are those Knights
doing on A3 and C2 it looks very odd it
looks like there's some Fisher random
going on but I think we know why if you
just go back a few turns we can bring up
an analysis board for it if we need but
the reason the Knight didn't go out to
the C3 Square
um you know after this series of moves
if we just keep going a little bit is
black to delay this development of the
night to F6 if you're going you see that
until black plays Knight of six white
does not play Knight to C3 because the
bishop will snap that Knight off so if
Knight C3 had been played Bishop takes
politics look at those double isolated C
pawns black is just going to go after
him I love playing this from the black
side in Blitz I've had it many many
times and it's just easy to play just
you know your targets so that is why Ray
Robinson said I don't want any part of
that I'm not going to allow you to go
out after my pawns Ian said broadside to
A3 and then later in this game he is
going to bring his Knight to E3 very
likely and take control over the D5
Square
that was very well explained moments
like that are so easy to overlooked and
yet they're crucial to understanding the
course of the game and why the players
make the moves that they do so the 993
is going to be a long lasting problem
for Rey he can try to reroute the Knight
via B5 in fact he can try to do that on
the very next move but first he takes
care of business because B2 was hanging
speaking of rerouting danishvar could
bring his Knight to C5 and ultimately uh
Robert I feel like the big question in
the next couple of moves is can black
whip up some form of activity on the
queen side before white takes care of
business and improves his Knight I
actually thought A6 might have been a
more prudent choice to keep the night at
Bay but Don eschvar going accelerated
Dragon style and creating a stronghold
for his Knight on B4 yeah Knight on B4
Knight on C5 give me those dark squares
for my Knights and Ray Robson he's
looking at his position like hmm I'm not
so sure about that one he can slice
Queen up to D2 just to take away that B4
square and it connects his Rook at the
same time but he actually just goes
forward with Knight to B5 showing no
fear whatsoever he's not afraid of these
night before jobs
and Knight C5 is on the board I'm on the
same page Queen D2 and B3 and although I
was impressed with dineshvar's opening I
feel like the trend of the game is
starting to pick up in White's Direction
maybe we'll actually try to change the
trend of the game with another typical
accelerated idea F7 F5 as risky as it is
to leave the bishop unprotected and the
center tender that's what you might need
in order to spark the Flames of the
initiative for black I like to move F5
it's just it's sort of thematic here in
a maroxy bind white has a bind with the
c and e four pawns so you play F5 to
challenge them but no Dinesh VAR plays
the move Pawn to a four he wants to stop
the beat Paul for pushing but you can
push it anyway so while we're thinking
along the main broadcast Ray Robson why
don't we bring in team captain of the
unicorns Costa kavutski so he we're
gonna have him join us here on the call
and there is hey what's up kosia
hey how's it going guys
I'm doing well how about you how are you
enjoying your role as a manager are you
nervous right now watching your players
play
um yeah it's been uh it's been super fun
uh we're rooting for the the unicorns
here we've got uh we got a slogan shook
him corns we're having tons of fun it's
uh
uh it's been a while since I managed the
team but um you know I'm working with I
Am David Bruce who's doing most of the
work here of course getting the players
and everything but um yeah it's been an
absolute blast
and Castillo obviously I won't hide my
allegiances I played for the unicorns uh
for many years so I will say that my
team is the cobras I want the cobras to
win but you know a part of my soul will
always be dedicated to the very end to
the unicorns
yeah I appreciate it absolutely
wow look at Donya not a neutral
commentator let's get him out of here
neutral me
well I actually have to ask you Coach
Joe so Ray Robson he has played for a
number of different teams in the protest
League of course he's uh often in St
Louis how did you get him on your squad
he's a super GM he is incredibly
talented what was that negotiation like
yeah I was
um absolutely
stoked uh when we when we got him I
believe David was the one that convinced
him to to join the team I'm sure they've
they've known each other for for many
years and
um yeah I forget exactly when we got him
it wasn't that long all this has
happened very very quickly in the span
of the last couple weeks or so but
um I think he wasn't playing on the team
I think David's always wanted to have
him on the team he's so strong in online
chess he's like a three-time puzzle
battle like world champion I mean he's
just a monster he's just an absolute
monster and a lot of our players are so
I'm honestly just super super excited
for her to watch these guys play
definitely want to look at some of the
positions but I also want to ask you
about Sam Shanklin who is a Bay area
native basically the same question about
Sam how well do you know Sam uh having
lived in the Bay Area uh yourself for
several years and how excited are you uh
to see Sam obviously former U.S Champion
make an appearance for the unicorns uh
in the subsequent weeks
yeah I've known Sam for for many years
uh we go way back and um I know he's
played uh for the team for many years he
used to play for the San Francisco
mechanics
um the fun fact David mentioned this not
too long ago Shanklin started out as a
board four in the U.S chess League you
know and has since worked his way up to
being you know one of the strongest
players you know not just in the league
but in the world obviously so uh it's
fantastic to have him as our uh is our
board one I think he's a natural leader
he often performs extremely well in team
events you guys know his record like in
the Olympiad so yeah I think he's just a
great player to have on the team
or sure well question we have you here
we're gonna look at the chess with you
as well so Rey and bardia dineshwar
they're just kind of hanging in this
position nothing major happening at the
moment so let's zoom out from this
specific game and look at all four
boards here uh you have the lead to an f
one half the California unicorns but as
you look I'm looking at the top right
Sabina Forster has an advantage against
Leon leviath so why don't we tune in
there and while we do kosher what was it
like bringing Sabina onto your roster I
think she lives in North Carolina closer
to dania than to the West Coast
yeah um Sabina was another great pickup
um actually this was this was my idea I
was the one that reached out and
recruited her
um basically we realized we needed some
female players just around 2200 to
really make it work with our average and
our lineup
um and she was her feeder ratings right
around there
um which actually I thought was very
fortunate because I think she's kind of
underrated like she's super experienced
U.S women's champion she's played like
these online events before so uh yeah I
think that was kind of a very lucky
pickup for us to have her available and
work with our with our average
mm-hmm well Casa how optimistic are you
about sabino's chances in this position
what jumps out at you
um well right now it's like okay it's a
symmetrical structure I think this was
uh exchange sloth so super solid
um I think she's done fine looks like
she's up a little bit on the clock which
is nice in that first round game I don't
know what you guys thought of it it was
like it came down to the wire right like
she was fighting and like putting up
very stiff resistance so hopefully that
gives her good confidence
um it's very tough for these board fours
because they start off playing the board
one right the strongest player on the
other team you know and then they have
to play the board too so they start off
with their absolute like toughest
matchups before they finally get to play
players a little bit closer to their
rating but Sabine is a huge fighter so I
feel like she's gonna do um absolutely
fine
Costa you're one of the nicest people in
the world so I just want to state that
thank you I make my next question is
well you're a team captain do you tell
players like hey you know I want you to
score a draw if you can with the white
pieces because you're mentioning that
Sabina is the lowest rated player of the
eight and if she scores a half point in
any individual game that seems like a
success so do you let the players do
their own thing or are you kind of
telling them hey you know maybe in
certain circumstances let's just secure
a draw here or play it solidly
yeah to be perfectly honest I would say
David David press he's going to be like
the main team captain slash manager so
if anyone is telling like the super jams
to make a draw or something you'll it'll
be him and it will be it won't be coming
from me um but I think most of these
players are experienced enough that they
kind of they kind of get it so being a
no she's playing up every round I mean
every half point is going to be useful
for the team
um and uh yeah I'm sure these guys are
experienced enough they know if we're
ahead play solid for behind you know you
need to take risks and and score points
um so yeah I'm not I'm not too worried
about I'm more kind of just following
them trying to Hype up you know the
crowd the dojo to uh to root for root
for the corns
well I just second what Robert said
about your uh wholesomeness and uh just
the educational value of your stream and
uh the the instruction and
recommendations that you and Jesse and
David bring to the table if we could
swing back to the bird's eye view really
quickly speaking of experience uh
georgmeyer uh We've sung his Praises
along along with Robert uh for this
entire match so as we navigate over to
his incredibly complicated position
against the Bulldogs top seed fogged on
Daniel Tasha you can opine on this
position as you wish uh but perhaps
could you also say a couple words about
uh how excited you are to have someone
like Georg on his team and what your
expectations are or him
yeah York another great player another
great pickup we uh David recruited him I
think like a week or two ago
um I was again surprised when we got him
he's so strong uh you know he uh has a
lot of experience in the league used to
play for the the Stockholm snowballs I
remember and he was there board one and
and he did fantastic uh he's such a good
like online uh speed chess player he's
just like so so strong
um and we have him as like board three
which I think is like really uh really a
good spot for him
um not that it matters that much
everyone is going to play everyone in
this format but
um still when I feel like yeah your
board three is uh is this good it
definitely gives you a lot of confidence
and his position right now I guess is is
not great I see the eval bar which is um
definitely uh definitely affecting me
but I also see White's Dark Sword Bishop
is a very annoying piece in in the
position that that seems to be the the
problem of course his opponent
um is also extremely strong so this is
yeah not an easy matchup for for Jurg by
any stretch
no it certainly isn't but I want to give
you one piece of good news before we let
you know you're streaming on your
channel uh if we just go back to the
bird's eye view quickly can we just have
all of our attention on the top right
for a second because Sabina foius with
the black pieces I see that Eva bar
going down I think the reason why is she
is up not only on the clock but she is
going to go after that D4 Pawn so it
cost you how does it make you feel to
see that pickup you know one of the
later pickups of being a foiser she's
performing it looks like in this game
for your team
yeah this is looking uh this is looking
great
um really yeah nice position on the
clock as well but yeah I see like King
F7 coming in for Black Knight of five
and yeah d-pawn's gonna be uh
under a lot of pressure seems just like
a very easy like healthy position for
blacks at play you have this F6 G5
structure that's just like restricting
the the 9R and F3
um I love it yeah it's great okay go
Sabina no no notes
you're going to be on the edge of your
seat Costa praying for your team but
great stuff so far from the unicorns a
team to watch an international Master
Costa kabutski thank you for making time
those watching on the chess.com Channel
twitch.tv chest Dojo live is it Costa's
amazing educational stream he's
streaming right now it's Acosta we will
let you go and enjoy the match in peace
good luck to the unicorns and thanks for
uh thank you guys appreciate it thank
you guys thanks coach good luck to your
team and you said it's a team to watch
it's also a stream to watch go to the
chest Dojo to learn and up your chess
game and right now Sabina foius is
bringing her best stuff when the team
needs her look at these last couple
moves G4 Knight F5 hitting the Knight 96
now winning the D4 pawn and there's a
huge problem for white is there's a fork
on E2 so it's not just you take my Pawn
I take yours after Knight takes D4 there
is no Knight takes D5 because of the
fork on the E2 Square so beautiful is
going to be up a part you see lay on
levia it's shaking his head and what
kosher kavutski said that Sabina Foster
is underrated she's just under 2200 she
makes the team average work and she's
working on the chessboard right now
she absolutely is Leon levage got too
casual he was slightly better out of the
opening but he opened up the center
prematurely and he is paying the price
in the most direct way imaginable losing
the pawn on D4 which used to be
protected by a lovely Pawn on E3 but he
got rid of that pawn didn't realize how
quickly sabina's pieces would get into
the game and you don't have to tell her
twice Knight F takes D4 is on the board
black is up a center pawn and for Sabina
right now I think sibi needs to go for
the kill I think she needs to believe in
her winning chances here obviously she
must be nervous right now she
understands the gravity of this game and
the impact that she could make with a
huge upset Victory let's see if she can
maintain her composure and most
importantly Robert manage her time well
and leave herself with enough time to
make good solid decisions and right now
The Rook came to C5 trying to win this
Pawn on D5 the problem for white is even
if you win the pawn I like to move Rook
C to d8 because if you take this Pawn on
D5 with your knight ever the black Rook
goes all the way down to E2 and their
problems everywhere in the position and
as you're pointing out B6 will kick The
Rook away so uh for Sabina she needs to
keep this lead on the clock just as much
as she wants to keep this extra Pawn on
the board and what kotia said is true
she has a wealth of experience she used
to be around 23 50 feet she has lost
points in recent years rating his
temporary classes forever she has what
it takes to take down the voyage in this
end game she also needs to keep that
lead on the clocks and that's where I'm
keeping my eyes
with every ticking second I'm starting
to get a little bit more worried here
now I draw would still be a very
impactful result would be a bit of a
disappointment given how much better she
is but nonetheless Amina has to make
sure that she doesn't flag that she
doesn't bring herself down to 10 five
seconds when absolutely anything can
happen a mouse lip plundering a fork I
have lost a couple of completely winning
positions to Leon levage in Blitz and
bullet games he is incredibly tricky as
Are all uh up and coming young GMS but
Rook C to the eight is on the board the
best move found by Sabina foister and so
far she is playing perfectly keeping her
Palm guarded 92 check Robert is a huge
threat penetrating to E2 and chopping up
more pawns on the queen side and we're
talking about how Knight takes D5 is not
really available in many positions
because of this B6 push so just to show
that yeah Rook needs to stay protecting
the Knight that Rook gets booted away
and that means that black would win
material and now lay on the viage about
40 seconds remaining on his clock that's
very bad bad news for the Bulldogs they
are down
on the scoreboard and now they're down
on this board he is bored too for the
Bulldogs but board four for the unicorns
is straight King H1 that's a sad move to
play maybe the best move down here but
who plays King H1 in an end game you
don't want you want your king of the
center
I'm not claiming I'm A Swindle
specialist I don't think I've ever won a
lost position in fact that's the only
thing I've done so you got to keep the
tension if you're Leon levage try to
keep as many pieces on the board set
traps when you can but you are on your
last legs I think Sabina should step on
the gas pedal G7 G5 well maybe not
because if Knight takes D5 and then the
F6 spawn hangs 92 check is much simpler
but levage can take and play Rook D1
Robert this game is far from over Sabina
needs to continue to play actively and
accurately but Levites is going to try
to boot The Rook off of E2 with King F1
but she has a trap Knight E5 welcomes
King F1 when The Rook takes F2 check you
sacrifice your Rook to win that Rook on
C5 so I actually think 95 to D3 can't
really be stopped because the Knight on
D2 is stuck in place the B2 Pawn behind
it is hanging so and 95 also threads
Rook takes D2 with a fork and F3 great
call but I think Sabina might be tempted
by Knight D4 which is inaccurate because
of King F1 and the similar tactic where
you try to simplify Into The Rook end
game I won't show that because Sabine is
about to make a move fails to Rook takes
D5 that's exactly how you see these
turnarounds no she's founded 95 on the
board Sabina making All the Right Moves
oh my lands and shield Rook takes up too
and you see leviath he's he didn't see
that coming at all he wants to resign
you could tell this is a team event you
cannot give up unless the position is
hopelessly lost there is still some hope
for women D4 throw that pawn forward
that is a passer and you can push it as
far as D3 but as you're pointing out B4
will boot that black knight backwards
sabina's clock continues to dwindle
White's down to 10 seconds Sabine is
down to 50 seconds she has to keep
herself above let's say 20 seconds King
F7 blunders upon though Knight E3 and
Levites are starting to make a little
bit of progress still some hope for the
Croatian Grand Master here oh my gosh
you push your Pawn too far now
this is bad she has so much extra time
but she is moving too quickly B4 will
boot the Knight out the D3 Pawn will
fall and I don't think she has an
advantage anymore this is not good for
the unicorns they really wanted her to
Spring this full upset
and games are cruel right this is how
quickly the game can turn around and I'm
gonna say something crazy Leon levage if
you can pick up the D3 Pawn is already
playing for a win but he's over
ambitious he's allowed rookie for check
and now he's got to waste the tempo The
Rook will infiltrate to E2 King D4 was a
horrific move by Levites King F3 was
automatic but he might still be able to
pull out half a point yeah he'll be
fortunate to hold that this game because
he is down a pawn in a simplified rook
and pawn ending and now for black where
do you put your Rook I would actually
bring it back to B5 put it on the A5
square and then move my king about she
went G6 okay she's just keeping the
status quo but Rook G2 that keeps the
Rook on D3 honest so what she really
wants and A6 here keeps that King out
she wants the white Rook to go to D6 and
go take the queen side pawns while she
takes the king side part I actually
think she's gonna win this game
she has great chances I want to stay on
this game and mention the bertia
danishvar is much much better in an end
game against Ray Robson so good news
there for the Bulldogs but let's stay on
this fascinating Rook end game Sabina
trying to find inroads going back and
forth knifing her way into White's
territory but now dropping the king back
Leon levage is still keeping her at Bay
and he's actually pretty close
especially if you can take both of these
pawns to creating a pond race and
potentially a draw it's so tough to beat
these GMC says by tedroid one she just
simplifies it she wants to keep her King
running while the enemy King is far away
it's not a horrible effort in your
opponent's time trouble but king of
fights with my Rook F3 check that is the
important Saving Grace
King E5 E3 check followed by Rook have
three check black cannot afford to give
up the F6 pawn and I think Leon levich
is on the cusp of bringing his skin back
there it is he should be able to hold
the draw now and Sabina has to stay
careful because I've seen crazier stuff
than this Rook takes G3 would force the
draw but she's still in the driver's
seat she is still very much pushing with
King E4 yeah she wants F4 now perhaps to
get her king after no she goes back but
this game will be a draw now Liam
leviath can finally breathe at long last
this is simplified and both players know
it this is now going to be a split point
so uh we can leave these players I feel
confident that nothing crazy is going to
happen and if we go back to the bird's
eye view as this game is about to come
to its conclusion we see it is a okay
she doesn't want the three-time
repetition but she trades her final Pawn
she doesn't that's a draw
huge news Robert for the unicorns George
Meyer has saved a completely lost
position and held the draw held the draw
against Bogdan Deja the number one for
the Bulldogs that's half a point that uh
the Bulldogs want back good news there
for the unicorns but let's go to the
Robson game because that is in a wild
time scramble wow and Robson I mean this
position is worse for him yeah we would
go right into that game and the Knight
can come back to C3 forking everything
but there is a rook the problem is the
King has made it the white King has made
it whoa G3
H takes G3 should end it but Knight
takes D1 might be the Practical option
in a Time scramble yeah he's gonna bring
his Knight back to D3 how many pawns are
under attack how many pawns is black up
this is gonna be huge a disappointing
game by Dash But Ken Danish far finish
it off he is laying down the wood in
this accelerated dragon and Rook E3
leads to mate so the white king is
nothing a checkmated I know that Ray
Robinson sees taxes quickly but rookie
three oh 93's even easier to win a piece
this is resign time 21 seconds F6 check
anything wins B4 rookie three just don't
allow stalemate that's it
wow bardia dinesmart is a monster the
Iranian he's about to be Minted as a
grand master he's about to deliver
Checkmate on the G3 Square it's resign
notes it's lost on time but same is true
mate awesome time resignation it's still
a win for bardia Dinesh for a huge for
the Bulldogs because Dania they look
like they were in huge trouble but they
tie this set of games two to two so they
keep the match within Striking Distance
they could not be happier at this result
Leon levage is going to be kicking
himself for not winning but he holds the
draw in a dead lost position a black win
for bardia danishvar and their most
disappointing result Robert was the
Bogdan dad struck georgmeyer he's not
just a buzz side he is as solid as a
rock he just does not give up it was a
winning position Robert for many many
moves but ultimately Bogdan
oversimplified it he he brought his
pieces too far back traded queens and
georgmeyer managed to hold a miserable
end game for a bunch of moves with no
time on the clock very impressive stuff
wait but how did this game end in a draw
because the evaluation bar seemed like
just go to the end just like the final
position and Ed final position is this
it's winning for white apparently
White's up a pawn so how did this game
end in a draw oh my gosh H6 ends the
game immediately kick F6 oh
yeah oh my gosh you're repeated by
accident
oh my God
so what you're telling me is that
georgmeyer escaped to the draw because
of a three-time repetition just like Jew
and June had against Nicholas theodoro
earlier today
I can't believe this he had a million
chances to go H6 and eight seconds is
not one second this is something that's
well within its capabilities but he got
nervous he got impatient he got nervous
and when you're in time pressure for 30
moves Robert crazy things start to
happen a huge Miss for bogged on Daniel
Dash but all credit to York for staying
in the game and Kaiser rewards him well
okay then the 2-2 finish for round two
seems even more fair because Sabina
forger she was about to take down levage
he survives your Meyer was about to lose
but he survived that is a split point
for both of them California and Croatia
only one point separates them Donya well
done Daniel one half points but bardia
dineshfar he's the real hero thus far
for the Bulldogs while for the unicorns
it's kind of everybody doing their part
yeah they're evenly distributed Sabina
foyer right she's done her job yeah she
didn't win that position but she pulled
out a huge draw with the black pieces
that gives her a lot of confidence and
she will have white in the next round
Leon levage he needs to step it up he
needs a big win in the next round and
back down Daniel Dash has to put this
game behind him and keep setting himself
on the right course this is a nail biter
Robert no better way to end the day than
with a match like this certainly not
only one point separates these two teams
will we see Ty breaks that remains to be
seen but for now we will get on out of
our chair stretch our legs get some
water because when we return the action
will continue here at the final match of
protest League week one it is the
Croatia Bulldogs led by a garbatore and
the California unicorns led by chess
dojo
thank you
[Music]
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything is
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 of games get to this position from
this position white is winning about 60
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I don't know
you see the board won for the Croatia
Bulldogs on screen in front of you that
is Bogue Don Daniel dayaj he is a super
Grand Master and I can't tell if his
bookshelf is organized or messy I see
some binders there Dania so I want to
say it's organized and he just has a lot
of things
it's a state of control entropy you know
he's got a school binders at the top but
the top of it is making a little bit
nervous that Globe at the top I feel
like if you breathe on it wrong the
whole structure could topple over well
Bogdan was unable to deliver on a
winning position in the last round but
it is not the end of the world for the
Croatia Bulldogs who are very much still
in the match maintaining that one point
deficit that they had after the first
round Robert as we review the pairings
for round three I was busy thinking
about the second law of Thermodynamics I
think that's like net entropy well and
minimum stay the same or maybe increase
but that's neither here nor there bug
done Daniel dayaj gets black against
daughters and Spirits Ray Robinson with
white against Leon Levites leviath he
barely survived against Sabina Forster
and speaking of Sabina she gets black
against bardia dineshra that's a big
opportunity for the Bulldogs Sabina has
shown she is not going to go down
without a fight but bartier Dinesh
Ferrar isn't playing excellent chess he
just took Down super Grandmaster Ray
Robson so Dunya as you look across the
four boards where is your X Factor game
well berdia danishvar is a huge pickup
for the Bulldogs he needs to deliver the
X Factor game for me is Leon leviach's
game against Ray Robson it is a tall
task he is not in the best form he has
the black pieces against array who is
determined to make up for his loss in
the previous round will on the vich be
able to get out of a tailspin calm
himself down and score at the very least
half a point I think that's what the
Bulldogs need to at least level up the
score after this round
well we see two players on our screen's
Darius spearch against Bogue Don Daniel
dayat so the unicorns have a one point
lead they get the white pieces in this
game and what do you make of this
matchup because spiritually he's not
somebody who takes risks unnecessarily
he starts with D4 in this game what do
you anticipate happening between these
two
yeah it's an interesting question and
Darius has written a two volume book on
one E4 here uh he plays the opening that
he's played for longer periods in his
life I agree with uh the gist of what
you're saying I think he's going to play
something on the more positional uh less
risky side 1987 by the way a very
popular Queens Gambit declined type
variation and White's got a vast array
of options here Bishop F4 uh has been
all the rage now for a couple of years
but Darius might play a Tamer idea like
C takes D5 where Jabba is nowhere to be
found but I think Darius is going to
keep himself uh well within range of
making a draw which would be a
completely acceptable result so my
favorite part of what you just did is
you didn't tell me or ask me if I
understood your hunt that was a good one
I uh appreciate that one but in this
position I have to appreciate that
Bishop F4 can be met by Pawn takes C4 so
these are the type of imbalances that
perhaps
once and we see that Bishop G5 5 was
played instead and now the bishop is
kicked the bishop goes back to H4 black
often just slides the bishop seven
breaking the pin and we have a solid
position right now black can take on C4
at some moment but that allows the white
Pawn to go up to E4 you don't want to
give your opponent the center so easily
yeah this this particular line of the
Queen's gamut has existed since time
immemorial but the idea of capturing on
D5 is a somewhat newer Trend so we've
got peace trades all across the board
the knights could get swapped as well or
Darius could play more ambitiously which
he does with E4 and I think we called it
Robert he's playing with less risk two
minor pieces are already off the board
but that doesn't mean the position has
no life this resembles a semi-tara
structure now particularly in the event
of a trade where black gets the classic
two on one majority on the queen side
and white gets the corresponding
majority in the center
and we will likely see that trade at
some point but perhaps I was gonna say
press B6 first nope B6 second the bishop
comes to B7 or Brook will come to C8 the
Knight will go to F6 but white is first
to the C file so Rook C1 right now is
very tempting and perhaps black will
play we'll play Knight F6 or there's the
second option of E5 I don't love the
look of E5 because you allow uh White to
have a past Pawn but you do carve out
the C5 Square for your knight so there
are pros and cons to every decision
there are indeed but Knight F6 is
Daniel's uh bogdon Daniels decision and
darish is going to have to press the gas
pedal in the center if you fall asleep
and you allow black to get his pieces
into the game and this is how black wins
these positions he gets all his pieces
in and a queen trade generally favors
black here because it is easier to
create a past pawn and that will be an
outside pass spawn in a potential end
game so Darius he might have a very
solid position but he's not out of the
woods and I think he's going to have to
play with a lot of dynamism and energy
to justify uh the structural
Transformations that he has allowed in
the opening well you use the word
dynamism and I think as we zoom out of
this game we'll see a game that is more
Dynamic if you look on the top right of
your screen there's been a pawn push up
to G5 for Leon levia so he is showing no
fear against Ray Robson as he takes that
Bishop on G3 uh the third game is also
about to start and there it goes bordia
the NASCAR plays Knight F3 we saw him
against Darius spearch play a very
strategic battle where he just had more
space and better control we'll see if
Sabina foyer can defend him off so Dania
uh in the top right I think that game
will likely be quite interesting between
the puzzle Rush champion and and angry
man leviath who lost to georgmeyer and
barely escaped with the draw against
Sabina fusher indeed and I think it does
Merit a closer look so let's zoom in to
Leon leviach's game against Ray Robson
and a big decision right now on deck for
Rey which side is he going to Castle now
you don't need to ask me you don't need
to ask Ray twice castles long that's the
only thing I wanted to hear that's what
we see but Robert let's not pretend that
this is not without tremendous risk
those Bishops they might be blocked in
by pawns right now but in the event of a
well-timed C5 perhaps supplemented by
Queen A5 and Rook CN maybe even B5 B4
you could totally see white get
checkmated here but white could also rip
open the center and it's not like black
skin is in a comfortable bed surrounded
by blankets it's feeling mighty
uncomfortable as well oh I would love to
be surrounded by blankets but instead
commentating with you not a bad
alternative and Donya I think the black
king has a choice because it can Castle
King said right now I would prefer to
Castle Queen side I think that you could
slide your queen up to E7 Castle Queen
side quickly bring your king to B8 and
then try to proceed from there but Rey
is going to slide his own King to B1 his
Rook to C1 his Knight to A4 and just try
to compete for the queen side so it's
kind of it looks tactical but there's a
lot of strategic elements at Play
there most certainly are and if the
Queens are swapped then the nature of
the game transitions entirely from
Dynamic and tactical to fully strategic
so you cannot play with abandoned here
especially with black you've got these
weak light squares uh on the king side
so I'm totally with you very very hard
position to handle and that is why we
see both players taking significant
things on every move
and while they do I do want to zoom out
once again because a game that is quite
far along is the last game that began
Paulina shuvalova with the white pieces
in the bottom right against Georg Meyer
I know the Queens are off the board
white has the bishop pair I feel like
this is everything you'd want if you're
thinking about this from the Croatia
Bulldogs perspective
yeah I would assume that this is
preparation by chevalova yorkmeyer is
one of the most predictable players uh
over 2600 he's also one of the best
prepared but those things they can go
hand in hand as we know from the case
for example of Maxime Michelle agrov
he's played the French for his entire
life he played it in this game and
shavalova essayed a system with an early
G3 kind of misdirection because the
bishop was not fan ghetto it delivered a
check on B5 that led to a mass trade and
white I think sits here with a
comfortable slight plus a bishop pair
Robert and most importantly that Knight
on D5 as impressive as it looks it could
be chased away on demand but white
should not do that too early because
then you would be weakening tremendously
some key squares along the D file yeah
I'm with you I like the look of White's
position but it's not like there's a
major advantage the one thing you don't
want when you have a pair of Bishops the
two Bishops Advantage is just trade off
one set of Bishops because then the
Knight often dominates the remaining
Bishop just think about it a knight on
D5 can't be kicked out by a Dark Sword
Bishop so Dania match strategy the
Croatia Bulldogs entered this round down
by a point this is a game where they
have the white pieces Paulina is you
know all but a grand master right she is
2500 uh she is very strong she just
doesn't have her final Norms yet but you
know when you look at this there's a
draw is that good for the Bulldogs of
the Unicorn
I think Paulina should decline to draw
if it's offered here I I feel like a
draw with black is a solid result for
the unicorns I mean well I've done
Daniel dad rarely loses games he's solid
um Leon levich against Robson I mean Ray
has the white pieces he's the favorite
there so you start thinking about it
you're gonna have to deliver on some of
your white games and I don't think that
Paulina is thinking about this from the
perspective of making a quick draw I
think she's gone for this end game
intentionally and she believes uh that
she can outmaneuver York Meyer here
which Robert is a task that very few
have accomplished and will accomplish so
I do not envy what's on paulina's plate
in this position put that on your plate
yeah well uh Sophie London will be proud
of you and so I'm seeing F3 now the king
will go to F2 I had to give you the
marvelous Mrs uh uh maisel sort of
reference there and we'll see some slow
development in this one so while that
happens let's tune out let's go back to
our bird's eye view just because this is
an end game and well Dania I see in the
top right Ray Robson against Liam levias
the king is still in the center for
black and then in the bottom left I see
Guardia Dinesh far against Sabina forger
early stages I like once again sabina's
time management she's always playing
quickly giving herself a time later down
down the stretch to find the best moves
I like her time management as well I
don't love her position she's given up
the bishop pair just seems like a
classic slight Advantage this position
could also come from a car economy and
you see uh that inverted upon triangle
which is common in the two knights Caro
so I feel like bardia is solidly better
and he's probably trying to figure out
whether he wants the center open or
whether he wants to push E5 so
definitely some decisions to be made and
Sabina foyer adjusting after that first
round and leaving herself with enough
time on the clock the Rooks traded also
in the top left encouraging uh signs
here for bogd and Daniel daj I think who
is holding his own pretty comfortably
thus far the more we look at the other
games the more I think Paulina who's not
risking anything should just make a draw
because Bulldogs are doing well across
the other boards not anything major not
a huge Advantage but you still want to
be ground down in an end game by Georg
Meyer and we know he's capable of that
so uh while that looks like the Rooks
are being traded off in the chevalova
game so I don't worry for either side
but I'm a bit worried in the game
between spiritual and Bogan Daniel deox
because you call this you foreshadow
this a long long time ago that for daryu
Spirits once the Pieces come off the
board black should have the slightly
upper hand because in an end game the
two on one Queen side majority should be
more helpful than the extra poll in the
center
well as we travel back to bogd and
Daniel Dash's state of controlled
entropy I think everything is well
organized in this position we might by
the way see a repetition here and now in
schwalova's game and we will let you
know if that happens but uh in the
meantime the Rooks are off the board and
I think a lot of people Robert would
look at this and say ah it's obviously a
draw uh you've got the same pieces on
the board but it could not be further
from being an immediate drive but the
position is equal but there's a lot
going on here under the hood the bishop
is hanging there is a pawn imbalance and
Bogdan Daniel Dage has a big decision to
make bishop A6 would trade the Bishops
Bishop B7 is also tempting because it
puts pressure on e4 where do you think
he should go
I generally like the look of Bishop B7
white will play H3 just to create left
for the king but
I'm trying to say the winning plan right
not that it's not a winning position we
acknowledge that it's about level but
I'm just trying to understand what plans
that both can execute to put pressure on
spirits and he plays Bishop B7 so if the
move H3 is played what's next for black
is there like a knight E8 to D6 I've
seen that happen before I just don't
know where the pieces belong
yeah that's that's where I love you know
Vladimir kramnik or Magnus Carlson in my
corner uh just to give me a little bit
of a push I feel like those players just
effortlessly find ways to keep
increasing the pressure tightening the
screws you could try that with A6 and B5
but you're also weakening a bunch of
squares when you're doing that so you
just can't push your pawns with abandon
you need to find the right time to do
that great call by you and Dari is
saying listen I'm just gonna hold the
fort here keep all my pawns protected
I'm tossing the ball right back into
bdd's court
first of all great nickname I've never
heard that before uh but
for black one of the big questions is
like can you bring the king towards the
center it is an end game so if you could
trade the Queens I think black then is
much happier but white for now is just
controlling the center it's very
important that the black pieces can't
jump forward I think E4 to E5 at some
point would be a huge mistake uh you do
not want to push that pawn it gives the
D5 Square to Black and opens up that
Bishop on B7 so the status quo is good
enough for spirits but the clock
situation that's also a bother he is
down over a minute on time and Pokemon
Daniel Dash has won title Tuesday in the
past he is really really good at Blitz
we'll turn to a Grandmaster hearing E5
in this position is akin to the sound of
nails scraping a glass table it is
definitely not on White's radar unless
of course uh E5 allows the queen to
infiltrate the C8 which is not possible
because the bishop controls that square
so Bogdan he's going to invest a long
time here uh get further into his
comfort zone which is of course the time
scramble which he seems to have in every
game and he does in fact make the
committal decision to play A6 so Robert
if he wanted an uneventful draw here I
think he could have brought his Queen
back to E7 or maybe played King f8 I
think he's signaling with this move and
he feels that he should at least make an
attempt to win this game
well players that are not making
attempts at least no longer are Paulina
and yeah I just saw the repetition
happen so that game is over and done
with a draw between board four for the
Bulldogs and board three for the
unicorns I think that's a very fair
result I think that was the desired
result for the Bulldog so as we look at
the other remaining boards the bottom
right is a draw the other three are
still in session Dania I'm looking the
bottom left and F4 was just played by
bardia dineshvar and I'm looking at the
top right where all of a sudden Ray
Robson that position is chaotic I don't
know where to turn but I'm gonna let you
take the steering wheel
well I'll second what you said lower
left bardia is very much in control of
the game he's got the dream set up he
will need to speed up a little bit of
Sabina has kept herself ahead on the
clock but I want to take a look at Ray
robson's game you called it Leon levage
has ensured the safety of his King by
Castle in queenside but he seems to have
forgotten that there are problems
awaiting him on the other side of the
board Rey has insta Bishop on F5
cemented it with a pawn and has a very
clear plan of increasing the king I
guess that's technically the king side
the king side pressure with Rook D-Day
F1 Leon leviage has just made too many
sloppy moves thus far and those moves
will not go unpunished by someone as
powerful as Ray Robson
look at this position just Domination by
those pawns E5 and D4 and G4 and any
trade you hope to make perhaps upon the
land on F5 but even a rook or queen
Lenny there the F7 Pawn is backwards the
H6 pawns backwards
I don't think I love that decision
I don't either I feel like there was no
rush and that gives Leon perhaps a Tempo
to put a Band-Aid on some of these
squares you're never supposed to play it
Dania but F6 here because you were
trying to rip open the e-file and that
way if you take on F6 then I think black
can just take on F5 and take on E3 after
that I I don't like what Ray just did
there was no reason to trade pieces when
you have more space more control you're
told to keep the pieces on the board and
I guess maybe Rook takes E3 as a blunder
because a rook takes
oh gosh that's nope that's not the move
what is this rookie one maybe just a
quiet move
typical anticlimactic computer chest
because the pawns are too strong but
I'll let you finish your thought Robert
apparently in this position you have to
make a very Zen move like just Queen C7
to t7 the epon actually works in your
favor because it keeps White's D1 Rook
without active prospects okay well
that's way more complicated than
initially met there I thought you would
just play F6 take on E3 and survive but
I was mistaken I acknowledged that I own
that uh but I still stand by my
statement that when you have more space
you want more pieces on the board if we
just go back one move down here before
Knight to C5 just to show what that
looked like where was that night on D7
going the answer is absolutely nowhere
so I feel like race should have just
been able to slide his Rook over and by
the way look what move was just played
so man leviath he understands that he
can't get away with this move F6 and you
don't want this to turn around right you
need to be careful
he does indeed and Leon understanding
that the opportunity train was about to
leave the station if Ray would position
The Rook on F1 F6 would be a bite would
be a possibility uh that would not
reoccur and the pressure down the f file
would simply become decisive and now the
big big moment for Leon if Rey takes on
F6 which I think he should Will Leon be
able to resist the temptation attack on
A3 no it's a moot point Bishop G6
instead is Race Choice
wow so Ray going after the Rook but
can't that Rook just slide over is the
best Bishop F5 after that are we gonna
see a repetition
huh
and maybe Rey's just trying to milk
leviath's clock down and then we'll play
he takes F6 but Robert after Rook G8
Bishop F5 well I can take and take on E5
and claim the extra Pawn I don't know
what to make of that position either
I don't really understand what Ray is
doing I'm gonna be honest I didn't I
kind of trusted him so I didn't think he
would give him a pawn but he must be
doing it for a reason
well Leon's gotta move he took about 45
seconds on that but he's calling Grace
Bluff and black must be objectively
better at this point yeah you see the
eval bar going just under the halfway
point advantage or black uh but we see
what Ray wants he has a healthy pass
Pawn on F5 a rook behind it he can play
G4 at any moment if it needs defense uh
but I like what Leon levage is doing
here he is up a pawn he can just take on
D4 if he wants and then he can bring a
rook to the f8 I can't go Rook f8 easily
because Rook takes H6 sneaky tactics
from the puzzle Rush King
listen my gut feeling given the time
situation levage is an incredible bullet
player but I just feel very apprehensive
about Black's chances that pass Pawn
supported by The Rook is the worst enemy
of the player who's in time first
there's so many tricks here F6 F7 and
then again Rook takes H5 there's
constant deflection ideas because the
queen is aimed at the promotion Square
yeah and what is levia's next move he
you know said a he's got to say B and he
does so he plays H4 F7 will probably
drop the pawn after Rook f8 you can't
bring another piece to defend it so all
of a sudden leviath can start playing
Rook f8 Rook F7 other Rook to f8 things
of this nature and he may be able to
Corral that runaway past Pawn so this is
a big moment for the California unicorns
they do not want to see this match turn
in the Bulldogs favor
A Swindle win here by levage would be
huge but even a draw would be an
excellent result for the Bulldog so Rey
needs to make sure he doesn't lose his
mind here do anything foolish perhaps
Rook F5 he plays G4 crazy move trying to
exploit Black's time pressure on poisson
here I think fails to Rook takes h8 and
F7 Ray playing for tricks but it might
work
well I mean what other moves are
possible H6 G3 out of the questions so
you can take on D4 if you want you can
push that pawn to E4 to release the
tension of those pawns and then play
Rook f8 and so on and black now has a
protected outside pass Pawn let's not
forget about that by playing G4 you've
given your opponent a passer uh this is
dangerous territory for both players and
Levites down into 25 seconds at this
point this is not good
and its form just hasn't convinced me
that he will be able to handle these
complications uh for the next couple of
moves Ray can intensify the pressure
with the Rook F5 I think E4 should have
been played on the Move prior but Rook
f8 is solid enough keeping this Pawn at
Bay and a decision for it Ray Robson D
takes these five allows the queen to get
active the immediate Rook F5 allows
black to lock up the center with E4
yeah Rey's thinking so I just want to
draw our attention if we zoom out for a
second to the other games we'll be right
back here but if you look in the bottom
left bardia dineshar is cruising oh or
he was until that move somehow that
allows black back in the game but I do
think white just has a Healthy Advantage
regardless and in the top left bogdon
Daniel Deus he might be the hero for the
Bulldogs it's adventure and look at
darje's clock he's five seconds
he's five seconds let's go to that game
indeed because it doesn't seem like
anything has changed why it's clock
certainly has changed and the position
has changed black is making progress
pushing these pawns and with five
seconds Robert can Darius handle the
further progress of these spots he's got
to find a way to get the Queens off the
board and reach some sort of clarity or
he's going to buckle under the time
pressure you know at one point or
another
yeah some of these players are moving
very a ginger Pace I mean this is very
slow play thus far five seconds in this
position B4 G whoa who plays G4 with
five seconds of the clock
Darius just trying to force matters he's
trying to open up Black's King but he's
opening up his own Queen C6 here builds
the pressure on e4 A5 is also possible
but damage now down to 40 seconds
himself so this ain't over
no it's not and B3 is also he plays A5
just a very simple straightforward with
three seconds whoa got to move up G5
swaps pawns and now what is E5 actually
a threat at some point for white
well I was thinking about playing E5 for
black and uh forcing the Queens off the
board but not sure about that Queen C7
E5 is played who called it 95 Queen E4
is what Darius is aiming for he wants to
Checkmate the black king but he might
check made his own Queen C1 check yeah
but there's also Queen C6 first that
turns checkmated one but he goes Knight
D5 and oh Queen C1 picks up the knight
in G5 good eye by you
Darius has to step away Queen C1 and
Knight F4 might end the game but bogged
on 18 seconds he has to avoid panicking
he simply must and well Queen said one
step one oh 93 is tricky
uh goes for the queen trade
okay actually that's just great decision
making he's an outside pass Pawn
and he's gonna go after this Apon or
play A4 and B3 but he has to be very
very careful in this end game Darius has
a chance here if he can get his Knight
back in time
go Bishop A6 get out of this pin bring
your Bishop to C4 he plays B3 right away
if a takes there's A3 you can't oh A3
yeah A2 a night before in any order
any order night before is brilliant and
he's gonna either win the bishop on e4
or promote a queen it's over
and that's a huge win for the Bulldogs I
mean you could take two minor P what
what was that
oh my gosh
and look at Darius future this is why
you don't resign I cannot believe what
we just saw instead of promoting he took
the Knight and gave up his passer and
he's gonna lose or is he he's keeping
the night at Bay he might lose this
Knight D3 he's gonna lose this game that
is unbelievable that is up there with
the Gawain Jones blunder I mean just won
but I can't believe what I'm seeing what
is up with this week Robert this is
insane the b-bond is gonna promote
oh my gosh and black at best sacrifices
the bishop for the pawn there's a
remaining Pawn that's resonation that is
unbelievable so if you see Darius he
just like goes I get out of here but
let's go back to that moment quickly
because Darius it's just like this was a
ridiculous game
this was insane he played the right move
but then he didn't promote the pawn he
forgot that the Knight was making
contact with A2 and Robert 11 seconds
that's what makes this moment and the
gawaine Jones Mouse slip uh of his
opponent so crazy take your time man he
blitzed out Bishop takes E4 spent less
than a second and after Knight takes A2
the pawn is gone and so are black
chances A1 Queen and Darius literally
resigns the game because everything is
falling here yeah Queen C3 check it
doesn't matter it was an apple Queen
yeah and Darius he can't he can't
believe it he is beside himself but the
Croatia Bulldogs will likely be beside
themselves let's go back to our full
scene we see that two games remain in
the top right Ray Robson against Lynn
leviage that's a rook and pawn ending
that's looking quite level but in the
bottom left chaos ensues Sabina fleisher
she's fighting she may be worse but she
has a chance because bardia dineshwar's
clock is ticking down to 40 seconds
she has clawed her way back into that
game I think Rey's game is gonna end in
a draw so sabina's game definitely the
one with the most Intrigue something is
in the air Robert and bardia he has to
win this game I mean the match isn't
over if he doesn't win but he absolutely
has to deliver to keep the Bulldogs in
the match I still can't believe what we
just saw but let's focus on sabina's
attempt to stay in this game and look at
what she's doing yes you could take on a
five with her rook and then bring her
Queen into G3 let's not forget that
black is actually up material there are
two Rooks for black only one for white
and after Queen G3 there are threats
everywhere Rook F2 rookie five Rook H5
you name a rook move it's a threat so
Queen G3 is Sabina Forster's chance
right now
important that The Rook on F6 is
guarding the C6 Square the moment the
Knight lands on C6 it is snapped off the
board Black's King has a has time white
black has the time to play Queen G3 and
Savina using the rest of her time here
she has to step on the gas pedal right
here a huge chance she goes red that's
also a perfectly good move white does
not want to trade Queens you have the
attack Queen 65. what up Ray one Ray one
no way
oh my gosh you wanna Pawn down Rook end
game look at the final position he's
forcing The Rook trade and we'll take on
D5 and this in the top right everybody
Ray Robinson gets the win the Rooks are
coming off white wins the king and pawn
end game that ensues that is
unbelievable the unicorns I mean they're
a magical creature Magic is happening
right now oh my goodness
they could basically win this match if
Sabina completes the Swindle but let's
go back to sabina's game she's down to
five seconds and I'm growing a little
bit pessimistic it looks like danishvar
is turning this game around Queen E4
ends the game so does Knight C6 check
Queen E4 I don't even see a move for
black but there's no threat whoa with
the king in the corner no way how
is there no good Discovery somehow
well the night's gonna drop back the
queen and seven guards B7 night guards
oh she lost some time she completely
forgot about her clock you could see it
in the expression on her face granted
she was in Rough Waters the king 98 but
Sabina Forster can't believe it she was
worse out of the opening bardia dinesfar
he is what is keeping the Croatia
Bulldogs in this match Daniel I think we
have to show the Ray Robinson ending
against Leon leviath because I mean that
just can't happen in a match of this
nature Ray Robson wins that position
there
and okay I didn't want to overstate the
case this is not better for black it was
better for black earlier but levage he
liquidates okay make the drop go Rook
D60 plays Rook G6 this doesn't spoil it
he brings the king in offer a draw
anything he stays afloat King F6 Dedra
Rey has no way to make progress here not
at all Rook H5 and Rook B8 unacceptable
move there by Leon Levi she panics
completely and allows white to push the
king away and drop the king into E5 he
had to find at this point a move like
King G6 or even Rook G8 Rook H6 check
and bringing the king back but all kudos
to Rey for creating a position where
it's not actually that easy to find one
of these moves Robert obviously Leon had
better moves earlier to avoid the
situation but the upshot is that white
forces The Rook trade and wins another
improbable game
I am in disbelief right now because you
see the California unicorns took this
round two and a half one half both on
Daniel Daya outplayed Dario search the
entire game he could have promoted his
Pawn to a new Queen he somehow inverted
the move order or thought a different
move happened and he loses that game had
he won it we'd have a tied match but
that's another here nor there that's a
thing of the past it is a 7-5 lead for
the unicorns thanks to Darius fears and
Ray Robinson somehow getting victories
in their games
bogged on Daniel Dash's bookshelf could
have itself promoted to A1 that you
could have you know breathed on the pawn
and it would have promoted unbelievable
hallucination it costs uh the Croatia
Bulldogs a point but it does not
necessarily cost them to imagine they've
got a cushion we've seen five seven
comebacks we actually saw the blitz come
back I believe from a five seven deficit
you were commentating that Robert so it
is possible but they need to push what
just happened behind them bury it under
a pile of rubble Bogdan has to store
that game in the bookshelf behind him
and focus on delivering a huge
Redemption game
is keeping the Croatia Bulldogs in this
we'll see if he can win his final game
and maybe land them that comeback that
they desire but for now we're gonna take
a quick break when return it is the
fourth and final round here at the last
match of week one of the protesting it's
your Croatia Bulldogs verse the
California unicorn stay tuned
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Ray Robson perhaps the hero for the
California unicorns he won what looked
like an unwinnable game and he has
helped his California unicorns with
seven to five lead over the Croatia
Bulldogs Dania we know Ray very well we
grew up playing against him that was not
his best game I think he would admit
that but he still has two points out of
his three games and now he's gonna get
the black pieces against it very very
angry both on Daniel dayaj
that would be quite the understatement
and the real MVPs Robert are those
players who are able to put in decent
performances even when they're in bad
form and they suffer a painful loss Ray
Robson suffered a painful loss to bardia
Don eschvar and I think painful there's
no word in the English language to
describe what Bogdan Daniel daj has got
to be feeling but whatever it is that he
has to be feeling he has to find some
way something inside of him that will
allow him to push that aside because
Bulldogs definitely have a major chance
to at the very least send this to a tie
break with a monster 3-1 Victory or even
take the match uh with three and a half
half or 4-0 but man oh man do a lot of
things have to go right and do they have
to avoid the craziness we saw in the
last round yeah I'm looking at this
lineup one half points needed by the
unicorns to take the match York Meyer
with the white Pieces good luck to
anybody who is facing him I don't care
if you're Magnus Carlsen but I'm looking
down at board four Paulina shuvalova
against Sabina forger Sabina has had
some good positions she almost took down
leviath but she's also been shaky at
times and I feel like shivalova she Drew
against York Meyer she's had the similar
type of day today she is the high rated
player she's the stronger player between
the two so I feel like board four could
settle this match and that could be good
news for the for the Bulldogs because
they are the rating favorite with
Paulina shuvalova having a big rating
Gap ahead of Sabina foyer indeed all
they need is a point and a half so
remember even if the unit the Bulldogs
win this round two and a half one and a
half that will not be enough because the
unicorns will hit the necessary eight
and a half points so the room for error
it's not non-existent they can lose a
game and still tie the match but that is
all that they can do here we go final
round of today buckle your seatbelts
Anna Berlin Ray Robson and I'll tell you
Bogdan is not going to force a Berlin
draw that would get him kicked off of
the team
well he plays D4 here he's taking
control of the center Ray Robson very
experienced very well prepared he always
has been ever since he was a teenager
because I played in the same events as
him we're on the U.S team together at
the world Team Championships so he knows
every opening Under the Sun and that's
why he's playing so quickly the last
couple moves seem ridiculous let's just
go back for a second why would white
play Rook E2 and then Rook to E1 so
rookie two it said well welcomes this
move B6 and the claim is that the bishop
for black it often goes out to F5 you
push your Pawn to D5 and bring the
bishop to F5 so in this variation B6 is
not considered a helpful move from
White's perspective and that doesn't
allow you to accomplish your initial
plan so chess is a game of these small
nuances I know that's particularly
complicated but here black often brings
the Knight out to E4 maybe tries to put
the pawn on D5 behind the Knight
Dania I've always struggled with this
opening I have to be honest me too and I
think so do most of the players play it
they're fighting for minuscule
advantages here right we're not talking
about attacks on the king and Checkmate
on move 20. they're fighting for 0.2.3
advantages and they analyze these lines
to move 25 or move 30. I mean I these
lines are a total mystery to me whether
the pawn belongs on D6 or D5 whether the
Knight belongs on e4 or F5 it's totally
counterintuitive that the bishop on B7
is actually worse than it would be on F5
but one reason why Robert I think is
that that Knight is more more vulnerable
than it looks the queen could come out
to G4 with Tempo and the second thing to
understand is that a move like B6 does
weaken your queen side it might not seem
evident now but one way to understand
that is if white runs the a pawn up the
board using the B6 Pawn as fuel uh to
fire up a potential Queen side
initiative so we'll see in the next
couple of moves if bogdan's hyper modern
approach is Justified and does in fact
lead to a small advantage
yes small being the operative word
because I feel like in these positions
it just you know you make incremental
progress maybe you have something to go
after uh but it's Ray Robson on the
clock he's not sure where to go so why
don't we go away from this game just for
the moment and then focus on Daniel's
has more time than he started with two
more games have begun in the top right
we have Leon leviath with the white
pieces against Darius Spears and then in
the bottom left we have Garrett Meyer
against bardia dineshfar so I'm looking
at the top right Dania in a must-win
game for land levage I think it's a
smart opening choice
and we have another Berlin Darius
Schwartz going for the Berlin I'm sure
he didn't coordinate that with Ray
Robson but it's just a very sensible
option in a situation where every draw
brings you oh so close to taking the
match and leave John levage has taken a
completely different approach from day
etch I think both approaches are valid
levage has gone for a line that has
gotten very popular in recent years
he takes on E5 and plays A4 that is the
path to the forced raw Robert but then
he deviates by bringing the queen out to
D3 and he is aiming for control of some
key dark squares you often see the queen
moving to C3 and the bishop aiming for
C5 but dariish aiming to beat him to the
punch because Queen C3 will run into
Bishop B4
yeah that's not pleasant you get to
develop the bishop for black with Tempo
then Castle your king So Bishop A6
already a threat Bishop B4 is available
because of the Pawn on A5 so what do you
do here for Atlanta if he's hasn't moved
yet he finally brings his Rook to D1 and
isn't Bishop A6 just a developing move
with Tempo against the queen then you
can bring your dark Square Bishop out
only one side has the light score Bishop
it's black something has already gone
wrong here for Leon Leviathan this is a
forgettable match for him especially if
he does not manage uh to at the very
least hold a draw a loss brings the
Bulldogs to the brink of defeat
everything else would have to go right
and let's be real I lost with the white
pieces I think will Spell immediate Doom
Darius playing a more modest move Bishop
E7 threat is stronger than its execution
and waiting for the perfect opportunity
to swing the bishop out to A6 but I love
his position he's solid he will Castle
he might even open up the king side
later Robert and really try to exploit
that Bishop pair that he's got by
opening up the king side
um it's true opening the king site could
play to Black's Advantage especially
with the King safe for uh Darius spirits
and Darius he won that game against Deus
that was incredible uh that was
fortunate I think he wants nothing to do
with that game anymore and he's in a new
one so Fort levage is C4 an option can
you push that pawn forward I just don't
see what white is trying to accomplish
if your knight could go to B3 in one
turn now we're talking right like the
Knight goes to B3 takes control of the
dark squares the dream scenario is the
dark squared Bishops disappear from the
board then white is in full control but
that's very far away
it is far away indeed and black is a
very clear path forward castles Bishop
A6 F6 a lot of low hanging fruit and
those are the kinds of positions that
you want in a rapid game levich
developing his Knight to D2 trying to go
for B3 Bishop A6 or even C5 move that we
haven't mentioned yet has now become
possible because the contact between the
rook and the pawn has been temporarily
severed by White's last move so I think
we'll leave Darius to his devices here
it's clear that he's solved his opening
problems but he will have to continue
playing accurately to keep White's Queen
side pressure at Bay let's go back to
the bird's eye view and check out the
other games all four of them are
underway and one of them I think is
going to finish pretty soon georgmeyer
is going to impose his will and get half
a point out of bardia danishvar you're
saying that georgmeyer wants a draw
that's in the bottom left uh he is
saying you know let's get these pieces
off the board let's just have equality
and if York draws that means only one
more point from the rest of the team but
that in a way could be good news for the
Bulldogs because on board four they're
gonna have to trust Paulina shuvalova to
get a win against Sabina fortune that is
mandatory and then they're gonna have to
find a win somewhere else and Well Done
Daniel dayas look at board one against
Ray Russell Ray is down four minutes on
the clock so I think that the Bulldogs
will be perfectly fine with a quick draw
for their board three
I think some people in the chat who
aren't as used to watching Team events
might think how could he possibly play
you know a grundfold and allow for a
straw totally agree with you Robert I
think a draw with black against York
Meyer who almost never loses with white
is a very wise decision yes you're
trusting your teammates but at the end
of the day you need a huge comeback and
you need your top boards to deliver
anyway so I think we're gonna see a draw
in that game maybe Gore though is going
to keep pushing I mean it's not over yet
and maybe he actually has a slight
advantage in that game I mean how many
of these end games have you seen him
squeeze out to a win Magnus Carlson
Style
way way way too many and we'll see if
today is another one of those but we're
gonna bring on somebody who is really
into this match someone who has uh you
know something at stake and that is
Costa kovusky the team captain for the
California unicorns gosia how are you
feeling right about now your team has a
7-5 lead all right have you recovered
from the third round of action
hey yeah we're we're doing good
Throwdown is definitely stressful there
was a moment there where I thought we
might even like lose like three and a
half half or something some of those
games looked very very very uh
uh Topsy Turvy but um the team got it
done I gotta say Darrow I feel like is
uh absolute hero playing really well
Jurg as well
and uh Ray also um I feel like he pulled
out a win in that last one which was
amazing
um so two point lead is great obviously
the match is not over so I'm not gonna
celebrate you know until until it's done
until we see that eight and a half and
it's it's clinched
well Costa you're watching the games on
your own stream and you go through the
whole gamut of emotions as the team
captain looks like Rey's close to
stabilizing the position here but when
you saw Darius pick up that pawn on A2
can you clue Us in on how exactly you
would describe the kind of euphoria that
you feel in that moment
yeah it's um it's like when you we've
been talking about food a lot on the
stream but it's like when you're you're
waiting for your food at a restaurant
and then you see the waiter coming out
of the kitchen and you like you see them
carrying your your tray of food and
you're like oh yeah I ordered that my
friend so you know it's your food it's
coming to your table like when I saw
when that pond he was like Knight versus
Bishop like outside past Pawn his King
gets in I was like oh my God I know
Dara's gonna win this he's just like so
Technical and so good in those
situations it's just such a relief I
think relief was the was the emotion
I mean have you seen a blunder of that
magnitude of course it was just uh
bogged on Deutsch he was struggling in
time pressure but have you seen
something that from a super Grand Master
that must have been shocking for you and
your audience
you know actually I I missed the exact
moment leading up to it I switched to
the game right as he was picking up the
pawn so I didn't realize that Bogdan
actually had had blundered I know he was
doing fine earlier and andara was way
down on time
um but yeah these wonders oh they're
brutal I mean sometimes like the match
just comes down to like a move or a
mouse slip or like a two-second thing
it's uh it hurts it really it really
stings when it doesn't doesn't go your
way unfortunately but um but that one
was was quite lucky for us
and it was a huge win right now we're
watching Ray Robson an opposite colored
Bishop middle game we were discussing
just before we brought you in castia uh
what we think is a wide strategy York
Meyer playing a very solid opening and
he's on the cusp of securing the first
half Point uh you need only a point and
a half do you approve of that strategy
and do you feel like Rey uh is out of
the woods here despite being down on the
clock
yeah I think um well no actually race
position to me it seems like he could
definitely be put under some pressure
especially given the match situation I
don't think diac is going to give him uh
an easy draw here if he can press I
think he'll try to press
um but yeah georga definitely approve of
his his approach just playing Super
solid
um I think it also makes sense because
he's playing a very very strong Junior
player and you know the the Trope The
Stereotype is to always take the kids
into the end game so I feel like there
might be a little bit of of that on
gorg's mind as well
um but this position looks so so drying
your Exposition that I feel like it's
yeah very likely just going to lead to a
draw that's okay I mean we're up by by
two points we just need one and a half
so you gotta have faith that the rest of
the team is going to be able to uh to
clinch it out
yeah I feel that question this one is
looking you know like the worst is kind
of behind Ray if he can play the move D5
and follow up with C6 it would appear
that he can finally get his Rook into
the action but white should stand better
uh with the Rook coming the only open
file that's rookie won in the near
future but if we zoom out of this game
for a second I just want to get your
opinion you are the captain one of the
captains for the California unicorns all
four games are still in session we've
talked about York Meyer in the bottom
left that one looks like a Surefire a
draw so no worries there but when you
see the other three boards are you
looking at it like okay we just need a
one other point we're gonna get it or
are you still nervous looking across
them
I mean yeah I'm always with these like
league matches and whenever you're
watching as like you know a coach or a
captain like you know you have no
control over the moves being made you
have no idea like what's gonna happen so
you feel a little a little powerless uh
either way but it's fun to root for the
team and I do really believe in these
guys um and Sabine as well I feel like
they've been
they've been very very clutch uh so far
um and uh yeah I think I think they'll
be able to uh
uh to pull it out obviously anything
could still happen so it's like yeah in
my mind by no means have we already won
so it's just gonna be a tight finish but
I'm hoping like everything goes
according to plan then and hopefully we
do uh we do take the first one home
well speaking of things going according
to plan we want to let you ride out the
match on your stream but before we do
that if we could go to darius's game
really quickly it seems to me at least
intuitively and the Evol bar disagrees
with me it felt when I looked at this
position that dariish has a pretty
significant initiative in the bishop air
but perhaps uh the the monster placement
of White's night on the central Outpost
outweighs Uh darius's current initiative
Costa what do you feel about this game
could this be at the very least another
half point in the bag for the unicorns
yeah it seems um very reasonable for for
Darrow here I know his opponent hasn't
done like that well in this match so far
so
I'm hoping yeah daru can at least get
half point that might be our winning
path here just a half point on the top
three boards
um I feel like one of them might even be
able to to somehow win but
okay one and a half is all we need so
that's that's definitely a good result
to uh to root for and um Sabina actually
I
don't think our position is um is that
bad uh right now it seems absolutely
fine but of course uh Paulina is just an
incredibly strong Blitz player so
um yeah that one will be will definitely
be very tough
yeah of every single game it feels like
goes down to the wire in this match and
while coaster will let you handle it
with your stream I hope it's an
enjoyable finish I hope you could smile
at the end of the day which means that
the results go your team's way but
thanks so much for stopping by with us
coach Jayden of course we'll send people
to the chess Dojo Channel they should
give you the support your educational
streams are awesome
thank you guys always a pleasure
and it was just the nicest guy
genuinely the kindest person ever it
really is I mean I've I know him for
many many years now he lived in the Bay
Area uh we we both taught at Bay Area
chess and that's when I got to know him
well just a credit to the chess
Community a fantastic instructor and uh
a fierce competitor Robert over the
board but absolutely the sweetest human
definitely follow his stream at
twitch.tv live
and maybe he could teach us a thing or
three about this ending because it's a
night on D4 against a light squared
Bishop that can't do anything and I saw
the bar react this move Bishop to D3 and
I just feel like White's play is simple
bring that Rook from A1 to E1 let's go
to the open file and then maybe The Rook
will go to E7 and A7 and we're just
gonna activate our pieces so I feel like
white has a free hand in this position
it's a type of position that only white
can win
not so sure about Rook A2 I guess he's
trying to go Rook B2 and pawn to B4 but
it just feels like the e-file was one
for the taking
and it feels like B4 it doesn't
accomplish as much as he thinks it does
in fact it could tactically backfire due
to Rook C4 that leads to a wild tactical
Skirmish Knight B5 there and there's
eight xb4 so that has to be calculated
but I agree rookie one
um he's putting all of his eggs in the
B4 basket rather than really nurturing
uh and trying to expand his positional
Advantage Leon levage has just missed
the mark thus far in this match
everything has to go right at this point
for the Bulldogs to secure uh at least a
tie so Rook a to B2 is very likely
having said a you have to say B and uh
the only Vice will have to squeeze a
full point out of this end game
he will he'll need to win for the
Bulldogs to have a chance and well
what's going on in the other boards we
know that jorg Meyer he was likely to
make a draw against bardia dineshvar
that's in the bottom left but Dania in
the bottom right that game is wild
between Sabina Forster and Paulina and
in the top left it looks like Ray Robson
he has zero issues anymore that game
looks likely to be a draw so the left
side looks drawn the right side slight
Edge to the Bulldogs but maybe not quite
enough
yeah Bogdan needs Kaiser to smile on him
especially after uh last the last round
he's asking the chess gods for at least
one lucky break he'll have to make
something out of nothing in that
position but I'll put it this way if I
face Magnus Carlson with a minute 40 in
a position like that I would still be
nervous so I think with White's control
of the e-file Rey needs to continue
being careful and continue being Speedy
obviously you can get the Queens off the
board then you're essentially knocking
on the door of a drawing Robert I agree
with you Sabina foyer is not just saying
I'm going to give this game away uh and
Trust the win to my teammates she is
doing everything she can to bag this
match on her own C5 is the last move I
don't think she's any worse there can we
also talk about the bottom left York
Meyer might win another unwinnable rook
and pawn ending he just has the more
active pieces I would not be surprised
if York wins in bardia dinesha's time
throw so I took that one for granted I
see the Evar and boom there it goes up
in York's favor after the move G5 was
played so
I think nothing going right for the
Bulldogs in this match it just feels
like it's slipping away from them even
when they have good positions and Ray
Robson I mean at this point we won't
jinx it by saying that that game is over
it's going to end in a draw there isn't
a single shred of winning chances Rey
with over a minute of a clock everything
is off the board and bogdon is going to
want to forget these last two games
great stuff by Ray Robson keeping his
composure in a slightly worse position
holding half a point a draw has been
agreed and now the unicorns are only one
point away from ending this match and
York Meyer might do it all on his own
shall we take a look at that end game
let's go to the georgmeyer game because
it suddenly that was the it's winning
most it was the most equal end game we
could ever ask for and then now he's
just gonna King C5 he's gonna bring his
King in there's only one thing that uh
York that's not bardia on the camera but
uh we will fix that soon but King to C5
uh is just what's black gonna do black
has to shuffle Rook F6 Rook G6 and so on
uh but uh maybe white will be able to
inch that kick forward
the ultimate you know sad irony uh would
be if Paulina manages to win and somehow
uh Leon squeezes the win out of that
Rook end game and it's bardia danishvar
who ends up losing what seemed like an
unusable game just a couple moves ago
the ultimate damning sign Robert dork
Meyer has just declined a draw he knows
that this is a winning end game he might
have gone into this game with the
intention of making a draw but he's not
just going to throw a win out uh into
the trash can if it's right there for
the taking he's not risking he can push
F4 the one thing he should not do is
play King into T6 and blunder into E5
check right that's such an easy blunder
to make especially if he didn't have
enough time he does though because King
D6 you can show them the board we'll go
right back
E5 with check and The Rook is behind the
king you're losing your material there
so what he needs to do somehow York
Meyer is he's has to remove his Rook
from C6 but if you go for a B6 check
then there's King C7 and if you go k6
well the king can go back to B7 right
like you just keep following this Rook
around and eventually F4 so F4 might
have been the correct sequence there but
that's why you're saying white should
start with F4 just to eliminate that
possibility that active break for black
it's not over yet the party I can go
Rook G4 we know how Rook end games can
be the the computer can give plus five
or plus six because it sees to the end
of the line but that could be very
misleading because a single wrong move
could send the evaluation right back
down to equality so work still to be
done for georgmeyer the result of this
game could ultimately be a moot point
but uh dorg needs to try to bag this up
and win this game because Leon levage is
still trying I don't think he's going to
be able to win his game though so at
this point I draw might be all your
needs and you're you know he could play
the move F4 right now yeah well the
black just I should have played it yeah
like had that opportunity that was that
was the one chance that bardia had now
white should play F4 black is completely
Frozen it's gonna be like a zoo song and
then the Rook will go to A6 and back
down the a file the king will slide the
D6 so it looks like Jurg Meyer is going
to secure the match victory for the
unicorns now I have full faith in him
and F4 has been played and they might
even go lossless in this round I mean
everybody seems to be coming through
with a clutch performance Darrow is
about to secure a draw he is repeating
moves he's actually better uh in this
Rook end game that he's got but there's
absolutely no need for him to risk it I
think they're about to repeat moves and
at that point the unicorns will be a
mere half point away from match victory
yeah the drug was just agreed in lay on
the virus against Darius spearch which
means it's officially eight to six in
favor of the unicorns the top right game
is done the scoreboard will reflect that
as it now has that was quick and it's
eight to six only one draw needed for
the Unicorn so georgmeyer if he doesn't
feel like winning he can just offer a
draw at any moment but he's risking zero
he can just win this game on his own
he absolutely can now with the world
team championship which is an over the
board event your team captain is allowed
to inform you uh in the event of a draw
for what the team score is and is
allowed to share his opinion I'm not
sure what the rules are here but again
it literally does not matter because the
only two things that will save the
Bulldogs right now are a mouse slip and
an internet outage and both are
vanishingly unlikely it does appear that
Paulina has gained the upper hand but
unfortunately that is not going to
matter no because Georg Meyer has this
one he can make a draw at any moment but
now he's gonna bring his King into D6
he's going to take on E6 and I like to
say a pawn chain is only as strong as
his base Pawn uh the E6 Pawn was
defending both right we have one face
Pawn we have uh the mutual
um you know goal posts for uh both sides
here that pawn structure
but now it's all gone
yeah I mean uh Harrison bunker right
here on E3 gonna send it right through
the middle after white eliminates both
the remaining pawns it really hurts
doesn't it
yeah truth hurts too uh but F5 D5 all of
them are going down and then all what
you need to do is stop this past h-bond
maybe easier said than done because H4
h3h2 but the white row can always slide
back to B2 to
grab that pawn
I've been on a roll not asking you if
you understood my puns but this time I
really feel like that question was
necessary I'm gonna be honest I I know
who Jalen hurts is and I was gonna you
know specify but after the butt Curt you
know reference and then Jalen hurt
reference I thought we might be in the
wrong broadcast maybe we should go to uh
replace Tony Romo or replace Greg Olsen
like Tom Brady just did
well I'd give you uh a buck if you did
that but Rook C3 check York Meyer is
going to get more than a buck for this
Victory because he is going to secure a
huge first round win for the unicorns
it's purely cosmetic at this point
Robert it doesn't matter this game is a
draw or a win it doesn't matter which
Pawn he takes just don't allow that H
Pawn to promote and you're good
that would be a shame we've already seen
one Pawn that could have promoted get
snatched by the enemy pieces and no this
one this seriously is very little that
RDA can do and you can see it he's just
hoping that jorg makes a mistake but
Georg is the end game Wizard he just
knows how to get it done he's under a
minute he's also really good at bullet
but I've learned my lesson at this point
I mean you count the eggs and they've
hatched we've literally seen everything
happen in the span of a week whatever
crazy finale you could think of it has
happened this week a mouse slip in the
most improbable circumstance happened
internet outage happens losing a
completely winning position happens I
mean the PCL is crazy Robert and this is
just week one so we're waiting we're
holding our breath cost is holding his
breath let me tell you that for sure
well of course yeah he you know he knows
that you're only need to draw so he
probably is breathing a little bit more
easily and well joke brings his King
back look at that he doesn't even go for
uh advancing his own pawns just yet he's
going for the enemy passer and it looks
like Paulina shuvalova did win her game
she was up I can't even count how many
Pawns in that final position but York
he's getting it done for the Unicorn
and what crazy how narrow these margins
of Victory are if Bogdan had promoted
that pawn right the match would have
already been tied and then imagine if
Leon levage had held that dead drawn end
game against Ray Robson of course you
can't think like that because the
unicorns missed some chances as well but
it's just crazy how these matches really
can go either way I think the PCL this
year does such a good job of ensuring
that most of these rosters they might be
composed completely differently the
strategies of assembly of the sea might
be different but almost all of these
matches have been so so so competitive
yes and you see chess twins saying
jurgmire knows how to handle his PCL
stuff it's true I feel like his best
chess is played in these team formats
and jorgas had a full-time job
throughout his chess career he does not
solely focus on chess oftentimes in the
Pro chess League seasons pass you'd be
coming back from his job to go sit up
and play in the league he is now up two
pawns his King wants to go to E5 doesn't
even have to resignation occurs that is
match victory for the California
unicorns York Meyer in an end game that
is a sentence I think I've said eight
million times
well this is the 8 millionth and first
georgmeyer secures Victory but all
credit to Ray Robson for holding with
black Daria schmirtz for holding with
black it did look precarious for just a
moment but at the end of the day the
California unicorns they have been a
Mainstay in one form or another ever
since the U.S the protest League was the
U.S chess league and they win another
inaugural matchup tying the final round
and ending the match in style
they did Ray Robson held as you
mentioned with the black pieces against
Bogue Don Daniel and that allowed them
to tie the final mesh two to two they
only need one and a half points they
scored two full ones and so for the
unicorns they win this match their top
score for the match I mean it was really
kind of a balanced effort for the most
part some Saves by various players uh
but Dania garrickmeyer he feels like the
hero that led the California unicorns
victory
yeah he's just such a reassuring
character such an asset to your team you
called it first and the Croatia Bulldogs
they have bright spots the teams that
lose week one they have to avoid having
a meltdown and overstating the case it
was close Mark Dia danishvar is a huge
addition to the Bulldogs obviously Leon
levage he will have to step it up in
weeks to come Belinda shavalova did
great as well it was very very close but
at the end of the day the team from
California I mean if Rey and Georg can
continue to play like they did today
they are going to be a force to be
reckoned with and let's not forget they
also have cash and Sam Shanklin and Ilia
niznik and others that can join the
lineup so they win this week nine to
seven a great match victory for the
California unicorns and we're actually
going to hear from their top board Ray
Robson so we're gonna take a short break
get Ray on the call and we'll interview
to hear his thoughts about his team's
Victory here against the Croatia
Bulldogs we'll be right back it's the
protest
[Music]
thank you
foreign
to our new video lecture series here
with the one and only the 14th World
chess champion vishwanathon and on if
you have to explain that your world
champion and it's taking longer than two
words there's something wrong with your
adventure there's something wrong but I
believe in when we're talking the 60s
and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um uh we got to grab this chance with
both hands because it's not going to
come by way
foreign
[Music]
what's up
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and we are joined by super Grandmaster
Ray Robson Ray congratulations for your
success and your team's victory for the
California unicorns my first question
for you is how does it feel to be back
in the Pro chess league and with a new
Squad
thanks Robert yeah it feels good um yeah
I used to play on the Webster windmills
for several years uh which was a lot of
fun and last year uh previously I played
also for Chicago win but yeah it's a
completely new team I really like our
team this year and um yeah first match
went really well
Ray was a topsy-turvy affair for you
today but ultimately you came out strong
and defeatedly on leviage in a crucial
game would you point to that as the
proudest moment of your performance
today after losing a painful game in
round two
yeah I definitely wouldn't say it was it
wasn't the best game but for the
my contribution to the match I guess it
was the the most important game
obviously I lost that round two game
where I was doing quite well but um I
missed a few things and then my opponent
was super tricky with his Knight um the
end of the game and yeah in round three
I think I also had a good position but
again I kind of messed things up but the
difference was compared to game two I
had more time than my opponent and so I
was able to keep some pressure on him
that way and in the rook and game
um I tried to create some campus
obviously he was still holding but as
though they get to win and yeah
well Ray you recently crossed 2700 So I
have to congratulate you for that as
well in classical chess uh but I guess
my question is about that now that
you're above that super Grand Master
threshold you're playing board one for
your team is that what added pressure on
you do you feel like you have to play
for results rather than just play the
board
uh a little bit
um but in general I just tried to
play normally
um I mean that's what got me to 2700 In
classical so I guess I should try to do
the same in Rapid as well and just hope
that it works out um yeah one of the
things is my repertoire especially with
black and classical is usually super
solid so sometimes it doesn't translate
so well to beating low rated players
um so that is something I'm a little bit
concerned about I'll have to maybe
change some openings but um for the most
part I just play it normally and today
it worked out pretty well
Ray you have a lot more team experience
than most players even more Grandmasters
you have played on the US Olympiad team
would you say that your experience in
the Olympiad of the world team
championship helps you manage the stress
of these events better than uh for some
less experienced Grandmasters
yeah for sure I mean it was also really
good that I got to have some of those
experiences when I was a bit younger
um I don't know I feel like that that
helps in a way to have those experiences
um kind of when you're growing up and
then
yeah I guess it's
you know nothing can really compare to
like playing in the Olympiad or
um the world team championship so
compared to those there's obviously I
feel a little a little bit less pressure
also just in general I'm I'm more
relaxed I think about
um
yeah online chess um even just chess and
general compared to when I was a kid
where I used to be really competitive
really hard on myself if I lost any game
at all in any format even if it was just
casual now I'm I learned to deal with it
a little bit better so
yeah
I I wasn't going too crazy but uh
yeah there has to be a balance I guess
sometimes you can just not care you can
care too little and then that also
detracts from your game so I try to find
the balance
um it was also the first week today so
first time playing protest league for me
in a while so I'm just trying to get
back into the group of things
yeah it's good to hear Ray that a
relaxed Ray Robson is maybe the best of
Ray Robson and I do want to get a
question from the chat from chess wind
uh their question is as a puzzles
Champion do you feel your pattern
recognition knowledge impacts your
intuitive decision on the board
yeah I saw Daniel was playing a lot of
Puzzle Battle uh last night he was
having some really exciting matches
um yeah I don't I don't know there's
definitely like specific patterns that
I've seen a lot so I guess I might
recognize those faster but in some sense
I don't know
like if you play a bunch of Puzzle
Battle and then you like go back to
Blitz or something your mind is kind of
focused on finding that the specific
patterns which doesn't really actually
happen that often in in real games so
um yeah there's a couple
patterns I've probably recognized
quicker than I used to these days but
um in general I don't think it makes a
huge difference
well I knew the puzzle battle King was
watching so I felt that I had to perform
array final question for me several
people in the chat were pointing out
that you hit 2700 uh I think for the
first time after the US Championship
what does it mean for you to hit that
Milestone is it particularly meaningful
to hit super Grand Master status and do
you sort of feel appreciably different
having hit this huge rating
um
it definitely was a big goal of mine
um other big goal was to someday win the
US Championship which is obviously keeps
getting stronger so that's going to be
even much more difficult I guess
um I I'm sure you guys know that like
you know you all have goals growing up
and you achieve when you achieve them it
feels really good but then it's kind of
like what happens next okay I achieve
this thing but like you know why did it
didn't change that much in my actual
life so it feels nice
um but for me I just focus on trying to
keep going up
um that's the thing it's it's kind of a
no man's land where I'm in right now
where I have to gain like still another
30 35 points probably to get invited to
the next like upper class of tournaments
which um I don't get invited to
um so that's that's really really
difficult still at this level so I guess
that's that's my
other main focus for now is just try to
improve see if I can get close to
reaching that level and get some invites
to Elite tournaments I mean it's going
to be really really hard but that's my
goal and yeah still enjoying 2700 I
haven't haven't played since the US
Championship so you know I'm just
sitting on my rating but I'll be fine
again soon
yeah I mean Ray interestingly I feel
like a lot of people see your name you
thrive and then you kind of go into
hibernation for a while so you haven't
played since the US Championship one is
that something you enjoy doing just
playing chess kind of less frequently
and two what is your next over the board
tournament where can we find you playing
yeah I do definitely play less than most
people
um I don't know I guess maybe it started
like when I started college because
they're basically play one or two events
for the college team and then maybe a
couple events in the summer but really I
was only playing like five tournaments
per year and even since I finished I
haven't really been playing finished
College I haven't been playing that much
more
um I guess I do like Choosing My
tournaments very selectively
um obviously there's a lot of really
strong open tournaments in the US but if
I were to play those I would still
probably be the first or second highest
rated player and
um I just don't feel like that would be
that great for my career right now so
I'm pretty selective about tournaments I
choose and yeah my next tournament is
going to be American Cup where
um it's a double elimination tournament
with eight players
um if the top eight players basically
from the US so it depends on Whose
rating is going to be higher I'm going
to play the I think I'm either gonna
play Fabiano or Wesley depending on how
Wesley's rating changes in this
tournament that he's playing right now
got it well Ray we look forward to
watching you at the American Cup and
cementing your super Grand Master status
definitely the MVP of today's match
congratulations on a first round Victory
and uh get some rest good job today Ray
thanks guys
congrats Ray
well that was Ray Robson he is leading
the California unicorns the last team to
score in opening week Victory these are
the eight teams that have won their
first match so done it as you look from
top to bottom you see teams that you
think are definitely going to make the
playoffs
well it's so hard to say the one thing I
learned from week one is that it is
impossible to predict the kind of
skeletal form of the hypothetical
winning team Robert because the rosters
are so different and as we talked about
at the start of the broadcast the
strategies adopted by the managers and
captains as they try to recruit players
is totally different obviously the
Canada chess bras they're the favorites
with Magnus Carlson one could argue but
some of the evenly matched teams like
the Shanghai tigers that we saw today
are going to make a serious run to the
top as well but even some of the teams
that have lost uh their first round
matchup we saw how close these matches
were and I've repeated this phrase
throughout this week I'm going to say it
one last time as we tie up the week and
start the weekend nothing has been
decided
and Daniel when I look at the oh and one
team the teams that lost their first
matchup I think the team that I have to
circle is a Saint Louis Archbishop
that's surprising to see them there but
with Fabiana carwana on their roster you
have to imagine they have the best
chance of anyone on that uh on this
listing except maybe the Charlotte
cobras and I have to say that because
you're helping me
hey I really appreciate it well we're
ending the commentary anyways so now's
your opportunity to be mean but in all
seriousness I mean you look at some of
these teams Spanish Maniac shrimps could
have easily been one and oh Brazil copy
bar as they got blown out in week one
but they have an incredibly strong team
I mean nobody on my team is happy that
we are facing them next week uh and they
are absolutely formidable same with the
Berlin bears with Joseph and heinemann
scoring a victory over Hikaru Nakamura
so so many of these teams are going to
go for Redemption Robert and these
aren't empty words I mean the match
scores throughout this week really prove
the fact that the PCL has succeeded in
creating a league where you can
essentially root for any team and almost
every team has a serious shot at the top
they have a shot there's a lot of Team
camaraderie there's preparation done
between the players and well we just saw
the standings we saw the teams that won
their first match the teams that lost
that's going to dictate the pairings for
next week you have the weekend off from
the protest League but on Tuesday the
matches continue and we will see a pair
of winning teams the chess bras from
Canada versus the Indian yogis and then
we'll also see in the second half of
double header the Brazil capybara is
facing your Charlotte Cobra so a quick
thought on these matchups Tanya who's
most likely to go to 2-0 and if you're
giving your honest assessment who's most
likely to drop to oh and two well I will
recuse myself from this conversation
listen here in Charlotte we're hungry
because we felt that we had a very
serious chance uh to score what would
have been an epic upset had the final
round gone our way and from the chest
spot perspective they dodged a major
bullet Magnus Carlson showed that he is
going to carry this team forward and if
his Supporting Cast comes along for the
ride rosvan priyoto and others Aryan
tari if they score half a point or a
point more they're just going to be
completely Unstoppable given magnus's
rapid form in recent months so would
love to watch that one Indian yogis they
scored a blowout win so two powerhouses
right there and for the Capybaras they
are going to try to erase the memory of
their week one loss but we are going to
try to prevent them from doing that and
put in front of them a fresh set of
painful memories we shall see Robert
I appreciate the non-answer there
because I did ask you you know who is
most likely to win the matchups yes yes
yes yes yes you took the Diplomatic
route I have to uh you know tip my
proverbial cap to you for that and just
thank you for what was a very fun last
about five plus hours so it flew by
these matches are always entertaining
exciting Good chess and sometimes
they're blunders in time travel like we
saw down the stretch of that Bogue Don
Daniel Day Out game against Darius
spirits but done at any sort of final
thoughts about the two matches we saw
today in the protest league and what we
should look forward to next week
well the matches were fascinating and
Robert always such a pleasure to cover
them with you these five hours did
indeed fly by and I will just close uh
by making a more broad point that what
makes the pro chess league so
fascinating isn't just the competitive
element itself which already uh creates
entertainment value it's there's so many
different perspectives from which you
can watch the PCL from an instructor
perspective with a lot of players just
playing some really interesting opening
preparation lines that you can use in
your Blitz Games as you try to improve
finding new players to root for 2600
players even some IMS who have very
bright features ahead of them or really
making their debut in front of most
chess fans and obviously rooting for
your home City rooting for your favorite
player so many reasons to watch the PCL
and block off five hours throughout the
week we are in for two more months three
more months Robert of a Non-Stop
entertainment I can't wait and I'm so
excited to be both playing and
commentating
I can't wait either but we'll have to
wait until Tuesday I just want to thank
all of our viewers it's so great of you
to show your support to enjoy your
Fridays with us our producer big would
work so hard behind the scenes Judith
and the rest of the chess.com staff
making sure the players are set and
settled and can just focus on the board
but thank you to everybody who makes the
protest say what it is the action will
only get better as we return on Tuesday
I'll have the call to Tanya Sacha
whether you're watching Canada from
India or anywhere else in the world
continue watching the protest League
we'll see you on Tuesday
foreign
[Music]